GOOD AFTERNOON WELCOME BACK TO
SUBCOMMITTEE FOUR ON STATE
ADMINISTRATION WITH THE
PACKAGING TODAY. COLLECTIBLE
ITEMS WANTING TO ADD ITEMS TO BE
HEARD AND WITH LISTA ABLE TWENTY
FOURTH HEARING. ROLE RIGHT NOW
WE DON'T HAVE A.
QUORUM CIVIL STARS A COMMITTEE
TO RESTORE OFF ON ISSUENUMBER
FOUR OF THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE OF
BUSINESS AND ECONOMIC
<c.blue&gt;EVELOPMENT.</c&gt;
CALIFORNIA PIECE TAX CREDIT FOR
HIM EXTENSION TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE
WE FORGET WE START WITH YOU
FIRST. YOUR WORKS.
GOOD AFTERNOON I'M WILL COOK FOR
THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE OF
BUSINESS AND ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT
WHICH ISSUE DID YOU WANT TO
START WITH TODAY.
.
FOUR FOUR FORTY BEATS GREAT.
OKAY.
THANK YOU CHAIR COOPER COMMIT
MEMBERS OUR MONEY WAS WELL
COOKED THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE OF
BUSINESS AND ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT.
IS A PLEASURE TO BE HERE TODAY
PERCENT ISSUE NUMBER FOUR WHICH
IS THE ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSAL
TO EXTEND THE CALIFORNIA
COMPETES TAX CREDIT.
TO GIVE YOU A LITTLE HISTORY
ABOUT THE PROGRAM WAS PART OF
THE GOVERNOR'S ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT INITIATIVE TWENTY
THIRTEEN.
IN WHICH THE OLD ENTERPRISE ZONE
PROGRAM WAS REPLACED WITH THREE
NEW TOOLS FOR ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT.
ONE OF WHICH BEING A PARTIAL
SALES TAX EXEMPTION FOR
MANUFACTURING IN RESEARCH AND
DEVELOPMENT.
THE SECOND BEING A
GEOGRAPHICALLY TARGETED HIRING
CREDIT AND THE THIRD BEING THE
CALIFORNIA COMPETES TAX CREDIT.
WHICH WAS CREATED TO BE A TOOL
FOR. A TO HELP ENCOURAGE
BUSINESSES TO LOCATE OR EXPAND
IN CALIFORNIA.
UNDER CURRENT LAW ARE
AUTHORIZATION TO AWARD
CALIFORNIA COMPETES TAX CREDITS.
ENDS ON JUNE THIRTIETH OF THIS
YEAR.
OUR PROPOSAL WOULD DO THE
FOLLOWING.
EXTEND THE CALIFORNIA COMPETES
TAX CREDIT FOR FIVE FISCAL YEARS
THROUGH FISCAL YEAR TWENTY TWO
TWENTY THREE.
PROVIDE TAX CUT ALLOCATION FORTY
OF ONE HUNDRED EIGHTY MILLION
PER FISCAL YEAR.
PROVIDE ROUGHLY ONE POINT FOUR
MILLION IN BUDGET AUTHORITY EACH
YEAR TO SUPPORT OUR EXISTING TEN
POSITIONS TO ADMINISTER THE
PROGRAM.
AND MAKES STATUTORY CHANGES TO
IMPROVE THE EFFECTIVENESS OF THE
PROGRAM.
THANK YOU I WOULD BE HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS THAT YOU
MAY HAVE.
THANK YOU FINANCE.
GOOD AFTERNOON JAY CHAIRMAN THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE A WE
SUPPORT THIS PROPOSAL WE THINK.
.
WE WE THINK IT TAKES WHAT HAS
BEEN A SUCCESSFUL PROGRAM IN
MAKES A MAKE SOME IMPORTANT
CHANGES.
VOWED TO.
TO MAKE IT EASIER FOR.
FOR GOBIZ TO.
ALLOCATE CREDITS THAT ARE.
BETTER MEETING THE GOALS OF THE
OF THE PROGRAM.
MEN AND WE'VE WE'VE NARROWED
THE GOALS.
IN THIS IN STATUTORY LANGUAGE
TO A TO GIVE THEM ADDITIONAL
FORTY TO MAKE SURE THAT THE
CREDITS ARE.
I'M GOING TO BUSINESSES THAT ARE
ON.
WHERE THE CREDIT IS ACTUALLY
MAKE A DIFFERENCE AND?
IN THE.
WHERE THE JOBS ARE LOCATED?
LL.
BRAIN WITH THE FORD WITH
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE.
IN FEBRUARY POSTS ARE FULL
COMMENTS ON THE MINISTRATIONS
CALIFORNIA COMPETES PROPOSAL SO
QUICKLY SUMMARIZE THEM. SOME WE
RECOMMENDED A REJECTING THE
ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSAL
BECAUSE IT DOESN'T EFFECTIVELY
ADDRESS OUR CONCERNS ABOUT THE
NUMBER OF PREFERENTIAL TAX
CREDITS TO HAVE BEEN AWARDED TO
WHAT WE CALL. NON TRIBBLE
BUSINESSES OF THOSE ARE
BUSINESSES THAT INHERENTLY SO
GOODS AND SERVICES TO THEIR
CUSTOMERS IN A LOCAL AREA AND SO
THEY'RE NOT. THE COMPETING ONLY
WITH OTHER CALIFORNIA BUSINESS
NOT NECESSARILY.
NATIONALLY INTERNATIONALLY AND.
SOME.
SMALL ACCOUNTING BUSINESSES
DOCTORS AND A WHOLE RANGE OF
COMMERCIAL AND RESIDENTIAL
BUILDING CONTRACTORS
SUCH AS PLUMBERS AND GARAGE DOOR
INSTALLERS.
FURTHER A WE THINK THAT SMALL
BUSINESSES ARE PROBABLY AMONG
THOSE THAT ARE MOST LIKELY HARM
TO BUY A WORD SCUFF REPEATS
WORDS TO COMPETING ON TRADE WILL
BUSINESSES.
WE DIFFERENTIATE THESE FROM
TRADABLE BUSINESSES THAT PROVIDE
SERVICES OR MAKE GOODS THAT THEY
SELL CLIENTS CUSTOMERS ALL OVER
THE COUNTRY.
WE'RE ALL OVER THE WORLD.
IN THOSE INCLUDE MANUFACTURER
SOFTWARE COMPANIES DISTRIBUTION
WAREHOUSES THAT SERVE MULTIPLE
STATE SO.
IN OUR QUICK.
IT WELL IN OUR.
ANALYSIS OF THE.
THE SEVEN HUNDRED AND SEVENTY
FIVE WORDS HAVE BEEN MADE
THROUGH NOVEMBER ABOUT FOUR
HUNDRED SEVENTY EIGHT SO MOST OF
THEM WERE MADE TO TRADE WILL
BUSINESSES. THE NEARLY THREE
HUNDRED ROOMIE TO NON TRADABLE
BUSINESSES AND SO IF THE
LEGISLATURE CHOOSES TO EXTEND
CALIFORNIA COMPETES WE THINK WE
MADE MORE EFFECTIVE IF YOU ADD
LANGUAGE THAT CLEARLY EXPRESSES
THE INTENT OF THE PROGRAM. TO
ATTRACT AND RETAIN CALIFORNIA
EMPLOYERS THAT SOUTHERN GOODS
AND SERVICES REGIONALLY
NATIONALLY AND INTERNATIONALLY.
THE NOT JUST TO.
CONSUMERS AND BUSINESSES WITHIN
CALIFORNIA. AT THE SAME TIME
RECOMMEND DELETING THOSE
PROVISIONS WITHIN THE LAW THE
DESTRUCTIVE IS TO CONSIDER OTHER
FACTORS THAT ARE NOT DIRECTLY
TIED TO THE CENTER.
ALSO IF THERE'S OTHER POLICY
GOALS THAT ARE OF INTEREST TO
LEGISLATURE. ON ANOTHER PROGRAM.
IN A NOT WE KNOW HOW TO WIN IN
MIND HELP INCREASE MAY NOT BE
THE BEST PROGRAM. TO TO ACHIEVE
OTHER POLICY GOALS NECESSARILY.
SO ON.
COME RIGHT NOW THE STATE'S
TRYING TO PICK AND CHOOSE FROM
AMONG VARIOUS BUSINESSES THAT
ARE WHERE THE PROGRAM IN APPLY
TO IT.
AND AND IT'S.
CREATING DISCREPANCIES AN
UNFAIR TAX TREATMENT BETWEEN
DIFFERENT BUSINESSES WITHIN THE
STATE. AND SO.
.
DID WANT TO COMMENT THAT.
WERE FOUND LOOKING TO
UNDERSTAND THE DETAILS OF THE
MINISTRATIONS TWENTY MILLION
DOLLAR PROPOSAL FOR TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE TO SMALL BUSINESSES
BUT WE DO SUPPORT. ELIMINATING
THE SMALL BUSINESS SET ASIDE
BECAUSE THE LOT OF THOSE CREDITS
WHEN ACTUALLY BEING USED BY
SMALL BUSINESSES. AND.
SOMETHING THAT MORE DIRECTLY
AFFECTS A MUCH LARGER NUMBER
SMALL BUSINESSES WOULD BE THAT.
IF ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE.
THE ONLY ONE HERE. AYE SYRIA TO
MEMBERS.
THE ON SITE.
OKAY ONLY GOING UP LOOKS UP THE
PUBLIC COMMENT ANYONE WISH TO
SPEAK ON THIS ITEM.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN ALICE
KESSLER HERE ON BEHALF OF THE
CITY OF LONG BEACH WERE IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THE PROPOSAL
TO EXTEND. THE CALIFORNIA
COMPETES TAX CREDIT PROGRAM.
IT'S A VITAL TOOL FOR THE
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT OF THE
STATE THAT SOMETHING THAT THE
CITY OF LONG BEACH HAS TAKEN
ADVANTAGE OF ON AT LEAST SEVEN
BUSINESSES. IN THE CITY HAVE
BENEFITTED FROM THE PROGRAM SO
WE URGE YOUR SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
WHO ELSE MOTIONS BEGIN THIS
AUTUMN?
HI MY NAME IS MARIE DAVIS WHAT
THE GREATER SACRAMENTO ECONOMIC
COUNCIL.
I'M HERE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF
CAL COMPETES RENEWAL.
IT'S BEEN PIVOTAL FOR US AND WE
APPRECIATE GO BUSINESS EFFORTS
SO FAR THINKS.
YOU THINK YOU.
YOU'RE PUTTING SPEAKING PLEASE A
LINE UP AND IF YOU.
WITH ANYBODY ELSE.
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON TERRITORY CAMERA
REPRESENTING SMALL BUSINESS
CALIFORNIA.
REPRESENTING FIVE THOUSAND
SMALL BUSINESSES IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU.
WE'RE GOING CLOSE PUBLIC COMMENT
THE RECOMMENDATIONS TO HOLD
SADDAM OPUS HOLD OPEN.
MOVE ON TO OUR NEXT ITEM WHICH
IS ITEM NUMBER FIVE. TELL FOR
SMALL BUSINESS DEVELOPMENT
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE EXPANSION
PROGRAM AND TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE.
TRY FINANCE NEARLY ALL MOVE UP
PLEASE TO THE.
DIAZ PARADISE.
CAN FINANCE ILLEGAL MOVE UP TO
DICE PLEASE.
BECAUSE OF APPEARED.
YOU MISTER CHAIR
I POTTERY AB AS THE DIRECTOR OF
THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE OF
BUSINESS AND ECONOMIC.
DEVELOPMENT.
SO ISSUE NUMBER FIVE BEFORE YOU
TODAY IS A REQUEST TO PROVIDE A
TWENTY MILLION DOLLAR
APPROPRIATION TO GOBIZ EACH YEAR
FOR THE NEXT FIVE YEARS.
TO EXPAND THE CAPACITY OF OUR
FEDERALLY DESIGNATED SMALL
BUSINESS ASSISTANCE HONORS.
THREE MILLION PER YEAR WILL GO
TO THE SMALL BUSINESS
DEVELOPMENT CENTERS.
TO MAINTAIN THE LEVEL OF STATE
MATCHING FUNDS FROM LAST YEAR'S
BUDGET.
AND THE REMAINING SEVENTEEN
MILLION PER YEAR WILL BE
AVAILABLE ON A COMPETITIVE BASIS
TO PROVIDING FUNDING. TO
FEDERALLY DESIGNATED TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE CENTERS WHICH
INCLUDES THE SPD SEIZE. THE
VETERANS BUSINESS CENTERS WOMEN
BUSINESS OWNERS OF MINORITY
BUSINESS OWNERS SO I HAVE MY
COLLEAGUE JUST THE TORIES HERE
WHO IS THE US STATES SMALL
BUSINESS ADVOCATE TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS YOU MAY HOW BUT FIRST
I'D LIKE TO. THANK OF ONLY
MEMBERS QUIRK SILVA AND
CERVANTES FOR THEIR LEADERSHIP
THEIR BILL A. B. TWENTY FOUR
SIXTY THREE REALLY SERVED AS THE
FRAMEWORK FOR OUR TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE.
WELL YOU'RE WELCOME.
YEAH UP BUT I THINK YOU FOR
ALLOWING US TO SPEAK TODAY
MISTER CHAIR AND AS THE CHAIR OF
THE ASSEMBLY. COMMITTEE ON JOBS
AND ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT AND THE
ECONOMY I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR SUPPORT OF THE TWENTY
MILLION. DOLLAR APPROPRIATION
FOR SMALL BUSINESS TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE
THIS APPROPRIATION WILL BE USED
TO CAPITALIZE ON EXISTING AND
NEW SMALL BUSINESS ASSISTANCE
PROGRAMS.
KEY ELEMENTS OF THE NEW PROGRAM
ARE OUTLINED IN BOTH THE GOBIZ I
AND IN AB TWENTY FOUR SIXTY
THREE. UP WHICH IS US SPONSORED
BY GOBIZ
AND THIS TWENTY MILLION DOLLARS
WILL BE PROVIDED THROUGH GRANTS
TO SMALL BUSINESS DEVELOPMENT
CENTERS AND OTHER FEDERALLY
DESIGNATED SMALL BUSINESS
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE CENTERS.
I DO WANT TO.
MAKE ONE COMMENT THAT WE WE ARE
LOOKING FOR A LITTLE BIT OF
FLEXIBILITY ON IN THIS
ALLOCATION AYE AND ONE OF A
RECOMMENDATION WE HAVE AYE IS ON
A KIND OF PROBE. OF KIND OF
PROGRAMMING AND HOW THIS WOULD
BE ALLOCATED IS THAT. WE WOULD
LIKE TO SEE THE LANGUAGE AYE IN
THE BCP.
WE THINK THAT IT CAN BE A
LITTLE BIT TO A LIMITED AND WE
ALSO WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT IT'S
NOT TOO NARROW. SO WITH THAT WE
WOULD LIKE TO SEE A LITTLE BIT
BROADER FOCUS FRAMED WITHIN THE
CONTEXT OF MAKING SURE THERE'S
AN ADDED VALUE ONTO SMALL
BUSINESSES AND ALSO. ADD THAT WE
MAKE SURE THAT WE UNDERSTAND
EXACTLY. WHAT I?
IS GOING TO BE OF WHAT IS THE
RESULT OF THE FUNDS AND REALLY
KIND OF THING COUNT. PART OF
THAT.
WE WANNA MAKE SURE IT'S CAN BE
AYE QUANTIFIED AS FAR AS I KNOW
WHEN WE MAKE THESE INVESTMENTS
FROM THE STATE. ON.
BUT I THINK ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT WE KNOW FOR SURE IS THAT.
.
WE HAVE SEEN MUCH ENTHUSIASM
FROM OF THIS PROGRAM AND WE WANT
TO MAKE SURE JUST WITH A LITTLE
BIT MORE FLEXIBILITY WE CAN.
IMPROVE IT EVEN MORE SO WITH
THAT THAT WE JUST WANT TO
CONTINUE TO ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT
ON THIS INVESTMENT OF TWENTY
MILLION DOLLARS FOR OUR SMALL
BUSINESSES THANK YOU THANK YOU.
WITH WITH THIS THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR I AM GRATEFUL FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
OF THE PROPOSED TWENTY MILLION
DOLLARS I'D A PREPARATION FOR
SMALL BUSINESS TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE. ALONGSIDE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER SHARON QUIRK SILVA WE
HAVE BEEN WORKING ON EXPANDING
RESOURCES FOR OUR SMALL BUSINESS
COMMUNITY FOR SOME TIME. AS WE
KNOW SMALL BUSINESSES ARE TRULY
THE BACKBONE OF THE CALIFORNIA
ECONOMY THAT IS ESPECIALLY TRUE
IN THE REGION THAT I REPRESENT.
THE INLAND EMPIRE IS TRULY AN
ECONOMIC FORCE AS ONE OF THE
FASTEST GROWING REGIONS WITH
OVER ONE HUNDRED THOUSAND SMALL
BUSINESSES. AND I KNOW THAT DOT
THE UNIQUE CHALLENGES A SMALL
BUSINESSES SPACE IN MY REGION
ARE ALSO SHARED EXPERIENCES
THROUGHOUT THE STATE. AYE MANY
OF OUR ENTREPRENEURS PUT THEIR
HEART AND SOUL INTO THE SUCCESS
OF THEIR SMALL BUSINESS
OFTENTIMES MISSING A CRITICAL
FAMILY MOMENTS SUCH AS MAY BE
MISSING SOCCER GAMES ARE FAMILY
TIME AROUND THE DINNER TABLE. AS
DIFFICULT AS OPENING A SMALL
BUSINESS MAY BE THE SMALL
BUSINESSES SPUR A SENSE OF
CAMARADERIE TRADITIONS LIFE
LESSONS THAT ARE YOU THAT ARE
UNIQUE CONNECTS TO OUR
COMMUNITIES ACROSS THE STATE.
WITH THE PROPOSED DOLLARS ADD
THAT THIS PROPOSAL SEEKS TO
OBTAIN THE STATE WILL CONTINUE
TO SUPPORT SMALL BUSINESSES
THEIR FAMILIES AND ALTERNATELY
ENHANCE THE ENTREPRENEUR SPIRIT.
THAT IS ALIVE AND WELL IN
CALIFORNIA AYE MISTER CHAIR IF
YOU'RE WONDERING IF THE TWENTY
MILLION DOLLARS FOR TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE IS NEEDED THE ANSWER
IS YES. AND I HAVE WITH US TODAY
TWO HUNDRED AND THIRTY LETTERS
FROM ON BEHALF OF TWO HUNDRED
AND FIFTY SIX ORGANIZATIONS ZERO
IN SUPPORT FOR THIS PROPOSAL
FROM ACROSS THE STATE. AND THEY
WOULD AGREE THAT THIS IS MUCH
NEEDED. I WANNA THINK GOBIZ I
WANT TO THANK OUR CHAIR OF THE
JOBS COMMITTEE FOR THEIR
LEADERSHIP AND CONTINUE SUPPORT
FOR SMALL BUSINESS COMMUNITY IN
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT. SO DO YOU EACH HAVE
TUNA PRETTY SIGNATURES
BUT IF YOU SPEAKERS LINED UP SO
IF YOU AGREE WITH THEM IT'S OKAY
TO SAY ME TOO ARE DEVELOPED.
YEAH.
AND I'LL BE QUICK ABOUT THEIR
FAVORITE BREVITY IS GREAT RIGHT
YES MY NAME IS. EXACTLY MY NAME
IS ROSS MCCARTY I IN THE ARM A
BOARD MEMBER FOR THE CALIFORNIA
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE I WANT TO
BRING TO THE ATTENTION THAT THE
LANGUAGE THAT IS PROPOSED IN
THIS PARTICULAR BILL. WHICH WE
WE SUPPORT ONE HUNDRED PERCENT
WITH GO A BIT AND JUST MAKING
SURE THE FOCUS THE SERVICING
WOMEN PRIZE OPPORTUNITY I WON I
THINK
OPEN IS NO I THINK OF ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS QUIRK SILVA AND
CERVANTES AND WE VERY MUCH
SUPPORT THIS BILL ARE VERY
EXCITED THAT THE STATE'S. MAKING
HISTORIC INVESTMENT.
MARY SELECIONE I'M HERE
REPRESENTING THE LARK TO
INSTITUTE AND I HAVE A QUESTION
SLASH OF REQUESTS FOR
CLARIFICATION ON INTENT. IN
THOUGH CRITERION FOR
APPLICATIONS THAT ARE APPLYING
FOR THE PROGRAM IT STATES THAT
AN APPLICANT MUST HAVE DRAWN
DOWN SUBSTANTIALLY ALL OF THEIR
FEDERAL FUNDING IN THE PREVIOUS
FISCAL YEAR. AND ESPECIALLY WITH
THE LARA INSTITUTE I WOULD LIKE
TO POINT OUT THAT. A SIGN OF
MANY DIFFERENT FUNDING SOURCES
IS THE SIGN OF A A HOPE THE
PROGRAM AND CONTINUOUS SERVICE
THAT SOMEBODY LIKE CLARK HAD
INSTITUTE HAS PROVIDED FOR
TWENTY FIVE YEARS.
AND IF WE ARE REQUIRED TO DRAW
DOWN ALL OF OUR FEDERAL FUNDING
THEN WE WOULD BE SOLELY
DEPENDENT ON THIS PROGRAM FOR
FINANCIAL BACKING.
SO I WOULD REQUIRE AYE AYE LIKES
SEEK A LITTLE BIT MORE
CLARIFICATON ON THAT PIECE AND
SEE IF YOU WOULD CONSIDER. A
CHANGE NOT COMPONENT BUT
OTHERWISE WE ARE VERY SUPPORTIVE
OF THIS PROPOSAL.
SURE NATIONALLY THE LANGUAGE HAS
CURLY STATES IS THAT YOU CAN
BRIAN ACTION PLANNED INDICATES
HOW YOU'RE GOING TO DIVERSIFY
YOUR FUNDING SO YOU CAN BE NEAR
YOU KNOW FULLY FUNDED BUT STILL
ALLOW US WORD KIND CONSIDERATION
FOR THIS KIND ASPECTS.
BUT IF WE NEED TO LOOK AT MORE
ABOUT HOW THE FEDERAL PROGRAM
YOU HAVE OPERATES AND WHAT THE
MATTER CRIMES ARE BUT MILLION
WORKERS THAT WORK IN
THESE MANUFACTURING.
SCHMIDT SO WE STRONGLY SUPPORT
THIS.
WE'VE BEEN A STRONG PARTNER WITH
GOBIZ FOR MANY MANY YEARS.
AND.
AND AGAIN I WOULD LIKE TO GIVE
OUR WHOLEHEARTED SUPPORT TO THIS
PROGRAM THANK YOU THANK YOU.
HELLO I'M SHARON MILLER FROM
RENAISSANCE ENTREPRENEURSHIP
CENTER IN SAN FRANCISCO WE ARE
WOMEN'S BUSINESS CENTER WE HAVE
BEEN PROVIDING TRAINING AND
SUPPORT SERVICES TO WOMEN
THROUGH THIS PROGRAM FOR
NINETEEN YEARS.
WE SUPPORT PRIMARILY LOW INCOME
PEOPLE WOMEN AND OTHER PEOPLE TO
CUT THROUGH THE WOMEN'S BUSINESS
CENTER. TODAY THE FOCUS IS ON
THE WOMEN.
ENGLISH AND SPANISH SPEAKING
WOMEN WOMEN OF COLOR AND THOSE
WHO REALLY NEED THE SUPPORT TO
GROW THEIR OWN BUSINESSES. THEY
ARE SUCCEEDING THEY ARE CREATING
ECONOMIC MOBILITY AND MOST
IMPORTANTLY THEY'RE BUILDING
BETTER FUTURES FOR THEIR SELVES
AND THEIR FAMILIES THANK YOU.
IF YOU.
CHAIRMAN DAY BUTLER I'M HERE
REPRESENTING THE UNITED CHAMBER
ADVOCACY NETWORK WHICH IS A
COALITION OF FIVE A CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE.
ORGANIZATIONS HERE IN THE
GREATER SACRAMENTO MARKETPLACE
INCLUDING. A ELK GROVE.
OUR MEMBERS SIR.
DON'T MANAGE ANY THESE
CONTRACTS BUT THEY'RE MEMBERS OF
BENEFIT FROM THIS WORK.
SO WE'RE GENERALLY SUPPORT OF
THE LANGUAGE ESPECIALLY
APPRECIATIVE OF. A GOBIZ IN THE
ADMINISTRATION RECOGNIZING THE
IMPORTANCE OF SMALL BUSINESS
SUCCESS OUT TO THE OVERALL A
BUSINESS CLIMATE OF A
CALIFORNIA.
AND ALSO ESPECIALLY APPRECIATIVE
OF GOBIZ CHOOSING TO LEVERAGE
THE EXISTING INFRASTRUCTURE AND
EXPERTISE WITHIN THE SPDC AND
OTHER A PROVIDER NETWORKING
CALIFORNIA TO DELIVER IT.
THE SERVICES SO WE'RE GRATEFUL
FOR THAT AND HOPEFULLY THIS.
EXAMPLE OF PARTNERSHIP CAN BE
YOU AND LEVERAGING CAN BE
UTILIZED IN OTHER AGENCIES. ARE
IN THE STATE JUST COUPLE
CAUTIONS THE AND THREE MILLION
DOLLARS IS NOT.
WHAT THE SBDC NETWORK NEEDS TO
REALIZE IT'S A FULL FEDERAL
MATCH WHICH I THINK EVERYBODY
KNOWS HOPEFULLY THIS IS AT? A
DOWN PAYMENT AND THEN.
SECONDLY I'M JUST WANT TO MAKE
SURE THREE YEAR OVERSIGHT OF THE
COMMITTEE LEVEL AT THAT.
BUDGET COMMITTEE LEVEL THAT
YOU'RE LOOKING AT HOW THE FUNDS
ARE DISTRIBUTED AROUND THE
STATE.
SO THANK YOU.
BUT.
GOOD AFTERNOON I'M RACHEL FISHER
WITH THE US SAN DIEGO
PROCUREMENT TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
CENTER.
ARE OF CALIFORNIA P. TAX WE
HAVE SIX REGIONAL HE TALKS AND
THE CLIENTS OF OUR P. TALK
CENTERS I WON OVER THREE HUNDRED
AND THIRTY SIX MILLION DOLLARS.
IN FEDERAL STATE AND GOVERNOR OF
LOCAL GOVERNMENT CONTRACTS LAST
YEAR JUST AND TWENTY SEVENTEEN
THE PROPOSED FUNDING WOULD ALLOW
US TO EXPAND OURS. SERVICES AYE
AND REACH ADDITIONAL CLIENTS
CURRENTLY THERE ARE EIGHTEEN
COUNTIES IN CALIFORNIA THAT ARE
COVERED BY A PITOT CURRENTLY UP
BY DOD FUNDING THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON.
MISTER CHAIRMAN AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS MY NAME IS MARK HE
STOCKS IN THE CHAIR OF THE
CALIFORNIA SMALL BUSINESS
DEVELOPMENT CENTER PROGRAM OR
THE SPC A REPRESENT ALL THE FIVE
S. B. C. REGION'S HERE. AND
CALIFORNIA.
I'M FULLY SUPPORTIVE OF THIS
CURRENT PROPOSAL.
TO MAKE AN INVESTMENT INTO
SMALL BUSINESS I THINK IT'LL BE
A HUGE IMPACT ON SMALL
BUSINESSES IN OUR ABILITY TO
PROVIDE SERVICES TO. THE
UNDERSERVED AND I WOULD LIKE TO
ALSO SAY ON IF YOU TAKE A LOOK
BACK AT THE THREE PREVIOUS YEARS
OF FUNDING THAT WE RECEIVE FROM
THE CAPITAL INFUSION PROGRAM. WE
PROVIDED A HUNDRED.
TOM'S ROI ON THAT INVESTMENT SO
ON ANY INVEST IN A SMALL
BUSINESS THROUGH US.
AND ALL THE OTHER FEDERAL
PARTNERS WILL PROVIDE A
SIGNIFICANT RETURN.
THE STATE.
BUT YOU THINK.
MARK HURLBERT WITH SMALL
BUSINESS MAJORITY WE ARE
NATIONAL SMALL BUSINESS
EDUCATION AND ADVOCACY
ORGANIZATION AYE AND WE'RE
THRILLED TO SUPPORT THIS
HISTORIC INVESTMENT IN SMALL
BUSINESSES HERE IN CALIFORNIA.
BUT YOU.
IT GOOD AFTERNOON DISCOVERED
OWSKI AT REPRESENTING NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA SPDC SMALL BUSINESS
DEVELOPMENT CENTERS. AND.
CALIFORNIA STATE LIAISON FOR A
SPEEDY SEES A REAL EXCITED ABOUT
THE NEW PROPOSAL REALLY
APPRECIATIVE OF AGO BIZ AND.
SO MEMBERS CERVANTES AND QUIRK
SILVA REALLY EXCITED TO EXPAND
OUR SERVICES OUT TO MORE THE
RULE AND UNDERSERVED AREAS THANK
YOU.
IF YOU.
HELLO MY NAME'S TIM YAMAUCHI ON
THE CURRENT DIRECTOR FOR THE
MBTA EXPORT CENTER ARE RUN BY
THE CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE.
WE PROVIDE SUPPORT THROUGHOUT
THE STATE TO.
MINORITY BUSINESSES.
IN EXPANDING THEIR EXPORT
OPPORTUNITIES ON MOSTLY ON
BEHALF OF THE OTHER FIVE
IMMEDIATE CENTERS AND UP TO SOME
STATS IN THE LAST YEAR. WE.
SUPPORTED THREE HUNDRED EIGHTY
EIGHT MPS THROUGHOUT THE STATE
CREATING ONE POINT TWO FIVE
BILLION IN CONTRACTS IN CAPITAL.
AND ALSO CREATING ALMOST SIXTEEN
HUNDRED JOBS AND OBVIOUSLY WE
SUPPORT THIS THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU.
HELLO NANCY SWIFT ON THE
FOUNDING DIRECTOR OF THE
JEFFERSON ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT
INSTITUTE FONDLY KNOWN AS JED I
UP IN THE FAR NORTHERN REGION.
OF CALIFORNIA AND.
WE HOST OF WOMEN'S BUSINESS
CENTER WE HAVE SINCE TWO
THOUSAND FOURTEEN AND WE'VE BEEN
SERVING SMALL BUSINESS OWNERS
AND ENTREPRENEURS IN VERY RURAL
CHALLENGED AREAS FOR THE LAST
TWENTY ONE YEARS. I'M ALSO ON
THE BOARD OF CAMEO SO I'M GOING
TO SAY DITTO TO EVERYTHING THAT
EVERYONE SAID AND VERY MUCH IN
SUPPORT OF THIS HISTORIC
INVESTMENT THANK YOU THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS LEAH
BAY A FORMER WBC DIRECTOR FOR
THE WOMEN'S BUSINESS CENTER OUT
WOMEN'S ECONOMIC VENTURES
SERVING VENTURA AND SANTA
BARBARA COUNTIES. WANTED TO SAY
WE ARE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS
TYPICALLY A DOLLAR INVESTEDIN
WE RETURNS TWELVE TO THE
COMMUNITY AND WE LOVE THE MULTI
YEAR FUNDING ASPECTS OF IN
STRONG SUPPORT THINK YOU.
IF YOU.
I MONIES MIKE STREAMER WITH THE
CALIFORNIA CAPITAL P. TECH HERE
IN SACRAMENTO PROCUREMENT
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE CENTER. AYE
WE HELP BUSINESSES DO BUSINESS
WITH THE GOVERNMENT IT'S HARD TO
DO HER OVER WITH ALL THE
PAPERWORK BUT THE SMALL
BUSINESSES ARE OTHERWISE VERY
QUALIFIED TO HELP THE GOVERNMENT
MEET THEIR NEEDS AT THE STATE
LEVEL AND FEDERAL LEVEL. SO THE
WORK THAT WE DO REALLY HELPS AND
THIS WOULD REALLY HELP US DO
MORE.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS KAREN
CONNELLY AND I HAD THE GREAT
HONOR OF SERVING AS A C. E. L.
FOR THE VETERANS BUSINESS SORRY
CENTER. WE PROVIDE ONE TO ONE
SMALL BUSINESS CONSULTING
SERVICES OVER TWO HUNDRED
TRAINING PLATFORMS ON AN
ANNUALIZED BASIS TO HELP
VETERANS RESERVISTS AND
GUARDSMEN BURRS. IN THEIR
MISSION IS TO EITHER START
SUSTAIN OR EXPAND A SMALL
BUSINESS AND.
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA THANK YOU
THANK YOU.
A QUESTION FOR STAFF TO CLARIFY
HOW MUCH FUNDING WOULD NEED WE
KNOW HOW WE NEED TO DRAW DOWN.
THE FEDERAL FUNDS FOR S. B. DC.
THE CURRENT PROPOSAL SUGGESTS
THAT PROVIDES THAT THREE MILLION
DOLLARS ON AN. ANNUAL BASIS TO
S. B. C. HOWEVER THEY ARE
ELIGIBLE TO APPLY FOR THE LARGER
POOL OF SEVENTEEN MILLION
DOLLARS.
THANK YOU.
ANY QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE.
THE RECOGNITION THE LIST OF OPEN
SO HOLD OPEN.
THANK YOU IF YOU. BRIATORE NEXT
ITEM ITEM NUMBER SIX
CLOUD SUPPORT BUSINESS ANALYSIS.
I WILL COOK AGAIN WITH THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE OF BUSINESS
AND ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT.
ISSUE NUMBER SIX IS A REQUEST
FOR BUDGET AUTHORITY OF TWO
HUNDRED SEVENTY SEVEN THOUSAND
DOLLARS IN FISCAL YEAR EIGHTEEN
AND NINETEEN AND EACH YEAR THERE
ARE PREFERRED TO NEW POSITIONS
FOR INFORMATION TECHNOLOGY UNIT.
TO MEET CLOUT SUPPORT AND
BUSINESS ANALYSTS REQUIREMENTS.
SINCE GO BUSINESS AND INCEPTION
IN TWENTY TWELVE WE HAVE
DEVELOPED EXPANDED SEVERAL
ONLINE TOOLS AND APPLICATIONS TO
ASSIST THE CALIFORNIA BUSINESS
COMMUNITY.
MOST NOTABLY BEING ARE
CALIFORNIA BUSINESS PROTO
CALIFORNIA BUSINESS PORTAL WHICH
PROVIDES ONLINE ASSISTANCE AND
INFORMATION TO START GROW OR
MAINTAIN A BUSINESS IN
CALIFORNIA.
THESE POSITIONS ARE CRITICAL TO
OUR ABILITY TO MAINTAIN AND
EXPAND OUR ONLINE TOOLS TO HELP
BUSINESSES THRIVING CALIFORNIA.
I HAVE MY COLLEAGUE TOM BOONE
WITH ME TODAY HE'S OUR
INFORMATION TECHNOLOGY CHIEF AND
HE'S AVAILABLE TO ANSWER
TECHNICAL QUESTIONS MAY HAVE
THANK YOU FINANCE.
WELL WE HAVE NO CONCERNS.
IN THE COMMITTEE.
WE WILL ASSIST NICHOLAS PUBLIC
COMMENT.
BUT REPUGNANT NOW SELLS A
QUORUM.
COOPER HERE BRO.
CABALLERO. CHIU CHOI HERE.
WE'RE GOAL OF TO OUR BODILY
CALENDAR REALLY TAKEN A LOT OF
SEVERLY WELL FIRST OF TAKE A.
LITTLE LEON ITEM NUMBER ONE.
THEIR MOTION.
ALSO GONNA.
ROLL CALL PLEASE.
COOPER I.
BRO.
CABALLERO.
CHIU CHOI.
YES.
OKAY GO NEXT WEEK UP THE VOTE
ONLY STILL ITEMS TWO THREE FIVE
TWO THROUGH FIVE.
I'LL SECOND THAT. REPUBLIC
COOPER AYE BRO.
CABALLERO.
CHIU CHOI.
IF IF YOU.
SO NOTICES BECAUSE IVAN PUBLIC.
THE COMMISSION DOES NOT OPEN.
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
IF YOU.
OR GO BACK TO.
IS NUMBER THREE. YEAH ITC
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN
AND MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY
NAME IS ALYSSA ANDERSON WITH THE
CALIFORNIA BUDGET AND POLICY
CENTER THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK TODAY.
AT THE KEY POINT I WANT TO MAKE
IN MY REMARKS TODAY IS THAT
CREATING THE KELLY A T. C.. WAS
ONE OF THE MOST IMPORTANT
ADVANCES THAT CALIFORNIA HAS
MADE IN RECENT YEARS TO IMPROVE
ECONOMIC OFFERS THE CONSULTANT
FEW OF THE. FOLKS OUTSIDE
CLAYTON PLEASE.
RECEIVE.
I.
CREATING THE KELLY TO SEE WAS
ONE OF THE MOST SIGNIFICANT
ADVANCES THAT CALIFORNIA HAS
MADE IN RECENT YEARS TO IMPROVE
ECONOMIC SECURITY IN OUR STATE.
EACH YEAR SINCE THE TAX CREDIT
WAS CREATED IT'S HELPED HUNDREDS
OF THOUSANDS OF FAMILIES WHO
EARN VERY LITTLE FROM THEIR JOBS
TO BETTER AFFORD BASIC
NECESSITIES. AND THANKS TO YOU
LAST YEAR'S EXPANSION OF THE
CREDIT MANY MORE FAMILIES CAN
NOW HAVE AN EASIER TIME MAKING
ENDS MEET.
SO I WANTED TO START OFF BY
HIGHLIGHTING EXACTLY WHO'S
BENEFITED FROM THE CREDIT AND
HOW MUCH THEY BENEFITED.
SO FIRST OF ALL FAMILIES WHO
QUALIFY FOR THE COUNTY EIGHTY SI
HAVE TO BE WORKING. BUT THE
MAJORITY LIVE WELL BELOW THE
POVERTY LINE SO THAT MEANS THE
ADDITIONAL INCOME THAT THEY GET
FROM THIS CREDIT IS A CRITICALLY
IMPORTANT.
OUR LAST YEAR FAMILIES WITH
MULTIPLE CHILDREN GOT AN AVERAGE
CALLIE ATC OF JUST OVER A
THOUSAND DOLLARS. AND IT'S A LOT
OF MONEY OF COURSE FOR A FAMILY
THAT'S LIVING PAYCHECK TO
PAYCHECK.
I THIS ADDITIONAL CACHES HELP
FAMILIES TO PAY THEIR BILLS PUT
FOOD ON THE TABLE PAY DOWN DEBT.
AND EVEN IN SOME CASES PAY FOR
EMERGENCY EXPENSES LIKE FIXING
THEIR CAR.
BECAUSE OUR STATE EITC BUILDS ON
THE FEDERAL EITC AND THE FEDERAL
CHILD TAX CREDIT. THESE THREE
CREDITS COMBINED CAN NEARLY
DOUBLE THE INCOME OF A FAMILY
WITH THREE OR MORE CHILDREN. AND
YOU CAN SEE THIS FROM THE FIRST
CHART AT THE BOTTOM OF PAGE ONE
OF MY HANDOUT.
THESE FAMILIES CONCEALER INCOMES
RISE BY AS MUCH AS NINETY TWO
PERCENT THANKS TO THESE THREE
CREDITS.
FAMILIES WITH FEWER CHILDREN CAN
ALSO SEE THEIR INCOMES RISE
SIGNIFICANTLY ALTHOUGH BY A
SOMEWHAT SMALLER PERCENTAGE AND
THAT'S BECAUSE SMALLER FAMILIES
QUALIFY FOR SMALLER CREDITS.
WE ALSO KNOW THAT THE KELLY ATC
HAS OVERWHELMINGLY BENEFITTED
CHILDREN AS YOU CAN SEE FROM THE
CHART AT THE TOP OF PAGE TWO OF
MY HAND OUT.
MORE THAN NINETY PERCENT OF
KELLY A TO SEE DOLLARS WENT TO
FAMILIES WITH CHILDREN IN TWENTY
FIFTEEN AND. AND THIS IS
IMPORTANT BECAUSE RESEARCH FINDS
THAT BOOSTING FAMILIES INCOMES
CAN HELP TO REDUCE THE HARMFUL
LONG TERM EFFECTS OF GROWING UP
IN POVERTY.
THE COUNTY TO SEE ALSO LARGELY
BENEFITS WORKING MOTHERS AS YOU
CAN SEE FROM THE CHART AT THE
BOTTOM OF PAGE TWO.
WOMEN MAKE UP SEVENTY PERCENT OF
TAX FILERS WITH CHILDREN WHO ARE
ELIGIBLE FOR THE COUNTY EIGHTY
SEE. SO THIS CREDIT IS AN
IMPORTANT TOOL FOR WORKING
MOTHERS WHO TEND TO EARN LESS
THAN MEN AND WHO ARE MUCH MORE
LIKELY TO BE SUPPORTING CHILDREN
ON THEIR OWN.
AND FINALLY THE TABLES ON PAGE
THREE OF MY HAND OUT SHOW THOUGH
THE CLAIMS DATA FOR THE KELLY A
T. C. OVER THE PAST THREE YEARS.
AND THE FIGURES HIGHLIGHTED IN
RED SO THAT AROUND THREE HUNDRED
AND SEVENTY THOUSAND TAX FILERS
BENEFITTED FROM THE COUNTY TO
SEE. IN THE LAST TWO YEARS AND
ACTUALLY MANY MORE PEOPLE HAVE
BENEFITTED FROM THE CREDIT
BECAUSE THE TAX FILER CAN BE A
MARRIED COUPLE OR CAN BE A
PARENT WITH CHILDREN IT'S
BASICALLY EVERYONE LISTED ON THE
TAX FOR.
I THIS YEAR THE KELLY ATC HAS
REACHED FAR MORE TAX FILERS
ALMOST EIGHT HUNDRED THOUSAND AS
OF MARK MID MARCH OF THIS YEAR
ABOUT A MONTH BEFORE THE END OF
TAX FILING SEASON.
I AND THAT'S BECAUSE LAST YEAR'S
BUDGET EXTENDED THE CREDIT TO
MANY. MANY MORE PEOPLE OF.
THIS MEANS THE DATA ARE
ACTUALLY NOT COMPARABLE FOR THIS
YEAR THAT WE HAVE SO FAR TO THE
PRIOR YEARS BECAUSE OF THE
EXPANSION OF THE CREDIT.
AND SO WE'RE ACTUALLY SEEING A
LOWER AVERAGE CREDIT SO FAR THIS
YEAR AND THAT'S BECAUSE PEOPLE
BECAME NEWLY ELIGIBLE FOR THE
CREDIT THIS YEAR TEND TO QUALIFY
FOR SMALLER CREDITS.
I SO SPECIFICALLY LAST YEAR'S
EXPANSION OF THE KELLY ATC
EXTENDED THE CREDIT TO SELF
EMPLOYED WORKERS AND THIS HELPED
TO BRING OUR STATE CREDIT INTO
ALIGNMENT WITH THE FEDERAL
CREDIT WHICH HAS ALWAYS
PERMITTED SELF EMPLOYED WORKERS
TO QUALIFY. AND THAT SO FAR THIS
YEAR BE WE'VE SEEN ABOUT A
HUNDRED AND EIGHTY THOUSAND
CLAIMS FROM THE SELF EMPLOYED.
AT LAST YEAR'S EXPANSION ALSO
EXTENDED THE COUNTY EIGHTY SEE
TO WORKERS A LITTLE BIT HIGHER
UP THE INCOME SCALE.
SO PREVIOUSLY PARENTS HAD EARNED
LESS THAN ABOUT AYE TEN THOUSAND
TO FOURTEEN THOUSAND DOLLARS A
YEAR TO QUALIFY FOR THE CREDIT.
NOW THEY CAN EARN UP TO ABOUT
TWENTY TWO THOUSAND DOLLARS A
YEAR.
AND SO WHAT THAT MEANS IS
PARENTS WORKING FULL TIME OR
CLOSE TO FULL TIME AT THE
MINIMUM WAGE CAN NOW BENEFIT
FROM THE CREDIT. AND THAT'S
IMPORTANT BECAUSE IN MANY PARTS
OF THE STATE A MINIMUM WAGE JOB
ISN'T ENOUGH TO SUPPORT A
FAMILY.
I FOR WORKERS WHO ARE NOT
SUPPORTING CHILDREN THE INCOME
NEEDED TO QUALIFY FOR THE KELLY
EIGHTY SEE MORE THAN DOUBLED
FROM JUST UNDER SEVEN THOUSAND
DOLLARS A YEAR. TO ABOUT FIFTEEN
THOUSAND DOLLARS.
SO I THINK THERE'S A STRONG CASE
FOR CONTINUING TO STRENGTHEN
MCCALLIE ITC.
OUR FIRST OF ALL EARNED INCOME
TAX CREDITS ARE PROVEN POLICIES
THE FEDERAL EITC HAS BEEN AROUND
FOR SEVERAL DECADES AND THE
RESEARCH SHOWS THAT THIS CROWD
IT DOESN'T JUST HELP FAMILIES
GET BY DAY TODAY. IT'S ALSO BEEN
LINKED TO IMPROVED HEALTH FOR
MOTHERS AND BABIES AS WELL AS
HIGHER HIGH SCHOOL GRADUATION
RATES AND COLLEGE COMPLETION
RATES FOR CHILDREN. SO IT
APPEARS THAT THOSE CREDIT CAN
PROVIDE BENEFITS THAT LAST INTO
THE NEXT GENERATION.
I AND OF INCLUDED A SUMMARY OF
THIS RESEARCH AT THE BACK OF MY
HAND OUT FOR YOUR REFERENCE.
I ALSO I THINK THAT WE NEED
POLICIES LIKE A STRONG STEVIE
ITC BECAUSE MANY PEOPLE SIMPLY
CAN'T COUNT ON THEIR JOBS TO
PROVIDE FINANCIAL SECURITY.
OF FOR EXAMPLE WAGES HAVEN'T
KEPT UP WITH THE RISING COST OF
LIVING IN PARTICULARLY HIGH
HOUSING COSTS.
SO EVEN WHEN OUR MINIMUM WAGE
IT'S FIFTEEN DOLLARS PER HOUR IT
WILL BE ENOUGH FOR MANY FAMILIES
TO GET BY.
I ON TOP OF THAT MANY PEOPLE
CAN'T FIND STABLE FULL TIME JOBS
SO THEY HAVE TO PATCH TOGETHER
TEMPORARY JOBS OR CONTRACT WORK.
OR THEY HAVE TO MAKE DO WITH
PART TIME HOURS ARE INCONSISTENT
HOURS.
SO THAT MEANS THEIR EARNINGS ARE
JUST IN SUFFICIENT OTHER
UNPREDICTABLE AND THAT MAKES IT
HARD FOR THEM TO STAY ON TOP
THEIR BILLS AND PUT ASIDE ANY
SAVINGS FOR THE FUTURE.
SO I THINK STRENGTHENING THE
COUNTY EIGHTY SEEWOULD FURTHER
INCREASE ECONOMIC SECURITY FOR
THESE FAMILIES.
SO I WANT TO CONCLUDE BY
HIGHLIGHTING A FEW WAYS YOU
COULD CONSIDER TO FURTHER INVEST
IN THIS CREDIT.
ONE OPTION IS TO ALLOW LOW
INCOME WORKERS WHO ARE CURRENTLY
EXCLUDED FROM THE CREDIT TO
QUALIFY.
FOR EXAMPLE MANY IMMIGRANT
FAMILIES WHO WORK AND PAY TAXES
DON'T BENEFIT FROM THE CREDIT
CURRENTLY.
YOUNG ADULTS UNDER AGE TWENTY
FIVE WHO AREN'T SUPPORTING
CHILDREN BUT WHO OFTEN DO EARN
LOW WAGES DON'T QUALIFY.
AND WORKERS OVER AGE SIXTY
FULLER DON'T QUALIFY FOR NOT
SUPPORTING CHILDREN EVEN THOUGH
SOME WORKERS ARE WORKING BEYOND
THE TRADITIONAL RETIREMENT AGE
OUT OF FINANCIAL NECESSITY.
ANOTHER WAY YOU COULD STRENGTHEN
THE KELLY EIGHTY SEE IS BY
MAKING SURE THAT FULL TIME
MINIMUM WAGE WORKERS DON'T LOSE
ELIGIBILITY FOR THE CREDIT AS A
MINIMUM WAGE RISES. AND THAT
WOULD SIMPLY.
REQUIRE RAISING THE INCOME
LIMIT TO QUALIFY FOR THE CREDIT
FROM TWENTY TWO THOUSAND DOLLARS
WHERE IT IS CURRENTLY TO ABOUT
THIRTY ONE THOUSAND DOLLARS BY A
TWENTY TWENTY TWO WHEN THE
MINIMUM WAGE IT'S FIFTEEN
DOLLARS PER HOUR.
I AND FINALLY YOU COULD CONSIDER
INCREASING THE SIZE OF THE CROWD
IT PARTICULARLY FOR THE LOWEST
EARNING WORKERS OR FOR WORKERS
WHO CURRENTLY QUALIFY FOR
RELATIVELY SMALL CREDITS.
SO THESE ARE SOME OF THE OPTIONS
YOU COULD CONSIDER TO FURTHER
BUILD ON THE KELLY ITC. AND THAT
WOULD HELP A ADDITIONAL LOW
INCOME FAMILIES BETTER MAKE ENDS
MEET. THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
YOUR TIME THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MICHELLE STILL
PREVENTS HE CHILDREN'S DEFENSE
FUND CALIFORNIA I WON I THINK.
BUDGET CHAIR TING IN THE
MEMBERS OF THE SUBCOMMITTEE AND
STAFF FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP ON
KELLY ABC OVER THE. PAST SEVERAL
YEARS.
BECAUSE OF YOUR COMMITMENT TO
THE EITC MORE THAN A MILLION
FAMILY AT LOW INCOME FAMILIES
HAVE MORE MONEY IN THEIR POCKET
TO PAY FOR BASIC NEEDS. AND WE
REALLY APPRECIATE THAT.
A I'M HERE REPRESENTING THE CAL
YANKEE SEE ADVOCACY COALITION.
WHICH IS A COALITION OF MORE
THAN THIRTY ORGANIZATIONS.
REPRESENTING ADVOCATES FOR LOW
INCOME FAMILIES IMMIGRANTS
CHILDREN USE SENIORS FOOD BANKS
PEDIATRICIANS SOCIAL WORKERS ON
ALL COMING TOGETHER BECAUSE WE
BELIEVE AND ARE COMMITTED.
TO THE CALIFORNIA E. I. T. C..
WE KNOW THAT IT'S A PROVEN WAY
TO SUPPORT LOW INCOME FAMILIES
AND INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE
STRUGGLING TO MAKE ENDS MEET.
ONE THAT REDUCES POVERTY.
IMPROVE CHILD HEALTH AND WELL
BEING CHILD UP EDUCATIONAL
OUTCOMES SPURS LOCAL ECONOMIC
GROWTH AND BUILD FINANCIAL
SECURITY IN THE LONG RUN ALL OF
THE GREAT RESEARCH.
THAT ALYSSA JUST MENTIONED.
THAT'S WHY ARE COALITION IS
URGING THE SUBCOMMITTEE TO TAKE
ACTION THIS YEAR TO CONTINUE TO
STRENGTHEN THE CALLIOPE DC.
WE STRONGLY SUPPORT PROPOSALS
TO CONTINUE TO BUILD THE SIZE OF
THE CREDIT.
TO IMPROVE THE POVERTY FIGHTING
IMPACT OF THE CALLIOPE DC.
A WE ALSO STRONGLY URGE YOU TO
CONSIDER.
EXTENDING ELIGIBILITY FOR THE
CALLEA EIGHTY SEE TO SEVERAL
POPULATIONS THAT ARE CURRENTLY
EXCLUDED FROM THE FEDERAL AND
STATE YEAH I THI SIS.
LOW INCOME FAMILIES WHO ARE
WORKING AND FILING TAXES BUT ARE
ABLE TO CLAIM THIS REALLY
IMPORTANT CREDIT.
SPECIFICALLY LOW INCOME WORKING
YOUNG ADULTS WORKING SENIORS AND
IMMIGRANT FAMILIES.
I'VE CALIFORNIA IS NOT BOUND BY
FEDERAL EITC ELIGIBILITY RULES
AND WE CAN MAKE OUR CALIPARI ID
SEE MORE EQUITABLE AND
INCLUSIVE.
AND A TIME WHEN FEDERAL TAX AND
SOCIAL POLICY IS ARE BECOMING
MORE REPRESSIVE THAT'S EXACTLY
WHAT WE SHOULD BE DOING.
SO WE URGE YOU.
TO EXTEND CALLEA T. C.
ELIGIBILITY TO THREE GROUPS.
FIRST OF LOW INCOME WORKING
YOUNG ADULTS AGES EIGHTEEN TO
TWENTY FOUR NOT CURRENTLY THOSE
YOUNG ADULTS ARE ARE EXCLUDED.
IF THEY ARE TO SUPPORTING
CHILDREN FROM THE CALLI IDC.
NOT AGE LIMIT REALLY LEAVES OUT
YOUNG ADULTS WHO LACK FINANCIAL
STABILITY EARLY IN THEIR CAREERS
WORKING STUDENTS WERE STRUGGLING
TO GET BY AND FORMER FOSTER YOU.
THIS AGE GROUP EXPERIENCES
POVERTY AT A HIGHER RATE THAN
ANY OTHER ADULT PIC.
ADULT AGE GROUP.
CURRENTLY A HIGH SCHOOL GRADUATE
WOULD HAVE TO WORK FOR SEVEN
YEARS BEFORE THEY EVEN BE ARE
ARE EVEN ABLE TO CLAIM THE EITC.
SO MAKING THIS CREDIT AVAILABLE
TO LOW WAGE YOUNG ADULTS WILL
PROVIDE KEY SUPPORT DURING A
VITAL PERIOD OF THEIR CAREER
DEVELOPMENT.
SECOND LOW INCOME WORKING.
SENIORS OVER THE AGE OF SIXTY
FIVE.
WHO ARE NOT CURRENTLY INCLUDED
IN THE CALLIOPE C.? I AT A TIME
WHEN OLDER ADULTS ARE BEING
FORCED TO WORK OUT OF. OUT OF.
FINANCIAL NECESSITY AFTER
TRADITIONAL RETIREMENT AGE THIS
AGE LIMIT IS PREVENTING POOR
STUDENTS ARE POOR SENIORS FROM
BENEFITING FROM THE CREDIT.
MAXIMUM SO SECURITY BENEFITS
AREN'T AVAILABLE UNTIL AGE AGE
SEVENTY AND MANY LOW INCOME
WORKERS DON'T RECEIVE ENOUGH SO
SECURITY TO LIFT THEMSELVES OUT
OF POVERTY.
AND FINALLY A IMMIGRANT WORKERS
AND FAMILIES WITH INDIVIDUAL
TAXPAYER IDENTIFICATION NUMBERS
ARE AYE TENS OR SOCIAL SECURITY
NUMBERS.
MANY IMMIGRANT WORKING FAMILIES
ARE EXCLUDED FROM THE CALLEA TO
SEE BECAUSE THE CREDIT IS ONLY
GRANTED WHEN EVERY CLAIMED
PERSON THE HOUSEHOLD HASN'T
SOCIAL SECURITY NUMBER BALLOT
FOR WORK.
MANY IMMIGRANTS FILE WITH THE
FEDERALLY ASSIGNED TAX VERY
IDENTIFY INDIVIDUAL TAXPAYER
IDENTIFICATION NUMBER OR AND I
TEN. I'M TO PAY FEDERAL AND
STATE INCOME TAXES AND FILE ON
THEIR TAX RETURNS YET ARE
ELIGIBLE FOR THE COUNTY IDC.
I INCLUDING THESE IMMIGRANT
FAMILIES WOULD HELP REDUCE THE
HARM OF RECENT FEDERAL ACTIONS
LIKE PROVISION IN THE TWO
THOUSAND SEVENTEEN TAX FEDERAL
TAX BILL THAT DENIED THE CHILD
TAX CREDIT. OF TWO OF MY ROUGHLY
ONE MILLION CHILDREN WHO HAVE.
BECAUSE THEIR FAMILIES DIDN'T
HAVE SOCIAL SECURITY NUMBERS.
AND IT WOULD ALSO PROTECT
ELIGIBILITY FOR SOME INDIVIDUALS
WHO MAY LOSE IMMIGRATION RELIEF
LIKE DHAKA AND TPS.
REMOVING THIS EXCLUSION TO THE
CALLEA T. C. WOULD PROVIDE
GREATER FINANCIAL SECURITY TO
LOW INCOME WORKING IMMIGRANT
FAMILIES.
WHO PAY TAXES AND CONTRIBUTE TO
OUR ECONOMY?
AT A TIME WHEN CALIFORNIA LEADS
THE NATION IN POVERTY. THAT'S DD
IDC REALLY OFFERS THE
OPPORTUNITY A APPROVING
OPPORTUNITY TO REDUCE POVERTY
AND HELP LOW INCOME FAMILIES AND
AND INDIVIDUALS IN THE STATE.
AND WE URGE YOU TO CONTINUE TO
STRIKE THAT I THINK YOU COULD
YOU.
I'M BRIAN WHETHER FORD WITH THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE AND
I PREPARED A HAND OUT.
THAT I DESCRIBED THE STATE'S.
AND INCOME TAX CREDIT. EDUCATION
OUTREACH ACTIVITIES I THINK ON
MOST YOU HAVE A COPY OF IT THAT
ON THIS ARE SOME OUTSIDE.
BUT THE FIRST TWO PAGES ARE
MOSTLY BACKGROUND ON THE CREDIT
BUT I WANTED TO BRING YOUR
ATTENTION TO THE LAST BULLET
POINT ON PAGE TWO.
.
MOST OF THE ELIGIBLE FILERS DID
NOT CLEAN THE STATE EITC LAST
YEAR AND OF COURSE THIS YEAR A
LOT OF THAT'S DUE TO THE
EXPANSION BUT. A SEVENTY FIVE
THOUSAND OF THOSE FIVE THERE'S A
FILING STATE TAX RETURN FOR THE
FIRST TIME.
WE'RE HIGHLIGHTING THIS BECAUSE
IT PROVIDES THE JUSTIFICATION
FOR ONGOING SUPPORT FOR
EDUCATION OUR CHECK TO THE CASE.
I'M TURNING TO PAGE THREE.
THE STE DATES EXISTING.
HAS A NUMBER OF.
EXISTING PROGRAMS FOR EDUCATION
SIT TAX PERSISTENCE CANADA
EDUCATION OUTREACH FOR THE YEAH
TEA SEE.
THEM UNIMPORTANT.
PROGRAM IS THE INTERNAL REVENUE
SERVICE'S INITIATIVE TO SUPPORT
FREE AND. OF FIVE FILING FOR
FEDERAL AND STATE TAX
PREPARATION THIS IS.
THE VITA PROGRAM AND REALIZE ON
ON THE ASSISTANCE OF A LARGE
NUMBER OF THIRD PARTY
ORGANIZATIONS INCLUDING NON
PROFITS COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS. AND OTHER STATE
AND LOCAL GOVERNMENTAL AGENCIES.
IN ADDITION THE FRANCHISE TAX
BOARD HAS RECEIVED A MILLION
DOLLARS ANNUALLY SINCE THE.
BEGINNING IN THE TWENTY FIFTEEN
SIXTEENBUDGET FOR EARNED INCOME
TAX CREDIT EDUCATION OUTREACH
TONIGHT DESCRIBE THOSE
INITIATIVES ON PAGE FOUR.
BUT I I WANT TO MOVE ON IN THE
INTEREST OF TIME TO PAGE FIVE
BECAUSE FOR THE LAST TWO YEARS.
THE FRANCHISE TAX BOARD HAS ALSO
RECEIVED ON TWO MILLION DOLLARS
ON EACH OF THOSE YEARS AND ONE
TIME FUNDS.
TO MAKE GRANTS.
TO.
TO OTHER ORGANIZATIONS FOR
ARNED INCOME TAX CREDIT
EDUCATION AND OUTREACH.
.
SEE ARM.
ADD THE FRANCHISE TAX BOARD
PARTNERED WITH THE DEPARTMENT
FOR COMMUNITY SERVICES AND
DEVELOPMENT ARE CST TWO
ADMINISTER THE GRANT APPLICATION
EVALUATION PROCESS.
SO THE APPLICATIONS ARM REQUIRED
APPLICANTS TO PROVIDE DETAILED
NARRATIVES DESCRIBING THE
RELEVANT EXPERIENCE IN REACHING.
LOW INCOME POPULATIONS THAT
MIGHT FACE CULTURALLY SPECIFIC
AND LINGUISTICALLY SPECIFIC ON.
CONSIDERATIONS AND.
BARRIERS TO MAYBE LEARNING
ABOUT HER.
THE THE E. I. T. C. IN FILING
THEIR STATE TAXES.
IN ADDITION.
IT REQUIRES NARRATIVES ON WHAT
THEIR EXISTING IT YOU SEE
EDUCATION OUTREACH OPERATIVE M.
ACTIVITIES WHERE AND HOW THEY'RE
GOING TO USE THE FUNDS TO EXPAND
THIS ACTIVITIES.
AND.
TWENTY SIXTEEN CST MADE ELEVEN.
GRANTS TO ELEVEN ORGANIZATIONS
AND ON TO TEN ORGANIZATIONS AND
TWENTY SEVENTEEN AND THERE'S A
MAP SHOWING. OF THE VARIOUS
REGIONS IN THE STATE.
AND THE GROUPS THAT RECEIVE
THOSE GRANTS AND ON PAGE SIX.
AND A SOME OF THE ACTIVITIES
THERE'S A WHOLE RANGE OF
ACTIVITIES THAT THE GRANTEES ARE
ENGAGED IN THESE INCLUDE I'M
PROVIDING FREE.
TAX PREPARATION ASSISTANCE.
PRESENT EDUCATIONAL INFORMATION
TO INDIVIDUALS AND GROUPS
THROUGH A WIDE RANGE OF.
SCALES FROM DOOR TO DOOR
CANVASSING TO LARGE GROUPS AND
EVERYTHING IN BETWEEN.
AND ADDITION TO OTHER TYPES OF
OF ADVERTISING FROM LOCAL NEWS
MEDIA TO SOCIAL MEDIA AND.
.
RADIO ADVERTISEMENTS AND SO
FORTH.
ANOTHER REQUIREMENT OF THESE
GRANTS IS THAT THE.
I'M TURNING OUT TO PAGE SEVEN
IS THAT THE GRANTEES ARE
REQUIRED TO COLLECT AND REPORT
MONTHLY ON STATISTICS ON THE
NUMBER OF INDIVIDUALS THEY REACH
FROM EACH OF THE ACTIVITIES THAT
THEY ENGAGE IN.
AND MANY OF THESE EDUCATION AND
OUTREACH ACTIVITIES ARM ARE
PRIMARILY FOCUSED ON RAISING
AWARENESS OF THE STATE EITC AND.
THIS IS CRITICAL ALSO THE VITA
CENTERS.
SO WE KNOW THAT IT'S DIFFICULT
TO MEASURE THE EFFECTIVENESS.
OF THESE PROGRAMS AND. E. I. T.
C..
CLAIMS.
JUST BASED ON THESE MEASURES
BECAUSE IT'S HARD TO KNOW.
IS RAISING AWARENESS LEADING TO
MORE CLAIMS WHEN PEOPLE LEARN
ABOUT THE PROGRAM ARE THEY AND
THEN GOING HOME WE'RE GOING TO
HEAR. A PAID TAX PREPARER AND
SO.
ONE OF THEM MOPE WITH ANYTHING
ONE OF THE MORE EFFECTIVE.
ACTIVITIES IS THE FREE TAX
PREPARATION AND IT'S CERTAINLY
EASIEST TO MEASURE THE
EFFECTIVENESS OF THAT ACTIVITY.
NOT TO DIMINISH THE IMPORTANCE
OF RAISING AWARENESS IT'S JUST
IN TERMS OF DETERMINING
EFFECTIVENESS IT'S IT'S HARDER
TO UNDERSTAND. THE EFFECTIVENESS
OF THIS ON THOSE ACTIVITIES.
BUT WITH THAT IN MIND AND GIVEN
THAT MANY ELIGIBLE INDIVIDUALS
ARE NOT REQUIRED TO FILE A STATE
INCOME TAX RETURN WE DO ON THINK
THAT FUTURE OUTREACH EFFORTS MAY
WANT TO CONCENTRATE.
ON PROVIDING A MORE FREE TAX
PREPARATION SITES AND MAKING
SURE THE SITES HAVE THE CAPACITY
TO THE NOON SUN TURNED AWAY.
THANK YOU.
AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN COOPER AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE I'M
JUDY DARNELL VICE PRESIDENT OF
PUBLIC POLICY FOR UNITED WAYS
THE CALIFORNIA. I WANT TO THANK
YOU FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP LAST
YEAR'S SUPPORTING THE EXPANSION
OF ELIGIBILITY TO THE HARD
WORKING SELF EMPLOYED FOLKS AND
TO THE. IN GROUP INCREASING NAY.
INCOME LIMIT HOWEVER UNTIL ALL
HARD WORKING LOWER INCOME
CALIFORNIANS AREAS THAT ARE
STRUGGLING TO GET BY HAVE ACCESS
TO KELLY ATC. WE HAVE MORE WORK
TO DO.
OUR GOAL IS TO GET AS MUCH OF
THE AREA TO SEE INTO THE HANDS
OF THE WORKING HOUSEHOLDS AS
POSSIBLE. BY INCREASING AND
IMPROVING THE OUTREACH TARGETED
TO LOOK.
ELIGIBLE HOUSEHOLDS AND IN BOTH
HIGH DENSITY AND RURAL
STRUGGLING COMMUNITIES ACROSS
THE STATE AND BY EXPANDING IN
PROMOTING THE AVAILABILITY OF
FREE TAX PREP SERVICES.
FULFILL THIS PROMISE WE HAVE
IDENTIFIED THE FOLLOWING AREAS.
THEIR FIRST IS THE NEED FOR THE
EXPANDED OUTREACH WHILE
ELIGIBILITY FOR CALLIE IDC WITH
EX TENDED TO THE ADDITIONAL ONE
POINT ONE MILLION WORKERS IN
TWENTY SEVENTEEN. THE FUNDING
FOR OUTREACH REMAIN THE SAME.
YET IN TWENTY SIXTEEN FEWER THAN
ONE IN FIVE PEOPLE WHO WERE
ELIGIBLE FOR THE EITC HAD HEARD
OF THE CREDIT AND FEWER THAN
HALF OF THOSE HAD FILE THEIR
TAXES.
ACCORDING TO A SURVEY BY THE.
BUDGET POLICY CENTER.
THE VAST MAJORITY OF ELIGIBLE
WORKERS ARE NOT REQUIRED TO FILE
THEIR TAXES BECAUSE THEIR INCOME
IS SO LOW AND BECAUSE OF THE
RECENT FEDERAL TAX LAW. EVEN
FEWER FAMILIES WILL BE REQUIRED
TO FILE THEIR FEDERAL RETURNS IN
THE FUTURE.
THE LAST TWO YEARS THE STATE HAS
PROVIDED THE OUTREACH GRANTS TO
REACH MANY POTENTIALLY ELIGIBLE
WORKERS BUT FOCUSED IN ON THAT
TEN COUNTIES DESPITE. DAHLE IT
SEE ELIGIBLE FOLKS LIVING
EVERYWHERE.
WE KNOW OUTREACH PROVIDES A GOOD
RETURN ON INVESTMENT.
ACCORDING TO THE UC IRVINE
RESEARCH CALLIE IDC OUTREACH
DRAWS DOWN UNTAPPED FEDERAL
DOLLARS FOR LOW INCOME AREAS BY
INCREASING THE FEDERAL EITC
UPTAKE. AND BOOSTING THE STATE
ECONOMY.
WITHOUT REACH PEOPLE WHO HAVE
NEVER FILE THEIR TAX RETURNS DO
SO.
SECOND IS THE NEED FOR.
MORE FREE TAX PREP.
BY INVESTING AN ADDITIONAL FREE
TAX PREP SERVICES MORE ELIGIBLE
WORKERS WILL HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO KEEP ALL OF THEIR
CREDIT LEVERAGING THE POLICY ARE
POVERTY FIGHTING IMPACT OF THE
EITC.
WHILE THERE IS A FREE ONLINE
FILING SUCH AS MY FREE TAXES DOT
ORG MANY PEOPLE NEED AND WANT.
THE ASSISTANCE OF A TRAINED
CERTIFIED VOLUNTEER TO ASSIST
THEM.
THIS IS EVIDENCED BY THE OVER
TWO HUNDRED AND SEVENTY NINE
THOUSAND CLIENTS
AT THE APPROXIMATELY EIGHT
HUNDRED FIFTY VITA SITES SERVE
LAST YEAR. AND A HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY ONE THOUSAND AS OF MARCH
NINETEENTH THIS YEAR.
ACCORDING TO THE NATIONAL IRS
REPORT COVERING TWO THOUSAND SIX
TWO THOUSAND AND EIGHT ALSO THE
ERROR RATE AT BY THE SITES IS
ABOUT A THIRD OF WHAT THEIR
COMMERCIAL.
PREPARES OUR.
UNFORTUNATELY APPOINTMENTS OF
BY THE SITES ARE SOMETIMES
FILLED FOUR TO SIX WEEKS OUT
WERE UNAVAILABLE. IN ADDITION.
IN AN ANALYSIS OF ZIP CODES IN
COUNTIES ALMOST FIFTY PERCENT OF
THE ZIP CODES WITH THE HIGHEST
ESTIMATED NUMBER A POTENTIALLY
ELIGIBLE HOUSEHOLDS. DO NOT HAVE
ANY FREE TAX PREP SITES.
SITES ARE VERY SCARCE IN RURAL
AREAS REPORTS FROM THE FIELD
SHOW THAT SOME RURAL CLIENTS
HAVE TO TRAVEL OVER AN HOUR AND
A HALF. TO REACH A FREE TAX PREP
SITE.
BUT EVEN IN LA.
CLIENT NOW HAMBRE HAD TO DRIVE
FORTY FIVE MINUTES SOUTH DUTY
RESTRICTIONS BY SOME OF THE
CURRENT FUNDERS THAT DID NOT
ALLOW HER TO BE SERVED CLOSE TO
HER HOME.
CALLIE ICC HAS BEEN A GREAT
SUCCESS HELPING TO FIGHT POVERTY
BUT TO CARRY OUT THAT PROMISE OF
KELLY I TO SEE. WE HAVE ASKED
THAT WE BE EQUALLY COMMITTED TO
REACHING OUT TO POTENTIALLY
ELIGIBLE WORKERS AND THEN
MAXIMIZING THEIR CREDIT BY
PROVIDING MORE FREE TAX
PREPOSITIONS.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME.
IT IS REALLY QUICK AND LET THE
RECORD REFLECT WE'VE BEEN
REJOINED BY MR BROKE MISTER CHU
AND BUDGET CHAIR TING.
PLEASE PROCEED AFTERNOON ON WHAT
CHAIRMAN COOPER MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE. MY NAME IS YVONNE SON
OF A GUN I'M A TWENTY NINE YEAR
OLD. SINGLE MOTHER OF THREE
AMAZING DAUGHTERS THREE YEAR OLD
MAYA SEVEN YEAR OLDS IT LOUDLY
UNTIL THE ROMANS ABOUT. I LIVE
IN SANTA ROSA CALIFORNIA AND I'M
CURRENTLY WORKING AS A SURGERY
SCHEDULE I SEE JOE'S HOSPITAL.
AFTER COMPLETING MY MEDICAL
ASSISTANT CERTIFICATE PROGRAM AT
SANTA ROSA JUNIOR COLLEGE. I
CARE. FOREIGN SUPPORT MY OWN
FAMILY OF FIVE IN ADDITION TO MY
PARENTS AND GRANDMOTHER AND
BECAUSE I'M THE OLDEST SIBLING.
I ALSO HELP.
MY BROTHER MEXICO WHEN HE NEEDS
HELP WITH HIS FAMILY.
LAST YEAR FOR THE FIRST TIME I
FILED MY TAXES WE UNITED WAY OF
THE WINE COUNTRY'S ERNIE ERNIE
KEEP IT SAVE IT FREE TAX
ASSISTANCE FIGHTER PROGRAM. AND
RECEIVE THE EARNED INCOME TAX
CREDIT BEFORE THAT I HAD BEEN
PAYING HUNDREDS OF DOLLARS EVERY
YEAR TO GET MY TAXES FILED. BUT
NEVER KNEW I HAD.
IF I HAD BROUGHT EVERYTHING THAT
I NEEDED FOR MY APPOINTMENT OR
IF THEY WERE BEING DON
CORRECTLY I CERTAINLY DON'T KNOW
ANYTHING MORE ABOUT MY OWN
FINANCIAL PICTURE ABOUT HOW. TO
SAVE FOR MY FUTURE IF YOU TRAVEL
ALWAYS DREAMED ABOUT BUT NEVER
THOUGHT I COULD ACTUALLY CHIEF.
LAST YEAR AT THE VITA SITE AFTER
BEING WALKED THROUGH MY WHOLE
TAX RETURN. WITH THE WARM
IMPATIENT VOLUNTEER. MY COMBINED
TAX REFUND WAS FORTY TWO SEVENTY
SIX AND OF THAT SIXTEEN OH FIVE
WAS MY EITC. MY REFUND MEANT I
COULD TAKE A DEEP BREATH AND
FEEL WHAT IT MEANT TO HAVE A
SAFETY NET UNDERNEATH US I WAS
ABLE TO MOVE OUT OF MY PARENTS
HOUSE WITH THE DEPOSIT FOR MY
VERY OWN APARTMENT WITH MY
GIRLS.
AND PAY FOR MY DAUGHTER'S
BAPTISM. GET IN THE CAL E. I. T.
C. AND FEDERAL EITC I UNDERSTOOD
IT WAS NOT A HAND OUT BUT RATHER
A HAND UP. MEET POSSIBLY BY MY
OWN HARD WORK AND PERSEVERANCE
THAT MADE ME FEEL PROUD BUT. MY
FREE TAX APPOINTMENT WAS SO MUCH
MORE AFTER BEING ENCOURAGED BY
THE UNITED WAY VOLUNTEERS TO
SAVE SOME OF MY REFUND I BECAME
ELIGIBLE TO ENTER TO THE SAVE
YOUR REFUND NATIONAL PHOTO
CONTEST. IT'LL MEET MY STORY OF
HAVING TO PREMATURE BABIES BOTH
BORN AT TWENTY SIX WEEKS MATTER
THEY TOLD ME MY DREAM TO GO BACK
TO SCHOOL. TO BECOME A NEONATAL
NURSE TO SOMEDAY HELP OTHER
MOTHERS IN THAT SAME DIRE
SITUATION MATTERED. IT'S ONLY MY
DREAMS WITH THE FIRST IN MY
FAMILY TO BUY A HOME FOR MY GIRL
SOMEDAY MATTERED. AND IF I
LEARNED TO SAVE STARTING WITH MY
TAX REFUND NONE OF THESE THINGS
WOULD HAVE REMAINED JUST
EXTREMES BUT INSTEAD COULD
BECOME REALITIES. I AM ALSO A
DOCTOR RECIPIENTS SO I KNOW
ABOUT DREAMS AND HOW FAR OFFER
IMPOSSIBLE THEY CAN FEEL
SOMETIMES SO I CAME HERE TODAY
TO TELL
YOU MY STORY.
I TELL YOU WHAT EITC LET ME DO
LET ME ACHIEVE FOR MYSELF AND
FOR MY GIRLS BUT MOST OF ALL.
HOW IT MADE ME FEEL LIKE A
CAPABLE SUPPORTER FOR MY FAMILY
WHO COUNTS ON ME EVERYDAY?
NOW WHEN I SAY WHAT I SEE I HAVE
MONEY I DON'T WANT TO SEE THAT
AMOUNT GO DOWN. THEY WANTED TO
STAY THERE I THINK WHEN YOU GET
USED TO STRUGGLING MONTH TO
MONTH YOUR WHOLE LIFE. HE JUST
ACCEPTED IT'S ALWAYS GOING TO BE
THAT WAY. AND IT'S EASY TO GET
STUCK IN THAT WAY THINKING
HAVING THAT MONEY IN SAVINGS
MOTIVATES ME AND I WANT TO
CONTINUE TO SAVE IT.
IT BRINGS BACK DIGNITY AND IT
FEELS LIKE SAFETY. WHEN YOU GET
HELP FROM PEOPLE WHO BELIEVE IN
YOU EVEN THOUGH YOU'VE JUST MET.
IN MAKES YOU REALLY LOOK AT
YOURSELF AND YOUR TRUE POTENTIAL
I HOPE THE MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE SUPPORT IMPROVEMENT
AND CALLIE ITC SO THAT MORE
PEOPLE CAN EXPERIENCE. SOME OF
THE OPPORTUNITIES I HAVE HAD
BECAUSE OF EITC.
AND WE NEED TO REACH ALL THE
PEOPLE WHO CAN CLAIM EITC I ALSO
ASK YOU TO HELP MORE PEOPLE HAVE
THE EXPERIENCE THAT I HAD WITH
FREE TAX PARKS BY THE SITES.
WERE SO MUCH MORE THAN TAXES ARE
HAPPENING FOR THOSE LIKE ME WHO
NEED IT. THE MOST THANK YOU FOR
LETTING ME BE HERE TODAY. MISS
BIGELOW WANNA TAKE YOU HALF THE
MEMBERS OF MANY FOR SHARING YOUR
STORY WITH US.
I'M GO HEAD UP THE PUBLIC
COMMENT. YOU WISH TO SPEAK ON
THIS ITEM.
GOOD AFTERNOON IT'S MISTER
CHAIRMAN OF THE COMMITTEE GINA
DESOTO WITH THE CALIFORNIA
IMMIGRANT POLICY CENTER WE ARE
IN SUPPORT OF THE PROPOSAL TO
REMOVE EXCLUSIONS FOR. I'M
CURRENTLY EXCLUDED WORKING
POPULATIONS PARTICULARLY
IMMIGRANTS IS AN OPPORTUNITY TO
REDUCE POVERTY BUT ALSO CREATE
AND IMPROVE OUR SAFETY NET TO
WORK FOR ALL CALIFORNIANS
REGARDLESS OF WHERE THEY WERE
BORN. I'M PARTICULARLY AS THE
FEDERAL RULES AND POLICIES ARE
INCREASINGLY NOT MEETING.
THAT NEEDS AND VALUES OF OUR
STATE OF CALIFORNIA WE ALSO ARE
IN SUPPORT OF THE PROPOSAL
RELATED TO OUTREACH WHICH IS
PARTICULARLY CRITICAL FOR
FAMILIES THAT ARE LIMITED
ENGLISH PROFICIENT. AND ARE HAVE
MIXED IMMIGRATION STATUS IS IN
THE HOUSEHOLD THANK YOU THANK
YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON THANK YOU FOR
INVITING US.
I'M SO PROUD TO BE HERE THE VON
TODAY MY NAME IS SUZANNE YEOMANS
AND I'M THE FINANCIAL STABILITY
PROGRAM OFFICER FROM UNITED WAY
THE WINE COUNTRY IN SANTA ROSA.
FOR A FIVE REGIONAL PARTNERSHIP
WITH ABOUT THIRTY FIVE TAX SITES
FROM CINEMA COUNTY. MEDICINE A
LAKE HUMBLE AND DELMAR. AND I'M
HERE JUST TO LET YOU KNOW THAT
WE REALLY THEY NEED SO OUTWEIGHS
THE AVAILABILITY OF THE
APPOINTMENTS AND MORE AND MORE
FAMILIES. ON NEED OUR HELP EVERY
YEAR ESPECIALLY WHETHER FIRES
RAVAGED WHERE WE WERE RECENTLY.
WE REALLY NEED TO DO A LOT MORE
TO EDUCATE.
A LOT OF ACRONYMS FLYING AROUND
BUT THE FAMILIES THAT NEED TO BE
EDUCATED.
COMING TO OUR TAX SITES.
IF THEY DON'T THINK THEY HAVE
TO FILE THEY JUST DON'T ON THAT
SO MUCH MORE HAPPENS AT A TAX
SAY WHEN THEY COME IN. LOOKING
AT THE BANK WRITTEN CONNECT INTO
SAVINGS INCENTIVIZE PROGRAMS
PULL THAT KRADDICK AT THEM IN
THE CREDIT COUNSELING.
WE CAN DO SO MUCH MORE FROM MY
THEY JUST WALK THROUGH OUR DOORS
AND TAKE CARE OF OUR FREE.
SERVICES SO AGAIN I'M REALLY
PROUD OF YOU AVON AND THANKS
VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON YEAR
ROUND OUT REACH.
BECAUSE.
MOST PEOPLE DON'T.
HAVE A FILING REQUIREMENT WHO
ARE ELIGIBLE FOR THE CREDIT.
SO IT'S IMPORTANT THAT WE
CONTINUE TO RAISE AWARENESS AND
EDUCATION OUT THROUGHOUT THE
YEAR AND I ALSO WANTED TO
EMPHASIZE THE NEED.
FOR CONTINUOUS.
AND EXPANDED FUNDING IN US WE
HAVE A LARGER POPULATION TO OUR
STILL AND WE CAN ESSENTIALLY
LEVERAGE.
PAST YEARS THE EFFORTS.
AND.
THAT ARE RICH THAT WE DON AND.
AND CONTINUE TO HAVE MORE
TARGETED.
OUTREACH.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS AMY WILLIAMS I
HAVE SOMEWHAT OF A DITTO TO
SUZANNE I ASSUME TITLES FROM THE
FINANCIAL STABILITY PROGRAM
OFFICER BUT FOR THE UNITED WAY
CALIFORNIA CAPITAL REGION HERE
RIGHT HERE IN SACRAMENTO. AND I
JUST WANT TO MENTION THAT WE
HAVE GROWN QUITE A LOT IN THE
LAST FEW YEARS WHERE THE LEAD
AGENCY FOR THE LOCAL VITA
COALITION. WE HAVE NOW FORTY
SITES AND WE EXPECT TO ABOUT
SEVEN THOUSAND FILINGS THIS
YEAR.
BUT EVEN THOUGH WE'VE GROWN SO
MUCH IN THESE RECENT YEARS OUR
SITES ARE VERY BUSY AND OUR
APPOINTMENTS ARE ALWAYS FULL AND
WE DO END UP HAVING TO TURN
PEOPLE AWAY SO FOR EXAMPLE EVEN
IN YOUR. DISTRICT CHAIRMAN
COOPER WE HAVE A THREE SITES IN
YOUR DISTRICT BUT THEY'RE ALWAYS
BUSY ALWAYS FULL AND THEY'RE
SORT OF A GAP IN LIKE IN THE
CALLED AREAS ABOUT SOMETHING
WE'RE LOOKING AT AND THAT'S THE
SAME AND. IN ALL THE OTHERS WE
SERVE WE HAVE MUCH MORE NEED
THAN THAT WE CAN MEET SO THANK
YOU FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION OF.
ADDITIONAL SUPPORT FOR OUTREACH
FOR THE CREDIT ITSELF BUT ALSO
FOR VITA WITCHES SUZANNE SAID IS
CONNECTED TO SO MUCH AWESOME
BUILDING WORK THAT WE DO THANK
YOU. YOU.
TRACY PATTERSON OF CALIFORNIA
FOOD POLICY ADVOCATES IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THIS PROPOSAL THERE
TOO MANY LOW WAGE WORKING
CALIFORNIANS WHO ARE TRAPPED IN
A CYCLE OF POVERTY HUNGER IN
POOR HEALTH IN THIS REALLY
PROVIDES AN OPPORTUNITY TO BREAK
THAT CYCLE. BILLION.
HI SHANTI PRASAD ALAMEDA COUNTY
COMMUNITY FOOD BANK IN OAKLAND A
WE ARE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF ALL
THE PIECES OF THIS PROPOSAL.
WE SERVE ONE IN FIVE PEOPLE IN
ALAMEDA COUNTY THAT'S ABOUT
THREE HUNDRED AND TWENTY SEVEN
THOUSAND PEOPLE ANNUALLY.
AND ABOUT FIFTY FOUR PERCENT OF
THE HOUSEHOLDS THAT WE SERVE.
HAVE AT LEAST ONE WORKING
HOUSEHOLD MEMBER.
AND THEY ARE RECEIVING THERE
OBVIOUSLY VERY VERY LOW INCOME.
AND THE ECONOMIC POLICY
INSTITUTE WHICH CALCULATES THE
AMOUNT OF INCOME NEEDED BY
COUNTY IN METRO AREA TO ATTAIN A
MODEST YET ADEQUATE STANDARD OF
LIVING SAYS THAT THE AMOUNT FOR
A SINGLE PERSON WITHOUT
CHILDREN.
OUGHT TO LIVE IN ALAMEDA COUNTY
IS OVER FIFTY SIX THOUSAND
DOLLARS.
.
NO ONE COMING TO OUR FOOD BANK
MAKES EVEN HALF OR. A THIRD OF
THAT.
SO EXPANDING ELIGIBILITY TO
YOUNG PEOPLE AND SENIORS.
AND TO IMMIGRANT POPULATIONS
WHO ARE WORKING.
WOULD GREATLY DECREASE HUNGER
ON IN OUR COMMUNITY.
AND THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA AND
WE SUPPORT THIS THANK YOU THANK
YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN COOPER
MEMBERS KNOW AT BOTTOM ALL
REPRESENTING CALIFORNIA RURAL
LEGAL ASSISTANCE FOUNDATION WE
SERVE LOW INCOME RURAL FARMER TO
COMMUNITIES STATEWIDE. WE IN
SUPPORT OF ECONOMIC.
CHARITY FOR OUR CONSTITUENT
COMMUNITIES AND THIS PROPOSAL
GOES A LONG WAY TO ADDRESSING
THESE NEEDS. WE ARE APPROVED AND
SUPPORT THE OUTREACH AND
EDUCATION. WE SUPPORT THE
EXPANSION TO YOUNG WORKERS AND
THE WORKERS OVER SIXTY FIVE AND
TO REMOVE THE EXCLUSIONS FAR
IMMIGRANT COMMUNITIES THANK YOU
VERY MUCH.
CHAIR MEMBERS KATHY MUST WORK
WITH THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
OF FOOD BANKS WILL ASSOCIATE
OURSELVES WITH THE COMMENTS OF
ARE FOR BIG PARTNER BUT WE
CERTAINLY SUPPORT ALL THE PIECES
OF THIS PAST.
HI I'M KEVIN IN SCOPE WITH THE
FRIENDS COMMITTEE ON LEGISLATION
OF CALIFORNIA AND LIKE TO
HIGHLIGHT THE IMPORTANCE OF
EXPANDING YET CALLIE ITC TO
WORKERS BETWEEN EIGHTEEN.
AND TWENTY FOUR.
THIS WOULD AFFECT ABOUT OVER
HALF A MILLION OF OUR YOUNG
PEOPLE AND YOU ALL KNOW THAT
CALIFORNIA'S A VERY CHALLENGING
AND EXPENSIVE PLACE TO START
OUT.
MY DAUGHTER ATTENDS AN
ALTERNATIVE HIGH SCHOOL SO I'VE
METAL OF THE KIDS THAT WILL FALL
INTO THIS CATEGORY.
THEY'RE GOING TO BE ON THEIR OWN
AS SOON AS THEY TURN EIGHTEEN.
AND THEY'RE GOING TO BE WORKING
TEMP JOBS MINIMUM WAGE JOBS.
THEY'RE GONNA NEED THE SUPPORT
EVERY DOLLAR WILL COUNT FOR
THEM.
AND I THINK WE NEED TO SEND THEM
A MESSAGE THAT WE SUPPORT THEM.
AND THAT WE HAVE THERE BACK IN
THE WE WANT THEM TO STAY IN
CALIFORNIA AND THRIVE HERE SO I
HOPE WE CAN SEND THEM THAT
MESSAGE THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN IT IS
JUST FRIDAY WITH CALLIE A CHEESY
FOR ME WERE ONE OF THE STATEWIDE
PARTNERS THAT WORK ON OUTREACH
AND IMPROVING THE YET YOU SEE
PROGRAM AND. ABSOLUTELY IN
SUPPORT OF ALL THESE PROPOSALS
TO EXPAND THIS PROGRAM IN AND
INCREASES EFFECTIVENESS IN JUST
ONE FINE POINT ON SOMETHING
THAT'S BEEN MENTIONED A COUPLE
TIMES WHICH HAS TO DO WITH WHOSE
ACTUALLY REQUIRED TO FILE. THE
THERE'S ALMOST A IN EQUIVALENT
MATCH UP BETWEEN WHO'S REQUIRED
TO FILE AND WHO'S ELIGIBLE.
TO FILE AND SO IF WE LOOK AT
THAT IF WE THINK ABOUT THIS
INTUITIVELY IF YOU'RE NOT
REQUIRED TO FIRE TAXES WHY WOULD
YOU.
UNLESS YOU KNEW ABOUT ONE OF THE
TAX CREDITS THAT WERE MENTIONED
EARLIER WHICH IS WHY THE
EDUCATION AND OUTREACH IN
MULTIPLE LANGUAGES AND MULTIPLE
CHANNELS ALL THROUGHOUT
COMMUNITIES ACROSS THE STATE. IS
SO VITAL AND SO IMPORTANT AND
WHY WE NEED TO DO MORE OF IT IF
WE'RE REALLY GONNA MAKE THIS
PROGRAM.
CONTINUE TO SUCCEED AT THE
LEVEL THAT IT COULDN'T SHOULD
AND WE CONTINUE TO FIGHT POVERTY
SO WE APPRECIATE YOU CONSIDERING
ALL THESE OPTIONS IN THE POOR TO
CONTINUE WORKING WITH YOU
SHIRTLESS CARRIER.
LATER ON.
YEAH I DON'T MIND HEARING BUT I
JUST HAVE A COUPLE QUESTIONS.
OKAY.
FINISHING.
VETERAN BOND WITH JUSTICE AN
AGING IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THE
PROPOSAL AND IN PARTICULAR
EXTENDING THE KELLY I DO SEE TO
SENIORS WOULD. HAVE STRENGTHENED
THE ABILITY OF THE CREDIT TO
FIGHTS YOUR POVERTY.
THE SENIORS ARE TODAY ARE
ENTERING RETIREMENT WITH FEWER
RESOURCES THAN PREVIOUS
GENERATIONS
PENSIONS ARE RARE AND THE
AVERAGE WORKER DOESN'T HAVE
ENOUGH OPPORTUNITY TO SAVE
SUFFICIENTLY FOR RETIREMENT. AND
AT THE SAME TIME RISING LEVELS
OF INCOME INEQUALITY ARE PUSHING
MORE SENIORS OUT OF ECONOMIC
SECURITY AND INTO POVERTY.
EVERYDAY TEN THOUSAND PEOPLE
TURN SIXTY FIVE.
BY TWENTY THIRTY BILL BE SEVENTY
TWO MILLION SOON OF SENIORS IN
AMERICA.
OUR SENIOR POPULATION IS
BECOMING LARGER AND PORTER.
CALIFORNIA HAS THE HIGHEST YEAR
POVERTY RATE OF ANY STATE.
WHEN USING THE SUPPLEMENTAL
POVERTY MEASURE WHICH FACTORS IN
OUT OF POCKET MEDICAL EXPENSES
AND GEOGRAPHIC VARIATIONS OF
HOUSING COSTS.
ONE OUT OF FIVE SENIORS IN
CALIFORNIA IS LIVING IN POVERTY
UNDER THIS MUCH A WHEN USING
THIS MEASURE.
AND ALSO SECURITY PROVIDES A
FOUNDATION OF RETIREMENT
PROTECTION.
OF THE BENEFITS ARE MUCH MORE
MODEST THAN MANY PEOPLE REALIZE
ESPECIALLY CONSIDERING
CALIFORNIA'S HIGH COST OF
LIVING.
GIVEN THE REAL HIGH OF THAT
GIVEN THE HIGH REAL POVERTY
RATE.
MANY MORE SENIORS CONTINUE TO
WORK OUT OF NECESSITY JUST TO BE
ABLE TO PAY FOR A BE ABLE TO PAY
FOR BASIC NEEDS.
THIS INCLUDES HOUSE HOUSEHOLDS
WHERE SENIORS ARE NOT ONLY
TAKING CARE OF THEMSELVES. BUT
ARE ALSO INFORMALLY TAKING ON
THE RESPONSIBILITIES OF RAISING
THEIR GRANDCHILDREN. OR
PROVIDING SUPPORT TO THEIR OWN
ADULT ADULT CHILDREN WHO MAY
ALSO BE WORKING PARENTS.
THE CAL YOU TO SEE CAN PUT MONEY
IN THE POCKETS OF LOW INCOME
WORKING SENIORS.
BUILDING ON THE FOUNDATION OF
SOCIAL SECURITY AND HELPING TO
OF SENIORS AND THEIR FAMILIES
OUT OF POVERTY.
LASTLY ON THE UPPER AGE LIMIT.
WHAT WHILE THE SO SCRITTI FULL
RETIREMENT AGE WAS SIXTY FIVE
WHEN THE CAT TWENTY IDC WAS
FIRST ESTABLISHED?
THE FULL RETIREMENT AGE IS
CURRENTLY SIXTY SIX AND FOUR
MONTHS MS ALWAYS WE GRADUALLY TO
SIXTY SEVEN BY TWENTY TWENTY
SEVEN.
SO THE SOVIET SIXTY FIVE AGE
LIMIT DOESN'T REFLECT WAS SO
SCREWED LOOKS LIKE RIGHT NOW. OR
IN THE FUTURE AND IT DOESN'T
REFLECT THE ECONOMIC REALITY OF
THE LIVES OF LOW INCOME SENIORS
IN CALIFORNIA. THANK YOU THANK
YOU.
OUR LAST SPEAKER. HAGGARD
PETNAME'S POLLS HAVE FIVE WE GET
UP WE HAVE A CHAIR LIKE RELIGION
FOR HUMANE IMMIGRANT RIGHTS WE
STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS PROPOSAL
GIVEN REPRESENT IMMIGRANTS WHAT
TIMES AND I KNOW. THE TAX CREDIT
BUT AND ALSO OCT CANNOT QUALIFY
FOR FEDERAL CREDIT IS AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR THEM TO ADD TO
BE ABLE TO DO TO TAKE ADVANTAGE
OF THAT. BUT THEN ALSO I BE
PROSPEROUS AND GET SOME OF THAT
MONEY BACK THANK YOU SO MUCH
THANK YOU MCCLOSKEY BUT PUBLIC
COMMENT AND COME BACK TO MY.
FELLOW.
COMMITTEE MEMBERS WERE SKIPPED
OVER SO MY APOLOGIES.
S. CAVIAR OF THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
MISTER CHAIR I I JUST HAVE A
QUESTION DOES ANYBODY KNOW WHAT
THE POLICY DECISION WAS TO NOT
INCLUDE LOW INCOME EIGHTEEN TO
TWENTY FOUR YEAR OLDS I MEAN
THAT'S. IT WHO I WORKED ON EITC
LAST YEAR IN MY MIND IS BLOWING
BECAUSE I REALLY I REALIZED IT
THERE'S THAT.
SOLUTION AND I JUST WONDERED IF
ANYBODY KNEW NUMBER ONE.
I DON'T ACTUALLY KNOW THE
RATIONALE AND KNOW THAT
ORIGINALLY WHEN THE CREDIT WAS
CREATED IN THE MID SEVENTIES IT
WAS ONLY AVAILABLE TO FAMILIES
AND IT WASN'T UNTIL THE EARLY
NINETIES THAT IT WAS EXTENDED TO
WORKERS WHO ARE NOT SUPPORTING
CHILDREN.
SO I BELIEVE THE AGE LIMIT WAS
PART OF THAT DECISION BUT I I
DON'T KNOW WHAT THE ORIGINAL
RATIONALE WAS.
AND I WOULD JUST ADD TO THAT
THAT.
IT CURRENTLY ARE ELIGIBILITY
SITS ON TOP OF THE FEDERAL EITC
AND THINGS WERE DIFFERENT THE
SEVENTIES.
LATELY UM SO YOU KNOW BUT WE
DON'T NEED TO STAY WITHIN THAT
FEDERAL GUIDELINES YES SO THAT
THAT THE OTHER QUESTION I HAVE
IS.
WHY DON'T WE MAKE THIS
AUTOMATIC I MEAN I UNDERSTAND
ALL THIS ENERGY THAT'S GOING IN
TO TEACH YOU KNOW? TEACHING AND
TRAINING PEOPLE. OUT BUT I LOOK
AT THE MAP AND IT'S NONE OF IT'S
IN REALLY IN MY DISTRICT RACE
BEEN HEAVILY. IN TERMS OF HEAVY
CONCENTRATION I KNOW THERE'S
SOME GREAT BY TO PROGRAMS IN MY
LOCAL REGION I'VE VISITED AND
VISITED THEM DURING THE TAX
SEASON. BUT IT IT JUST SEEMS
COUNTER INTUITIVE TO ME TO
REQUIRE PEOPLE TO ACTUALLY ASK
FOR MONEY THAT THEY'RE ENTITLED
TO ANYWAY. AND IF WE JUST MADE
IT THE REVERSE WITH A PROCESS
WHERE AT THE END OF THE YEAR.
FDB DETERMINES
HERE ARE THE PEOPLE THAT ARE
ELIGIBLE GET THEM A CHECK IT
WOULD SEEM TO ME TO BE
ADMINISTRATIVELY MUCH CLEANER.
AND WE'D REALLY GET THE MONEY TO
WHERE IT'S GOING TO DO THE MOST
GOOD SO EMPTY AND ANY. I'M I'M
INTERESTED IN THAT I GUESS IS MY
POINT AND I KNOW IT'S GOING TO
COST A LOT MORE BECAUSE IT JUST
MEANS WE'RE PAYING PEOPLE WHO
WERE GIVING PEOPLE MONEY THEY'RE
ENTITLED TO AND. SOMETIMES WE
TRY TO KEEP.
FROM LETTING PEOPLE KNOW BUT TO
THE EXTENT THAT WE REALLY NEED
TO LET PEOPLE KNOW AND WE HAVE
SUCH AN INCOME GAP IN THE STATE
IT JUST SEEMS TO ME.
TO MAE LOGICAL SENSE AND I
REALLY APPRECIATED YOU COMING
TODAY AND GET AND TELLING YOUR
STORY MISS VEGA BECAUSE I. AM.
EVERY DOLLAR MAKES A HUGE
DIFFERENCE IN IN THE LIFE OF OUR
FAMILY SINCE I'D LIKE TO FIGURE
OUT A WAY TO BE ABLE TO GET GET
THE MONEY.
MR TO.
FIRST WHY ONE ECHO THE COMMENTS
OF OUR COLLEAGUE WE WERE JUST
CHATTING ABOUT WHY IT ISN'T MADE
AMERICAN. AND I TOLD HER SHE WAS
INTERESTED AUTHORED A BILL IN
THAT TO BE HAPPY TO JOINT
AUTHORED THAT BILL. ARM SO I
WOULD ASK THE COMMUNITY
ADVOCATES IF THIS IS SOMETHING
YOU MAY WANT TO CONSIDER.
EITHER THIS YEAR IN THE
DISCUSSION AROUND.
EITC REFORMER OR OTHERS.
AND I'VE BEEN A HUGE FAN OF THE
EARNED INCOME TAX CREDIT SINCE
MY COLLEGE DAYS AND.
IT'S BEEN NOW OVER TWENTY FIVE
YEARS OF OF OF KNOWING THAT THIS
IS LIKELY THE MOST EFFECTIVE
ANTI POVERTY. TAX POLICY THAT WE
COULD POSSIBLY HAVE.
AND WE KNOW IT IT IT LIST FOLKS
OUT OF POVERTY IT ENCOURAGES
WORK. AYE AND AT A TIME WHEN WE
HAVE THE HIGHEST POVERTY RATE IN
THE COUNTRY WITH LOCAL HOUSING
COSTS.
AND THE DEEPEST INEQUALITY IN
THE COUNTRY ARM WE HAVE TO
EXPAND IT SO I WANT TO JUST I
KNOW THIS IS AN INFORMATIONAL
ITEM BUT. I'M CERTAINLY
SUPPORTIVE OF MORE DOLLARS FOR
OUTREACH IN FACT ABOUT REACH A
I'D CERTAINLY ALSO SUPPORT
EXPANDING THIS AND ALL THE
DIRECTIONS THAT HAVE BEEN.
CONTEMPLATED FOR FOR YOUNG
PEOPLE FOR OLDER FOLKS.
TYPICALLY FOR IMMIGRANT
COMMUNITIES MY MY ONE QUESTION I
HAD FOR ADVOCATES.
HAVE THERE BEEN STUDIES ON THE
IMPACT OF THE EARNED INCOME TAX
CREDIT IN REDUCING SOCIAL
SERVICE EXPENDITURES ON THE PART
OF GOVERNMENT.
WONDERING IF IF THERE HAVE BEEN
STUDIES ON THAT TOPIC BECAUSE I
BELIEVE. THAT MY GUESS IS FOR
EVERY DOLLAR THAT WE SPEND ON
EARNING A TEXTURED OR SAVING
FIFTY CENTS OR OTHERS. IN OTHER
AREAS BUT I WOULD LOVE TO BE
ABLE TO QUOTE. NUMBERS ON THAT.
I CAN TIME AND SAY THAT I'VE
DONE A LOT OF RESEARCH ON THE
EIGHTY SI AND I HAVEN'T COME
ACROSS THE STUDY THAT'S LOOKED
AT THAT. I WOULD ASSUME THAT
WOULD BE TRUE IN PARTICULAR
BECAUSE THERE'S A STRONG BODY OF
RESEARCH SHOWING THAT THE EITC
INCREASES EMPLOYMENT.
PROCLAIMING SINGLE MOTHERS WHO
ARE.
THAT LARGEST BENEFICIARIES OF
THE ACC SOARED ASSUME THAT WOULD
BE TRUE BUT I HAVEN'T COME
ACROSS ANY RESEARCH.
MIDDLE SAFE FOR EXAMPLE ON THE
CHAIR OF THE HOUSING COMMITTEE
HAD A A VERY SMALL INVESTMENT IN
ANTI OF ACTION DOLLARS WHETHER
BE FOR VIXEN DEFENSOR. HELPING
SOMEONE WITH THAT ONE MONTH GAP
ARMY CAN SAVE LITERALLY HUNDREDS
OF THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS RELATED
TO EVICTIONS AND HOMELESSNESS
AND A LEGAL DEFENSE IN THE LONG
RUN AND AND I SUSPECT THAT
THAT'S PROBABLY TRUE IN THIS
AREA BUT I JUST SAN.
SEEN THAT DATA
HOW TO SAY THAT ANECDOTALLY WE
HEAR A LOT FROM CLIENTS THAT
THEY USE THEIR EITC FOR TO STAY
IN THEIR HOUSING. FOR FIRST IN
ORDER TO GET INTO HOUSING.
OR TO SAVE FOR HOUSING.
THE LOT OF MUSIC FOR FIRST AND
LAST WORD AVOIDED IT FICTION IF
THEY LIZA.
ROOMMATE OR SOMETHING LIKE THAT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ELSE I JUST
WANNA SAY TO MISS NOT A BIGGER.
OF THANK YOU YOUR VOICE IS SO
IMPORTANT HERE BECAUSE
OFTENTIMES WE DON'T HERE IN THE
CAPITAL SO THANK YOU FOR FOR
SHARING.
ANY FURTHER QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE.
STRING.
I THINK MISTER CHARGES ORDER
THANK YOU IN THIS COMMITTEE FOR
THEIR.
LEADERSHIP ON THIS ISSUE LAST
YEAR.
I ALSO WANT TO TURN ON.
THANK YOU FOR COMING TODAY AND
TELLING YOUR STORY IT ACTUALLY
IS.
EXTRAORDINARILY IMPORTANT AT
THE SPEAKER JUST MENTIONED HE
HAD IN THE VENT.
THIS LAST WEEKEND AND.
THAT THE PERSON THAT THEY FACED
THAT HE MET ON INACTION MEANT
THE MONEY.
HE GOT FOR YET TO SEE WAS TWO
MONTHS RENT
THE AND THAT'S THAT'S HOW PEOPLE
THINK THAT THIS IS NOT ABOUT.
MONEY THAT THEY'RE JUST.
PUTTING IN THEIR POCKETS BITS
FOR RAN IT'S FOR A CAR IT'S FOR
SOMETHING BIRDS ARE CRITICAL
COULD BE FOR FOOD. SO AGAIN
THESE ARE ON. YOUR STORY IS.
POWER TO THIS POLICY AND I
THINK IT'S SO IMPORTANT TO
KATINA TELLS A THANK YOU FOR FOR
DOING THAT.
ARM BUT I. DID JUST TO ECHO THE
COMMENTS EVER BEEN MADE.
YOU KNOW I I ALSO BELIEVE THAT
THIS IS.
ONE OF THE MOST EFFECTIVE TOOLS
WE HAVE FOR FIGHTING POVERTY.
WE DO NEED TO MAKE IT AS EASY
AS POSSIBLE FOR PEOPLE TO GET
MONEY. INTO THEIR POCKETS ASSUME
THEY DESERVE IT BECAUSE THEY'VE
WORKED AND EARNED THESE DOLLARS
IS JUST.
GIVEN THE MONEY BACK SO ON.
I DID WANNA ON ASK ASKING OF THE
PANELISTS.
WE HAVE SEEN AN UPTICK ARM
OBVIOUSLY.
POP POSSIBLY DUE TO THE
EXPANSION BOND IF YOU'VE
ANALYZED Y. WE'VE SEEN AN UPTICK
UP TO THIS POINT. OF PHONE
CREDITS BEING BEING PUT OUT AND
AND WHERE THAT'S COMING FROM.
IN TERMS OF AN ABSURDITY. I JUST
WANTED TO KNOW THAT SHE YES
THERE'S BEEN A VERY LARGE UPTICK
IN THE NUMBER OF EITC CLAIMS AND
THAT. I'M I'M NOT SURE FORMAL
ANALYSIS OF THE DONE I SUSPECT A
VERY LARGE A NUMBER OF THAT IS
DUE TO THE EXPANSION. WHEN YOU
LOOK AT WHERE WE DID THE EXTENT
EXPANSION WE EXTENDED THE INCOME
LIMITS FROM FIFTEEN THOUSAND TO
TWENTY TWO THOUSAND. AND A LOT
OF THOSE PEOPLE ARE.
SAY A LARGER PROPORTION OF THOSE
MAY HAVE ALREADY BEEN FILING
THEIR TAXES AND SO NOW THEY'RE
ELIGIBLE FOR THE CREDIT. WAS AT
THE LOWER END OF THE INCOME
RANGE THOSE ARE PEOPLE WHO MAY
NOT BE AWARE OF THE CREDITOR MAY
NOT HAVE THE FOLLOWING
REQUIREMENTS.
GREAT THANK YOU.
I'M I WOULD JUST THAT I RECEIVE
SOME DATA JUST BEFORE THE
HEARING THAT ALLOWS US TO
COMPARE.
THE CLAIMS THIS YEAR COMPARED
TO LAST YEAR LOOKING
SPECIFICALLY AT PEOPLE WHO ARE
ELIGIBLE UNDER LAST YEAR'S RULE.
OUT AND WE HAVEN'T SEEN.
ANY CHANGE IN SORT OF WHO WAS
ELIGIBLE LAST YEAR SO THE BULK
OF THE HIGHER CLAIMS IS REALLY
COMING FROM THE EXPANSION.
GREAT THANK YOU.
NOT A CHOICE.
I'M LOOKING AT THE DATA.
CLAIMS TO MAY.
TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN TWO
THOUSAND SIXTEEN AND THE TWO
THOUSAND SEVENTEEN. THREE.
THOSE THAT ARE.
THE DRASTIC DIFFERENCE OF FROM
PRIORITY YEAR TWO THOUSAND.
STEEN TO TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN
AVERAGES SO.
A TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN WAS
APPOINTED FIFTY SEVEN.
REYES SO.
IT WAS SO OUR OWN MOSTA DOUBLER
IN TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN AND A
FIFTEEN.
EFFORT WAS SO FIVE HUNDRED
THIRTY TWO.
AND.
WITH A THREE DEPEND ON THE SO.
LAST YEAR WAS SO FOUR HUNDRED
SEVENTY EIGHT.
WHILE PRIOR YEARS WAS SO. ELEVEN
HUNDRED THIRTY EIGHT TO KNOW WHY
THIS ACROSTIC CAUGHT YASSER THAT
IS DUE ENTIRELY TO THE EXPANSION
SO THAT THE THE THE DATA FURTHER
TWENTY SEVEN TAX YEAR NOT
COMPARABLE TO THE PRIOR YEAR
BECAUSE THERE ARE MANY NEWLY
ELIGIBLE PEOPLE. WHO CLAIM THE
CREDIT AND MANY OF THE PEOPLE
WHO BECAME ELIGIBLE UNDER LAST
YEAR'S EXPANSION QUALIFY FOR
MUCH SMALLER CREDITS SO THEIR
INCLUSION BRINGS DOWN THE
AVERAGE? MORE CLUES MORE
PROCLAIMS SO THE MONTH OR SO SO
MORE CLAIMS FROM PEOPLE WHO
QUALIFY FOR SMALLER CREDITS.
ARE THE PEOPLE WHO ARE ADDED WHO
EARN BETWEEN SAY FOURTEEN ONE
POT THE.
THE MONEY YOU DISTRIBUTE THE
WATER IS A BASED UPON MY
QUALIFICATION I SHOULD BE
ENTITLED TO SEE MY MOM.
SO RIGHT SO WHEN I ACTUALLY
RECEIVE DATA FROM THE FRANCHISE
TAX BOARD JUST BEFORE THE
HEARING THAT I WASN'T ABLE TO
INCORPORATE IN MY HANDOUT THAT
ALLOWS YOU TO ACTUALLY COMPARE.
OTHER PEOPLE WHO QUALIFY UNDER
LAST YEAR'S RULES IN THIS YEAR'S
RULES THERE'S BEEN NO DROP IN
THE AVERAGE CREDIT FOR THOSE
FOLKS THE DROP IN THE AVERAGE
CREDIT IS ENTIRELY FROM PEOPLE
WHO BECAME NEWLY ELIGIBLE FOR
THE CREDIT THIS YEAR. UP THE FOR
EXAMPLE PARENTS WHO EARN BETWEEN
ABOUT FOURTEEN THOUSAND AND
TWENTY TWO THOUSAND DOLLARS
BECAME NEWLY ELIGIBLE FOR THE
CREDIT. BUT THEY QUALIFY FOR
VERY SMALL CREDITS COMPARED TO
THE LOWER INCOME POPULATION THE
QUALIFIED PREVIOUSLY.
I THINK.
OKAY I THINK THE PANEL FOR THEIR
PARTICIPATION WAS VERY A ROBUST.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH APPRECIATED
ANOTHER NO BETTER VOTE ONLY
CALENDAR.
THERE WERE A VOTE ON ISSUE
NUMBER ONE.
FOR.
AND CHIU.
THEN LE ITEMS TWO THROUGH FIVE
BUT ONLY.
PRO.
YOU.
NEXT ONE ITEM NUMBER THIRTEEN.
STATE BOARD OF EQUALIZATION
BUDGET OVERVIEW
.
OKAY QUICK START WITH THAT
FINANCE PLEASE.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR MEMBERS.
STEVEN PUBLIC DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE.
PURSUITS PROVISIONAL LANGUAGE
IN THE TWO THOUSAND AND EIGHTEEN
BUDGET ACT FINANCING OR TO A
REVIEW BOARD MEMBER STAFFING
LEVELS IN NEEDS IN THE WAKE OF
LAST YEAR'S ENACTMENT OF AB ONE
OF TWO.
WHICH SHIFTED MOST THE BOARD
EQUALIZATION'S RESPONSIBILITIES
TO THE NEWLY ESTABLISHED.
DEPARTMENT TAX AND FEE
ADMINISTRATION.
IT SHOULD BE NOTED THAT AB ONE
IT'S HE REDUCED EACH BOARD
MEMBER STAFF IN. FROM SIX EXEMPT
EMPLOYEES.
A TO EXEMPT EMPLOYEES.
HOWEVER THE BUDGET ACT ALLOWED
THE BOARD MEMBERS TO RETAIN. ALL
SIX OF THEIR EXEMPTS THAT.
STAFF FOR THE REMAINDER OF THE
FISCAL YEAR.
FOR THE PURPOSES OF THE REVIEW
FINANCE ADMITTED SERVICE EACH
WORD MEMBERS OFFICE REQUESTS AND
DETAILED INFORMATION ON THE
WORKLOAD. FOR EACH OF THEIR
TWELVE STAFF.
SPECIFICALLY WE ASKED FOR A
BREAKDOWN.
OF A NUMBER OF HOURS EACH STAFF
SPAT IN THE TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN
COUNTY YOUR.
INVOLVED IN NINE CATEGORIES OF
WORK
I THESE CATEGORIES ARE DEVELOPED
BASED ON THE MISSION SCOPE OF
DOE PRIOR TO AB ONE A TO
ENACTMENT.
WE RECEIVED SURVEYS BACK FROM
EACH BOARD MEMBERS OFFICE.
BASED ON OUR ANALYSIS OF THE
QUANTIFIABLE WHAT WOULD
REDUCTIONS WE EXPECT TO SEE AN
OVERALL WORKLOAD DECREASE OF
ABOUT THIRTY PERCENT.
HE'S PROBABLY SEEN IN THREE
WORKLOAD CATEGORIES.
RESEARCHING AND RESPONDING TO
INQUIRIES REGARDING TAX MATTERS
WE EXPECT TO SEE REDUCTION
EQUIVALENT TO FOUR PERCENT TOTAL
WORKLOAD.
ASSISTING WITH MATTERS RELATED
TO TAX APPEALS WE EXPECT TO SEE
A REDUCTION EQUIVALENT TO TWENTY
FOUR PERCENT OF TOTAL WORKLOAD.
AND PERFORMING CONSTITUENT
TAXPAYERS EDUCATION AVERAGE
RESPECT SEE REDUCTION EQUIVALENT
TO THREE PERCENT OF TOTAL
WORKLOAD.
OTHER WORKLOAD CARRIERS I SHOULD
SEE VARIABLE DECLINE BUT THEY'RE
NOT READILY QUANTIFIABLE.
OVERALL RECOMMENDED STAFFING
LEVEL FOR EACH OFFICES EIGHT
POSITIONS.
WE NOT BAD THE TO THE ONGOING
TRANSITION ADMINISTRATION
CONTINUE TO REVISIT THIS ISSUE
TO CONSIDER WHETHER THEY WERE
GONNA LEVELS ARE PROPRIA AND
LONG TERM.
WITH THAT WOULD BE HAVE TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS. OIL.
THANK YOU ARE BASED ON OUR
REVIEW OF THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCES REPORT AND THE DATA
SUBMITTED BY BOARD MEMBERS WE
THINK.
THAT FINANCES APPROACH LIKELY
OVER ESTIMATES THE BOARD
STAFFING REQUIREMENTS.
BUT BEFORE THE LEGISLATURE GETS
INTO SPECIFICS ABOUT THE NUMBER
OF POSITIONS THERE'S.
A BIGGER PICTURE DECISION MAKE
WHICH IS HOW TO.
STRUCTURE BOARD MEMBERS OFFICES
ARE CURRENTLY. GOVERNMENT CODE
ONE FIVE SIX ZERO ZERO AFTER
AUTHORIZES ONE DISTRICT OFFICE
AND ONE OFFICE IN SACRAMENTO FOR
EACH.
BOARD MEMBER HOWEVER THE TWENTY
SEVENTEEN BUDGET ACT.
STATED THE LEGISLATURE'S INTENT.
FOR THE BOARD MEMBERS TO BE
REGAL LOCATED IN TO ONE STATE ON
SPACE AS THEIR.
LEASES EXPIRE.
SO.
BEFORE SCRIPT DECIDING UPON A
LEVEL FUNDING THE LEGISLATURE
SHOULD CONSIDER WHAT DEGREE OF
BOARD MET OFFICE CONSOLIDATION
IT DESIRES AND SO. CORRESPONDING
TO THAT BIGGER PICTURE DECISION
WE HAVE A TWO PART
RECOMMENDATION CORRESPONDING TO.
TWO POSSIBLE PATHS THAT THE
LEGISLATURE COULD TAKE ON THAT
PARTICULAR DECISION.
I'VE THE LEGISLATURE WISHES TO
MAINTAIN THE CURRENT STRUCTURE
WITH.
I EIGHT SEPARATE OFFICES WITH
COMPLETELY SEPARATE STAFF FOR
EACH BOARD MEMBER. ARE UNDER
THAT SCENARIO WE WOULD RECOMMEND
THAT THE LEGISLATURE AUTHORIZED
I SIX POSITIONS PER BOARD
MEMBER.
IF INSTEAD THE LEGISLATURE IS
INTERESTED IN A GREATER DEGREE
OF CONSOLIDATION. OF OFFICE
CONSOLIDATION IT'S POSSIBLE BUT
THE LEGISLATURE COULD ACHIEVE.
SOME ADDITIONAL SAVINGS BY
HAVING.
ALL BOARD MEMBERS COOL THEIR
STAFF RESOURCES TO A GREATER
DEGREE THAN THEY WOULD UNDER
THAT SCENARIO.
AND SERVE AS NOTED IN THE.
.
AGENDA WE HAD ORIGINALLY
REFERRED TO THE SECOND
RECOMMENDATION WE LABEL THAT
LONG TERM BUT.
IT'S UNDERSTANDING ACTUALLY
THAT ALL FOUR OF THE BOARD
MEMBERS SACRAMENTO OFFICE LEASES
EITHER WILL EXPIRE OR WILL MOVE
TO SOFT TERM.
BETWEEN MARCH AND JULY OF TWENTY
NINETEEN SO.
.
PLAUSIBLY THIS YEAR'S BUDGET
PROCESSES IS A KEY DECISION
POINT WHEN IT COMES TO THAT.
.
DECISION ABOUT THE DEGREE OF
CONSOLIDATION THAT THE
LEGISLATURE TO.
REALLY.
HI THERE MIDDLE SHARE GEORGE
RUNNER CHAIR THE BOARD OF
EQUALIZATION.
AMONG THEM I'M TO MAKES IN
GENERAL COMMENTS IN REGARDS THAT
AND THEN OBVIOUSLY UP HERE YOU
HAVE.
IN KENNY THE ET AND.
WE ALSO HAVE BEEN FLEMING OUR
DEPUTY.
AND SELL LET ME JUST SPEAK IN
GENERAL ARE TO SOME OF THE
RECOMMENDATIONS AND AND THOUGHTS
THAT WERE LAID OUT THERE. ALSO
HAVE.
BOARD MEMBER STAFF IS AVAILABLE
HERE AYE AND WILL PROBABLY
EITHER MAKE COMMENT OR WILL
AGREE OR DISAGREE TO SOME
DEGREE.
IN REGARDS TO THE SHOULD THE
THE THESE ISSUES.
.
FIRST OF ALL LET ME JUST LAY OUT
A COUPLE THINGS IN TERMS OF THE
STAFF COMMENTS I THINK THE STAFF
COMMENTS THAT YOU HAVE. ARE
ACTUALLY LAY OUT THE CONCERNS
THAT WE WOULD WE WOULD AGREE
WITH.
I THINK THERE'S TWO MAIN ISSUES
THERE.
THE THE FIRST COMMENT IN
REGARDS TO THE ISSUE OF THE
NUMBER OF STAFF.
I THINK GENERALLY SPEAKING ARE
ALL OF US OF BOARD MEMBERS ARE
IN AGREEMENT WITH THE ISSUE OF
EIGHT STAFF WE THINK WE CAN WORK
WITHIN THAT. I KNOW MEMBER
HORTON HAS A LITTLE DIFFERENT
OPINION I THINK SOME OF YOU HAVE
RECEIVED MEMBER HORTON'S.
CORRESPONDENTS IN REGARDS TO
THAT ALSO I THINK SOME DETAILED
CORRESPONDS CITIES GIVEN IN
REGARDS TO WHAT HE SEES A SOME
LEGAL CHALLENGES IN REGARDS TO
THE ISSUE IN REGARDS TO UP.
CIVIL SERVICE EMPLOYEES TO THE
ELECTED OFFICE SO I THINK THOSE
ARE YOU GOT THOSE I'M SURE THOSE
OF THE EFFORT FOR FOR DISCUSSION
BUT GENERALLY SPEAKING. THE
EIGHT STAFF IS SOMETHING THAT WE
THINK WE CAN ACTUALLY WORK
WITHIN.
WHAT WE ARE CONCERNED ABOUT
THAT IS THE NATURE THOUGH STAFF?
ALL RIGHT NOW THE WAY THE STAFF
LAYS OUT IS THAT WE HAVE TWELVE
AND THAT WOULD BE.
SIX THAT ARE EXEMPT AND SIX
THAT ARE CIVIL SERVICE UNDER THE
RECOMMENDATION THAT'S THERE IT
GOES TO TWO ONE SIX.
CHALLENGE THAT WE HAVE A HIGH IN
REGARDS TO THE ISSUE OF TO
EXEMPT IS THE NATURE OF OUR
WORK.
AS ELECTED OFFICIALS I THINK
IT'S VERY WE WE NEED SOME
FLEXIBILITY AND I GET LITTLE GO
AGAIN THE ISSUE A FIFTY FIFTY
SPLIT GIVES US SOME OF THAT
FLEXIBILITY RIGHT NOW. BUT THE
LIMIT US THEN TO TO I IN TERMS
THE EXEMPT STAFF ISSUES I THINK
CREATES AN ADDITIONAL ISSUES FOR
US REGARD STOOD THAT LIMITS THAT
ARE THERE. WHEN IT COMES TO
CIVIL SERVICE EMPLOYEES
AND THAT'S A CHALLENGE WOULD
LIKE TO CONTINUE TO TALK THROUGH
A WE THINK THAT THAT AGAIN WE
CAN WORK WITHIN THE CONFINES AND
BE APPROPRIATE REGARDS TO HOW
STAFF ASSIGNMENTS ARE MADE.
YOU KNOW ONE SINCE I THINK AND
I GUESS I COME BACK TO YOU AS A
FORMER MEMBER BOTH IN THE
LEGISLATURE IN THE IN THE SENATE
AND THE ASSEMBLY. IN THAT I
THINK PART OF THE ISSUE THAT'S
UNIQUE IN THAT I HOPE YOU
UNDERSTAND THAT IS WHEN YOU CAME
INTO YOUR OFFICE.
YOU HAD BASICALLY CONTROL OF
YOUR STAFF IN TERMS OF WHO THEY
WERE WHAT THEY WERE DOING AS YOU
GOT ELECTED YOU MADE YOUR CHOICE
IN THE NOW AND AND AND AND AND
ASSIGNMENTS.
THAT'S VERY THAT WE'RE IN THAT
SAME SENSE OF WERE ELECTED
OFFICIALS.
AND SO THE START WITH ELECTED
OFFICIALS THAT ACTUALLY THAT
HAVE TWO THIRDS OF OUR STAFF.
THAT HERB BETTER BY DESIGNATION
CIVIL SERVANTS MEANS THAT
THEY'RE ALREADY ASSIGNED TO YOU.
IN LIGHT OF THE FACT THAT TELL
YOU DIDN'T HAVE ANYTHING TO DO
WITH OUR INTERVIEWS OR ANY OF
THAT PROCESS BUT YET THEY'RE
SERVING YOU THERE YOUR SECTION
S. THERE THE PEOPLE WHO ARE
WORKING IN YOUR OFFICE. IN MANY
DIFFERENT HUESO AGAIN MORE
FLEXIBILITY I THINK IS IMPORTANT
THERE WE THINK THAT THE EIGHT IS
A GOOD NUMBER WE DISAGREE UP
WITH WITH THE LA SHOWS.
WORK WE'VE GIVEN MORE
INFORMATION WE DIDN'T WE WE HAD
NO CONVERSATIONS WITH THE ALEJO
AND I THINK NOW THE OFFICES
DEBT.
WE HAVE GIVEN THEM THE
INFORMATION THOUGH SINCE THEN
WE'RE ASKING THEM TO DIALOGUE
WITH US ON ON THAT ISSUE.
IN IN REGARDS THAT.
THE OTHER ISSUE I THINK THAT I
WANT TO SPEAK TO IN REGARDS TO
THE SIZE OF STAFF.
WHILE THE FOOTPRINT OF THE BE.
WE MET RESPONSIBILITY IS
SMALLER NO DOUBT ABOUT THAT
THE FACT IS THERE OTHER SERVICES
TO WHICH WE NO LONGER HAVE
ACCESS TO.
FOR INSTANCE.
IN IT IN IN THIS IS MUCH LIKE
YOUR OFFICES IF YOU'RE TO CHOOSE
TO DO A SEMINAR SOMEWHERE YOU
HAVE YOUR CAUCUS STAFF THAT
HELPS YOU DO A LOT OF THAT WORK.
THAT SUPPLIES YOU INFORMATION
THAT MAKES A LOT OF THE
ARRANGEMENTS FOR YOU.
WE USED TO HAVE WHEN WE ARE THE
BE ALL WE TOTAL WE USED TO HAVE
AN OUTREACH THAT.
THAT WOULD TAKE CARE OF SOME OF
THOSE THINGS WE'RE DOING A
SEMINAR THOSE NO LONGER EXISTS
TO US IN FACT IN LAST YEAR'S
LEGISLATION THERE'S A BIG
FIREWALL PUT UP THERE.
AND SO NOW ALL OF THOSE SERVICES
THAT USED TO BE STAFF OR HELPED
IN TERMS OF STOPPING WHEN IT
COMES TO THE ISSUE OF SIR OUTS
REACH SERVICES FOR INSTANCE
THOSE ISSUES. NO LONGER
AVAILABLE WHICH MEANS ALTHOUGH
SERVICES HAVE TO BE DONE IN THE
HOUSE WITH OUR OWN STAFF.
UP FOR INSTANCE GIVING OTHER
SMALL ONE WEB SERVICES
WE USED TO BE ABLE TO CALL ON
OUR WEB SERVICE FOLKS IN ORDER
TO HELP US WORK WITH ISSUES
ABOUT PUTTING PRESS RELEASES
UPPER OR OR OR MAKING
ANNOUNCEMENTS. WE NO LONGER HAVE
THE ABILITY TO DO THAT.
IN FACT
WHAT THE DEPARTMENTS HAVE TOLD
US WERE SUPPOSED TO BE SERVICING
US IS YOU NEED TO HAVE A
SPECIALIST IN YOUR OFFICE.
IN ORDER TO DO THAT ALL THIS IS
PUT MORE DEMAND ON US IN THOSE
AREAS NOT LAST SO I WON'T LAY
THOSE OUT THERE. THE OTHER ISSUE
THAT WE WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK TO
REQUEST LIKE.
AND THAT IS THE ISSUE OF
TRANSITION.
WE DO NOT AGREE WITH WHAT THE
THOUGHTS WERE IN REGARDS TO TO
FINANCE IN REGARDS TO SOMEHOW
THE EIGHT WAS ALREADY DECIDED
LAST YEAR.
NOW WE BELIEVE AGAIN IN THE
CONVERSATIONS THAT TOOK PLACE
THAT THE PURPOSE OF ASKING FANS
TO GIVE A REPORT THIS YEAR IN
APRIL WAS IN ORDER TO MAKE THOSE
DECISIONS THIS YEAR.
AND SO WE THINK THIS IS AN
IMPORTANT ISSUE BECAUSE WE THINK
WHAT WE NEED TO DO NOW THAT
WE'VE COME UP WITH THE NUMBER.
THAT WE WE NEED TO DO IS
TRANSITION THEN THROUGH THIS
YEAR.
THE FACT IS THAT TAKING TWELVE
PEOPLE ARE TAKING SELF HAPPENED
CUTTING THEM BY. TELLING FOR
THEM MEANS A SOME OF THOSE
PEOPLE BY BY BASICALLY THE
PASSING A BUDGET WILL LEAST LOSE
THEIR JOBS.
IT'S INTERESTING TO SOME OF
THOSE PEOPLE INDEED COULD BE
CIVIL SERVICE PEOPLE AND THAT'S
WHY I BROUGHT IT IT'S VERY
UNIQUE IN OUR SITUATIONS THAT
MANY OF OUR CIVIL SERVICE
PEOPLE.
DON'T DON'T HAVE RETURN RIGHTS
TO THE TAX AGENCIES.
AND SO WE HAVE CIVIL SERVICE
EMPLOYEES THAT BASICALLY HAVE.
TURN RIGHTS.
THE BILL WE MEMBERS OFFICE BUT
THE POSITIONS HAVE BEEN CUT IN
THE BE ALWAYS OUT MEMBERS OFFICE
SO THEY PERCEIVE THEY ARE CIVIL
SERVICE EMPLOYEES WITHOUT RETURN
RIGHTS.
OUR AND WE THINK THAT THAT'S A
THAT'S A PROBLEM SO WE THINK
AGAIN TRANSITIONING MAKES SENSE.
HELPING US THEN A THEN UP
THROUGH THIS YEAR AND THEN
MAKING THOSE ADJUSTMENTS THEN
FOR JANUARY FIRST MAKES A LOT OF
SENSE SO. THOSE ARE MY COMMENTS.
AGAIN I'M I'M SURE THAT SOME OF
THESE OTHER MEMBERS WOULD LIKE
TO MAKE COMMENTS OR
REPRESENTATIVES MOTHER MEMBERS
OFFICES MORE WHERE POSITIONAL OF
MISS HARKNESS SAYS MOMENT MINUTE
MANY MEMBERS OF MY STAFF.
VOLUNTARILY RESIGNED THEIR
POSITIONS DO OTHER WRESTLING
IMPLEMENT OPPORTUNITIES DECISION
TO LEAVE WAS BASED IN PART ON
THE POSSIBLE CHANGES WHICH THEY
REFERRED FOR MAYBE ONE OR TWO
RIGHT SO THE INFERENCE WAS THAT
IS GOING TO HAPPEN. IF ILLEGAL
COULD COMMENT ON THE EXAM I'M
SORRY FINANCE ON THE EXEMPT
EMPLOYEES.
ON THAT ISSUE.
AND I'M KRYSTLE PARTNER FINANCE
IN TERMS OF THE PROPOSED LEVEL
STAFFING FOR EXEMPTS.
WHEN WE WHEN WE GET OUR REPORT
WE JUST LOOKED AT OVERALL
WORKLOAD. DEMANDS AND SO WE WERE
LOOKING AT EXEMPTS THE SUPPOSED
TO CIVIL SERVICE PER SE FOR
MAKING FINAL RECOMMENDATIONS
WORDS LOOKING OVERALL WORKLOAD.
AND I JUST CANCELED OUT TO
THIRTY PERCENT.
DECLINE IS WHAT WE'RE SEEING
AND THAT DOES CORRESPOND TO THE.
.
THE LOSS OF THE FOR EXAMPLE
SESSIONS THAT. ARE SUPPOSED TO
TERMINATE AT THE END OF THE
CURRENT FISCAL YEAR PURSUANT TO
ARM THE PROVISIONAL LANGUAGE IN
THE BUDGET ACT SO. ON THAT'S HOW
WE FIND OURSELVES WITH THAT
RECOMMENDATION.
BUDGET TING.
IT'S JUST A QUESTION FURTHER FOR
THE CHAIR COMMUTE COULD YOU
DESCRIBE THE ARM.
AT LEAST WITH YOUR PERSONAL
HISTORY THE THE SIX CIVIL
SERVICE STOP WITH THOSE STAFF
ASSIGNED TO YOU BASED ON. BURN
THE RECEIPT YOU INHERITED OR DID
YOU HIRE THEM AND THEY HAD TO GO
THROUGH THE PROCESS OR DID YOU
HAVE TO HIRE THEM FOR THE GOOD
AND GOOD HEARTEDNESS IT'S A GOOD
QUESTION BECAUSE IT'S A BET IT'S
BEEN A BIT OF THAT A BIT OF A
MOVING TARGET.
TRADITIONALLY.
WHEN A BOARD MEMBER WAS ELECTED.
AT THE BO WE.
AND WE CAME INTO THAT OFFICE
THERE WERE ALWAYS SOME CIVIL
SERVICE IN THERE WAS ALWAYS SOME
EXEMPT.
IN THE PAST WHAT WOULD TAKE
PLACE AGAIN BE A WE WITH A VERY
BIG ORGANIZATION THAT POINT.
SO AT THE PASS IN THAT POINT
WHAT WOULD HAPPEN IS THE
INCOMING BOARD MEMBER. WOULD
LOOK AT THEIR STAFF AND WE
DETERMINE WELL I'M I THINK I'D
LIKE TO.
THE COULD BASICALLY CHIU CIVIL
SERVANTS IN THE SENSE OF OF OF
OF IF SOMEBODY NEEDED TO MOVE ON
THEY COULD MOVE AMMAN. BUT THAT
WHAT HAPPENED IS THAT THE DEAL
WE SEE.
ADMINISTRATIVE STAFF WOULD
ABSORB THEM WITHIN THE BILL WE
ORGANIZATION.
SO THEY NEVER LOSE A POSITION AT
THAT POINT.
THEY ALWAYS THEN STAY WITHIN THE
BE.
WE THEY WOULD GO INTO
HEADQUARTERS ARE GOING TO
DISTRICT OFFICE OR SOMEWHERE
LIKE THAT.
AT THAT POINT THEN THERE WOULD
BE A NEW SOLICITATION.
FOR A CIVIL SERVICE POSITION TO
WHICH THEN THE BOARD MEMBERS NOR
MEMBER WAS INVOLVED IN.
NOW THE NEWER INTERPRETATION OF
WHAT'S TAKING PLACE AS I
UNDERSTAND IT IS THAT THAT WAS
NOT A PROPER PROCESS
AGAIN IT WAS JUST THE ONE THAT
THE PROCESS THAT WAS IN PLACE
FOR AS FAR AS I KNOW FOREVER.
NOW THE PROCESS TIAS FOR CIVIL
SERVANTS WHO ARE EXISTING IN A
CERTAIN IN A MEMBER'S OFFICE
LIKE IN MINE. A NEW MEMBER MORE
MEMBER COMES UP IN. THEY
BASICALLY HAVE THOSE CIVIL
SERVANTS.
THERE'S NO CHOICES AT THAT POINT
THEY STAY IN THAT OFFICE YOU
DON'T HAVE THE ABILITY TO MOVE
THEM OR MAKE THEM OR ABSORB
THEM.
QUITE FRANKLY IT'S A PRACTICAL
ISSUE TO NOW WITH THE SMALLNESS
OF THE VIEW WE THERE JUST NOT
THAT MANY PLACES TO PUT SOMEBODY
RIGHT. SO THAT'S PART OF THE
ISSUE.
AND AGAIN.
ONE THE ONE OF THE ON IT
UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES OF LAST
YEAR WAS AGAIN THIS ISSUE OF OF
RETURN RIGHTS.
WE'VE CIVIL SERVANTS WHO
BASICALLY HAVE NO RETURN RIGHTS
NOW.
AND I DON'T AGREE WITH THE
INTERPRETATION THAT HAS BEEN
MADE BY SOME OF THE ARM THREE A
HUMAN RESOURCES DEPARTMENTS IN
REGARDS THE FACT SOME OF MY
STAFF WHO ORIGINALLY WERE IT
WOULD BE A WE. SHOULD HAVE
RETURN RIGHTS BACK TO THE TAX
AGENCIES RIGHT NOW THEY DON'T.
AND INTER IN AND SO AS A RESULT
OF THAT IF THEY WERE TO LOSE
THEIR POSITION. THEY BASICALLY
END UP.
WITHOUT PROTECTION BUT THE SAME
THE EMPLOYEES IN THE CAPITAL TO
THOUGH.
RIGHT NOW YOU DON'T HAVE CIVIL
SERVICE IN THE CAPITAL SEE
THAT'S THE DIFFERENCE IT YOU'RE
EXACTLY RIGHT A MISTER CHAIRMAN
THAT'S EXACTLY WHAT HAPPENS BUT
YOUR PEOPLE ARE NOT PROTECTED
WITH CIVIL RIGHTS OR CIVIL CIVIL
SERVICE PROTECTION. WILL FOURTH
OCCUR AT ITS DEBT PRIOR STATUS.
IN CIVIL SERVICE.
THEY COULD GO BACK GO BACK YES
BUT HERE'S THE PROBLEM THE
PROBLEM IS IF SOMEBODY FOR
INSTANCE WITH SOME PEOPLE ON A
BEEN IN OUR IN OUR OFFICES.
PRIOR TO ME THEY'VE BEEN THEY'VE
BEEN IN MEMBERS OFFICES FOR
GOODNESS SAKE I THINK GO TO TO
TO.
.
FIFTEEN SIXTEEN YEARS THEY
NEVER WORKED WITHIN THE TAX
AGENCY.
BUT THEY'VE BEEN A BILL WE
EMPLOYEE.
THEY JUST WORK IN OFFICE THEY
HAVE NO PLACE TO RETURN TO THEN
UNDER THIS UNDER THIS SCENARIO
SO AGAIN WE THINK IT CAN BE FOR.
THERE'S A COUPLE THINGS TO FIX
THAT NUMBER ONE.
IF YOU JUST GIVE RETURN RIGHTS
TO TO BE A WE EMPLOYEES BACK TO
THE TAX AGENCIES THAT WOULD
SOLVE THAT PROBLEM.
THE OTHER ISSUE IS AGAIN GIVE A
LITTLE MORE FLEXIBILITY TO THE
INCOMING MEMBER BY TRADING OFF
AT LEAST.
YOU KNOW GOING FROM AT LEAST TWO
TO FOUR AND THAT GIVES A LITTLE
MORE FLEXIBILITY BUT STILL MEANS
THAT THE BOARD MEMBERS CAN HAVE
TO KEEP SOME OF THE STAFF THAT
THE COME INTO. AS THEY COME INTO
OFFICE.
SO JUST JUST TO CLARIFY SO YOU
SEE YOU.
YOU FEEL THAT THE YOU AND SOME
OF THE OTHER MEMBERS NOT NOT ALL
IN THE SAME ITEM. WOULD BE OPEN
TO UP FOR EXEMPT AND FORCE OF.
THAT'S AN IMPROVEMENT OVER WHAT
IS
PRESENTED BEFORE US WITH THE
FINANCE WORK MANAGING GIVES US
ENOUGH FLEXIBILITY WE WOULD
BELIEVE THAT SO SO YOU'RE NOT
GONNA GET THE MORE FLEXIBILITY
THE BETTER OF HIM I THINK I'VE
GOT SOME OTHER MEMBERS WOULD SAY
THEY SHOULD ALL BE EXEMPT RIGHT.
BUT I THINK ANY MOVEMENT TOWARD.
TOWARD AN ADDITIONAL NUMBER
GIVES US MORE FLEXIBILITY
SO THE IDEAL SITUATION WOULD BE
TO HAVE ALL A. B. EXAM VERY
SIMILAR TO WHAT IT IS THAT YOU
HAVE IN YOUR OFFICE.
THANK YOU.
AND I JUST WOULD LIKE TO RAISE
ONE POINT COM FIRST FINANCES ARE
PROPOSALS NOT REDUCING THE CIVIL
SERVICE STAFF AT ALL. AND
SECONDLY.
IF FOR SOME REASON THE CIVIL
SERVICE STAFF MEMBER REDUCED IF
YOU'RE HIRED TO THE CIVIL
SERVICE PROCESS SUPPORT
EQUALIZATION AND SUBSEQUENTLY
SIGNED A BOARD MEMBER.
BASED ON MY UNDERSTANDING HOW
CIVIL SERVICE WORK SHE WOULD
HAVE RETURN RIGHTS TO THAT
AGENCY.
IT'S LIKE A PARTNER FINANCED
WITH PEOPLE WE FINANCE ALL THE
TIME TO TAKE JOBS THE
LEGISLATURE THEY WOULD HAVE
RETURN RIGHTS BACK TO FINANCE
THAT IS NOT THE WAY THAT THE
THAT THAT HUMAN RESOURCES IS
RESPONDING AYE OF INDIVIDUALS IN
MY OFFICE THAT ACTUALLY.
CAME AT THAT CAME OUT OF THE
LATE KIM LEGISLATE ROOM
LEGISLATURE WENT AND WORKED FOR
THE BILL WE AND THEN CAME FROM
THE EFFORT FOR A PERIOD OF TIME
THEN CAME TO MY OFFICE. AND
THEY'VE BEEN TOLD AND I WAS IN
THERE AND I WAS IN THE MEETING
WITH THEM WITH WITH WITH
CALLAHAN THAT KELLY CHORE BUT
WITH THE TAXI DID SEE.
THAT THEY DID NOT HAVE THOSE
RIGHTS SO AGAIN I I DISAGREE
WITH THEIR INTERPRETATION I DO
AGREE WITH YOURS THAT THAT
THAT'S BILL WE HR I.
BUT TALK.
WE DON'T HAVE ONE.
WE DON'T HAVE ANYONE KNOW WHERE
NOW SERVICES THAT THEY JUST KNOW
I'M ONE THING IS YOUR THING.
PRIOR WRITTEN ABOUT KELLY CHORE
THAN NO NO PRIOR PRIOR WE HAD
OUR OWN HR WHAT AT THAT TIME
TALKING ABOUT SO WITH THAT THE
PRIORY CHARGE THEY KNOW THAT WAS
THE CURRENT OKAY JUST WHICH IS
AGAIN A. WHICH IS THE TAX AGENCY
WHO NOW IS GIVING US.
SERVICE.
YET DEPARTMENT JACKSON BUTTE
MINISTRY RIGHT PROVIDES THEIR
HUMAN RIGHT HUMAN RESOURCES.
WE WILL CERTAINLY LOOK INTO THAT
FOREVER.
THAT THAT IS SO FULL OF OF THE
CIVIL SERVICE YEAH I'M IT WOULD
LOWER HIS OR WE BEGIN AGAIN I
THINK THE BROADER THAT'S IT
THAT'S AT ISSUE THAT OUGHT TO BE
ADDRESSED BUT. BROADER ISSUE IN
REGARDS WHAT'S BEFORE YOU IS I
THINK THE NUMBER THE LEVEL OF
STAFF IN THOSE CONDITIONS CAN
MAKE ONE QUICK REMARK IN REGARDS
TO THE ISSUE THE BILL WE ABOUT
CONDUCTS HOLIDAYING STAFF ISSUES
ARE WITH ONE OFFICE.
AGAIN MY OFFICE IS A LITTLE BIT
DIFFERENT IN THAT MIKE
SACRAMENTO OFFICE AT MY DISTRICT
OFFICE ON A LITTLE BIT DIFFERENT
IN THE SENSE OF THE OTHER BOARD
MEMBERS.
IN THAT SENSE ARM.
BUT THE PROBLEM WILL BE WITH
ASSURING STAFF IS WE BAGLEY
KEENE ISSUES.
AND SO ALL OF A SUDDEN YOU HAVE
STAFF THAT ARE SERVICING TWO
DIFFERENT MEMBERS.
IT BECOMES A PROBLEM IN REGARDS
TO CONVERSATIONS THAT TAKE PLACE
BETWEEN THOSE INDIVIDUALS
MEMBERS AND THEIR STAFF BECAUSE
THEY'RE STAFF IS NO LONGER JUST
THERE'S.
SO I THINK IT BEGS BAGLEY KEENE
QUESTIONS AND ISSUES THAT I
WOULD BE CAN.
IN THE COURSE ISN'T COMMITTEE.
I DON'T MEMBERS.
ARE GOING UP AND UP ERNIE COMES
FROM.
NUMBER NUMBER STAFF.
BOB WE'RE JUST HERE TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS THE COMMITTEE MAY
HAVE.
OKAY.
JOHN OF EACH APPOINTED CHIEF OF
STAFF TO VICE CHAIR FIONA MA. ON
IN REGARDS TO THE THEY ANALYSIS.
YEAH I'M NOT SURE IF.
STAFF SCOPE OF WORK WAS ANALYZE
BETWEEN ON.
EXEMPT AND CIVIL SERVICE
BECAUSE.
BASED ON THE ANALYSIS OF THE
RECOMMENDATIONS THERE IS A
REDUCTION IN A SCOPE OF WORK AND
TAX RELATED NEXUS.
WORK HOWEVER.
.
YOUR RECOMMENDATION THAT
DEPARTMENT FINANCE
RECOMMENDATION IS NOT TO
DECREASE CIVIL SERVICE STAFF
HOWEVER MOST OF THAT WORK IN OUR
OFFICE.
ON. AND I TO SPEAK ON BEHALF OF
OUR OFFICE IS WITHIN CIVIL
SERVICE
AND SO WE WOULD PREFER THAT
THESE POSITIONS ARE ARE EXEMPT.
THE ZIP THIS IS OUR STATUE
CORRECT.
CRACKED.
BUT AND I AM JUST MAKING A NOTE
A BASED ON THE YOU THE
RECOMMENDATIONS OF
RECOMMENDATIONS IS BASED ON
STOCK PRODUCTION.
BUT MOST OF OUR.
CIVIL SERVICE POSITIONS CARRY.
TAX COUNSEL THREES AND TAX ON.
TAX SERVICE POSITIONS WITH THE
QUESTION WOULD BE HOW THE BILL
YOU WHO THE WORKLOAD COMPARE NOW
TO PREVIOUS YEARS.
SOURCE HEARINGS.
SO I.
OUR AND WORKLOAD HAS DECREASED
DRAMATIC DRAMATICALLY.
HI A HAS BASED ON YOU KNOW
HEARINGS AS I AND YOU KNOW AS.
IN IN OUR EXPERIENCE HOWEVER.
AND AS.
CHAIR.
RUNNER HAS MENTIONED.
THE REPORTS TOLL ON REFLECT A
DECREASE IN RESOURCES AND THAT'S
WHAT I WANT IS TO SPEAK ABOUT
THERE WAS.
YOU NO THERE IS NO TRANSITION
TRAINING FOR BE IT FOR BOARD
MEMBER STAFF FOR BOARD MEMBERS
OF THERE'S NO EDUCATIONAL
MATERIALS AND I LIKE TO PASS OUT
SUMMITEERS OUR OFFICE HAS. HAS
DONE IN TERMS OF EDUCATION
OUTREACH TO OUR CONSTITUENTS WE
ARE STILL IN ELECTED OFFICE WE
STILL ARE OF OBLIGATED TO
EDUCATE OUR. CONSTITUENTS WE
STILL GET CALLS ABOUT UP BO EAST
OR CD TFA TAXES THAT WE STILL
HAVE TO NAVIGATE AND HELP
NAVIGATE OUR CONSTITUENTS
THROUGH THIS PROCESS THAT STILL
TAKES TIME. JUST BECAUSE WE GET
A CALL ON TAXES DOESN'T MEAN
WE'RE NOT GOING TO HELP OUR
CONSTITUENTS WHAT YOU KNOW AND I
THINK THAT'S A REALLY GOOD POINT
BECAUSE I THINK I AGAIN I THINK
THE IDEA OF THE FIRST NARROW THE
SMALLER FOOTPRINT I AGREE WITH
THE FACT IS. WE DON'T WE DON'T
CONTROL WHO CALLS OUR OFFICES.
AND SO FOR INSTANCE WHEN WE GET
A CALL ABOUT SOMEBODY WHO'S AT
THE INCOME TAX QUESTIONER THOSE
OTHER ISSUES I'M THEIR ELECTED
OFFICIALS.
WE END UP HAVING TO RESPOND TO
THOSE AND QUITE FRANKLY WE BACK
YOU GUYS UP IN THAT ISSUE TOO
BECAUSE THAT WE TAKE CARE OF
YOUR WE HAVE MUTUAL
CONSTITUENTS.
AND SO BY THAT TIME WE ARE
DEALING WITH THOSE INDIVIDUALS
AND SO THE IDEA OF ATTACKS
COUNSEL.
A CPA ARE VERY IMPORTANT FOR US
TO HELP GUIDE INDIVIDUAL.
CONSTITUENTS MUTUAL CONSTITUENTS
THAT WE ALL SHARE AGAIN IF THE I
WANNA GIVE YOU ONE MORE EXAMPLE
ABOUT FOOTPRINT EVEN OUR
FOOTPRINT IS SMALLER. OUR
RESOURCES THAT WE COULD CALL ON
NOW DON'T EXIST FOR INSTANCE IN
THE PAST IF I WANTED A BROCHURE
PRINTED.
IN ORDER TO TELL PEOPLE ABOUT
PROPERTY RIGHTS FOR VETERANS
I HAD A WHOLE AGENCY THAT WOULD
GO AHEAD AND SET THAT UP WORK ON
THAT DEAL WITH THAT. THAT NO
LONGER EXISTS FOR US.
ALL THAT HAS TO BE DONE NOW BY
OUR OWN STAFF.
AND SO.
AGAIN I GET WITH WITH WHAT WE'RE
TRYING TO DO AND IT WAS
ACCOMPLISHED BUT THE SAME TIME I
THINK WE NEED TO BE CAREFUL THAT
WE DON'T GO TOO FAR IN THEN
LIMITS OUR ABILITY TO MEET OUR
ALL OF OUR CONSTITUENTS IT WE
HAVE AWFUL CALLS TO. WRITE
COOPER FOR IN THOSE FOLKS
OBVIOUSLY FROM YOUR PHONE CALLS
REFERRING TO CTF A CERTAIN WELL
KNOW IT WELL AGAIN THERE AGAIN
THERE'S A DIFFERENCE BETWEEN
REFERRING A PHONE CALL AND
HELPING A CONSTITUENT THROUGH
THE PROCESS BY IS IF WE GET
THOSE SAME CLOCK NO DISTRICT
OFFICES SO. RIGHT JUST BECAUSE
YOU TAKE PHONE CALLS DOES MEAN
THAT.
RESULTS IN THEIR WORK PRODUCT
WELL TO DO A LOT OF REFERRAL
SING FOLKS ELSEWHERE WE ARE
THERE SOME PRODUCT THAT RESULTS
FROM THAT BUT. EVERY PHONE CALL
WAS NOT RESULT.
IN WORK BEING DONE WELL I AGREE
ALTHOUGH AT LAST YEAR WE HAD
FOUR THOUSAND CONTACTS WITH
CONSTITUENTS OF WHICH MOST OF
THEM TOOK MORE THAN ONE PHONE
CALL THEIR INDIVIDUALS WHO WERE
HELPING THROUGH A VERY CONFUSING
TAX PROCESS.
AND AS YOU KNOW ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT WE THAT WE USE TO
BUILD TO DO IS TAKE YOUR
CONCERNS AND GIVEN TO US AND
THEN WE WOULD DEAL WITH THE.
ARE AND SO I THINK AGAIN.
I ONLY SAID THE FOOTPRINT HAS
CHANGED BUT IT'S CHANGING A LOT
NUMBER OF DIFFERENT WAYS.
AGAIN GO BACK TO THE BASIC ISSUE
WE THINK IT WILL WORK WE JUST
NEED FLEXIBILITY.
IT ALSO HAS BEGUN THIS.
I GOT UP LOOKED OF PUBLIC
COMMENT.
USE OF THIS EFFORT.
I AM LEASE OR NOT A CHIEF OF
STAFF FOR DIANE HARKEY.
AND I COME FROM UNIQUE
PERSPECTIVE IN THAT I'M A THIRTY
YEAR VIEW EMPLOYEE. WHO HAPPENED
TO COME FROM WHAT IS NOW CITY
TFA?
I'M VERY CONCERNED ABOUT STAFF I
THINK WE NEED TO BE CONSIDERED
I'VE A THIRTY YEAR AUDITOR WHO'S
BEEN TOLD SHE MAY BE SURPLUS TO.
AND THAT SHOULDN'T HAPPEN OUR
STAFF SHOULD GO BACK TO SEA DUTY
IF THEY WHERE THEIR STRENGTHS
AND WE ALSO BELIEVE THAT OLIVER
STAFF SHOULD BE EXEMPT EMPLOYEES
OF VARYING LEVELS SIMILAR TO IT
LEGISLATIVE OFFICE.
SO THAT.
OUR CURRENT STAFF CAN GO BACK
TO WHERE THEY CAME OR WHETHER
SKILL SET ARE. AND THEN WE COULD
HAVE ON THE STAFF.
THAT WOULD PROVIDE THAT FOR THE
NEXT MEMBER THAT COMES AND COULD
HIRE WHO THEY WANT TO.
SIX.
PUT CURRY HAVING CHIEF OF STAFF
FOR BOARD MEMBER JOE MARTIN
THANK YOU CHAIR RUNNER FOR
GIVING A PRESENTATION TODAY. AND
WE ARE NOT IN DISAGREEMENT WITH
THE OTHER MEMBERS OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE ON THAT
NUMBER. THE EIGHT.
AND WE ARE OPEN TO.
WHATEVER MIX
THE DISCUSSIONS I WOULD JUST
HOPING THEIR OPEN DISCUSSIONS ON
THE NEXT STEP.
OF WHAT LEVEL OF SAPPY WE HAVE
PROFESSIONAL LEADING WHETHER
THEY'RE EXEMPT SEE EA'S OR A MIX
OF CIVIL SERVICE AND THAT. AND
WHERE HOW THOSE DISCUSSIONS ARE
GOING TO TAKE PLACE WE HAVE
PRESENTED YOU WITH ON A COUPLE
OF MEMOS WITH ATTACHMENTS THAT
WE'RE HOPING YOU WOULD CONSIDER
WE PROVIDED THEM TO THE ALLEY O.
AND DO AFTER WE'VE HAD. SOME
SHORT CONVERSATIONS WITH THEM
AND WE WERE HAPPY THAT YOU'RE
I'M OPEN TO INFORMATION AFTER
THE SURVEYS. WE'VE TRIED TO DO
ANY EIGHT SOME OF THE NUMBERS
ASSOCIATED WITH.
THE CONSTITUENT BASE WITH THE
REDUCED OR THE MORE FOCUSED A
WORKLOAD ASSOCIATED WITH ARE
CONSTITUTED CONSTITUTIONAL
DUTIES OF THE MEMBERS.
AYE A.
WOULD LIKE TO.
WE ALSO SUPPORT THAT THERE ARE
SOME ADDITIONAL ADMINISTRATIVE
TYPE OF WORKLOAD THAT HAS COME
TO THE MEMBERS OFFICES WERE NOT
ASKING FOR ADDITIONAL POSITIONS.
OVER THE EIGHT THAT DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE AYE RECOMMENDS WE
THINK THERE ARE SOME LEGAL
RESTRICTIONS THAT WOULD NOT
ALLOW MEMBERS TO CONSOLIDATE AND
SHARE STAFF. IN A SACRAMENTO
OFFICE ON THAT WE BE OPEN TO
THOSE DISCUSSIONS AS WELL.
.
AND AS FAR AS A TRANSITION
PERIOD REDUCING THIS IS A LITTLE
BIT OF A UNIQUE SITUATION.
POSITIONS ARE CUT IN BUDGET AXE
AND THERE ARE SURPLUS IN S. R.
AWAY LISTS THEIR CREATED FOR
OTHER DEPARTMENTS AND HISTORIES
CALIFORNIA. THIRTY FIVE YEARS
STATE EMPLOYEE I'M ONLY VAN WITH
A COLLECTED BOARD MEMBERS AN
EXACT POSITION FOR LESS THAN
FOUR YEARS. SO I DO UNDERSTAND
THERE IS THAT PROCESS IN THIS
CASE LIKE MR RUNNER HAD AN
ILLUSTRATED IS THAT. THESE
EMPLOYEES THAT CIVIL SERVICE
EMPLOYEES THAT MAY BE IMPACTED
BY THE NEXT BUDGET ACT AT THOSE
CIVIL SERVICE POSITIONS CHANGE
OF THEIR EXACT POSITIONS THAT
ARE. SET OF CIVIL SERVICE AND.
THEY WERE HIRED TO AN AGENCY AND
SO IN THE PAST.
.
ASSEMBLY RETAINING.
THE AGENCY ACTUALLY HIRED THE
CIVIL SERVICE EMPLOYEES THEY
BELONG TO THE POV.
AND WHENEVER THERE WAS A CHANGE
IN ASSIGNMENT BECAUSE AGENCIES
ARE ALLOWED TO CHANGE CIVIL
SERVICE ASSIGNMENTS WITHIN AN
AGENCY WITHOUT ADVERTISING IF
THERE IS A NEED TO TRANSFER
THEM.
SOMETIMES THAT DID OCCUR WHEN
BOARD MEMBERS.
TURNED OUT AND LEFT OFFICE IN
NEW MEMBERS CAME IN.
.
BUT THERE WAS NEVER AN ISSUE
THERE BECAUSE THEY WERE HIRED BY
THE DOD WHERE MEMBERS
PARTICIPATED IN INTERVIEWS AND
THE SELECTION PROCESS. THE
RECRUITMENT OF THOSE THINGS THE
HR MATTERS THE APPROVAL OF THOSE
THINGS THE. UP PROBATIONARY
PERIODS THE PERMANENT STATUS WAS
AT THE BOARD OF EQUALIZATION
THERE WAS NOT ANOTHER AGENCY CO
THAT WAS FOR BOARD MEMBERS
OFFICE.
AND SO IN THIS SITUATION I DO
BELIEVE THAT WE'RE INTERPRETING
UNLESS YOU CAN TELL US
DIFFERENTLY. THAT NOW WE ARE
FUNCTIONALLY AND BUDGETARY EARLY
INDEPENDENT FROM THE BE A WE AS
AN AGENCY ALMOST CREATING TWO
SEPARATE ENTITIES AND THESE
EMPLOYEES. THAT MAY HAVES AND
STARTED THEIR CAREERS AS
APPEALING PLAY PASS PROBATION AS
A BE A WE EMPLOYEE. AND NOW HAVE
ONLY RETURN RIGHTS TO IT WHERE
MEMBERS OFFICE IN A POSITION AT
WAIT MAY HAVE BEEN ELIMINATED SO
THROUGH A BUDGET ACT.
THEIR RETURN RIGHTS HAVE BEEN
ELIMINATED AND SO I WOULD JUST
SAY AND I DON'T KNOW HOW MANY IF
ANY THERE ARE BUT I THINK WE
SHOULD TAKE THAT INTO
CONSIDERATION AS WE LOOK THROUGH
A TRANSITION PROCESS.
AND.
SO WE WOULD ASK THAT YOU.
TAKE A LOOK AT SOME OF THE
INFORMATION THAT WE HAVE
PROVIDED. WE ALSO AND JUST HAVE
A LEGAL QUESTION WERE NOT SURE
HOPEFULLY MAYBE SOME AS WE
DISCUSS THE CLASSIFICATION. OF
THE POSITIONS OF THE MOVE BOARD
IS.
DO THE BOARD MEMBERS AS ELECTED
OFFICIALS HAD EXAM HAVE THE
LEGAL AUTHORITY TO HIRE CIVIL
SERVICE SO THERE ARE SOME
RESTRICTIONS THAT IS OUR IN THE
CURRENT DATA BUDGET AX.
THAT LIMIT OUR PARTICIPATION IN
BOARD EMPLOYEES WERE JUST
WONDERING WHETHER THAT FALLS
TRUE FOR A BOARD MEMBERS OFFICE
AS WELL BUT WE ARE NOT IN
DISAGREEMENT WITH THE NUMBER.
AND WE ARE HAPPY TO OF HAD.
OPEN DISCUSSIONS ABOUT
CLASSIFYING AND HOW THIS
COMMITTEE OR THE OTHER
COMMITTEES WILL DECIDE THAT.
OR TO HAVE A SPECIAL WITH CAL HR
ABOUT CIVIL SERVICE NAY
SIMPLICITY BRING THAT BACK THAT
THEY WILL ACTUALLY. TRYING TO
YOUR SEVERE. THE QUESTIONS YOU
FAST RECOVER ARE CLARIFIED.
YEAH AND I BELIEVE MISTER RUNNER
HAD TALKED ABOUT.
.
THE HR DEPARTMENT AT CD FTA THAT
IS PROVIDING THAT THE SERVICE
AND THE INFORMATION THAT
PROVIDING THE EMPLOYEES AND I.
BELIEVE THERE PROVIDING
INFORMATION BASED UPON THE
CURRENT SCENARIO AND SO IT'S
DIFFICULT FOR THEM TO GIVE US A
LEGAL ANSWER OF SOMETHING THAT.
HASN'T HAPPENED YET RIGHT.
SO WE WOULD REALLY APPRECIATE
KALINJAR SPV COMING AND AND.
I THINK I WOULD I IMPORTANT AND
WOULD BE GLAD TO GIVE THE GO
AHEAD AND TALK ABOUT INDIVIDUALS
BECAUSE THEY I GET REALITIES
THIS COMES DOWN TO REAL PEOPLE.
THIS A THESE ARE REAL PEOPLE WHO
ARE TRYING TO FIGURE OUT WHAT
THEIR NEXT JOB STATUS
SO IT WOULD BE REALLY GOOD TO
HAVE THAT CONVERSATION NO AND WE
WILL DO THAT'S RIGHT NOW ONE OF
THE PUBLIC COMMENT. YOU WISH TO
SPEAK ON THIS ITEM.
THAT THAT'S ONE THING THE STATE
BEING HERE I MEAN EVERY XEGS IS
HEATHER ON A CHARTER PARTNERSHIP
CAL HR. YOU GET DIFFERING
OPINIONS THAT'S ONE FRUSTRATING
THING WITH THE STATE.
IT'S LIKE I SAID I'VE HAD SOME
EXAMPLES ON THIS AND THAT'S ONE
THING WE GOT A CLEAR UP. AND FIX
THAT OVERALL THAT IS AN ISSUE I
AGREE WITH.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MARK A PRAYER I'M HERE
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ALLIANCE OF.
TAXPAYER ADVOCATES THERE IT
STATE WIDE TRADE ASSOCIATION
REPRESENTING PROPERTY TAX AGENTS
AND WE'RE NOT GOING TO GET INTO
THE DETAILS OF A EXEMPTS VERSUS
NON EXEMPT. BUT WE DO WANT TO
CAUTION THE COMMITTEE OF THAT AS
YOU'RE LOOKING AT THE BO EASE
BUDGET THAT THERE ARE EXISTING
RESPONSIBILITIES IN THE PROPERTY
TAX.
ARENA.
WHETHER THEY ARE FOLKS ARE
REPRESENTED BY A TAX AGENT OR
ARE CALLING ON THEIR OWN THEY
ARE STILL LOOKING TO THE BE AWAY
FOR INFORMATION OR HELP. THAT
THEY MAY I'LL. WISH A DIRECTION
OR INFORMATION THAT THEY CAN'T
GET.
FROM SOME OTHER SOURCE SO WE
WOULD JUST MAKE SURE THAT YOU
WOULD BE MINDFUL OF THAT. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. SO WITH ALL THIS
ITEM OPEN SWOOP ON OUR NEXT ITEM
ISSUE NUMBER SEVEN.
FRANCHISE TAX BOARD FIGHTING TAX
CREDIT TO THE BILL LANGUAGE
GOOD AFTERNOON THAT IT TAKES HIM
APARTMENT FINANCE.
.
THE ADMINISTRATION IS PROPOSING
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE TO CREATE
A CALIFORNIA HIRING CREDIT.
HOW THIS CREDIT WOULD BE AN
EXPANSION OF THE EXISTING NEW
EMPLOYMENT CREDIT? ON THE NEW
CREDIT IS CALCULATED TO THE SAME
SET THIRTY FIVE PERCENT OF
QUALIFIED WAGES HAS THE EXISTING
CREDIT. ON.
IT WOULD BE EXPANDED IN SEVERAL
WAYS BY GEOGRAPHY BY INDUSTRY BY
THE RANGE OF QUALIFIED RE A
WAGES.
HOW THE NEW CREDIT WOULD BE
AVAILABLE FOR HIRES HONOR AFTER
JANUARY FIRST TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN AND BEFORE JANUARY
FIRST TWO THOUSAND TWENTY FOUR?
A FOR ALL BUT A BACKGROUND IN
TWO THOUSAND THIRTEEN THE
LEGISLATURE ADOPTED SEVERAL
BILLS THAT. EMANATED ENTERPRISE
ZONE CREDITS NAM.
I CREATED NEW TAX INCENTIVES TO
ENCOURAGE ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT
CALIFORNIA.
ONE OF THE NEWLY CREATED TAX
INCENTIVES WAS NEW EMPLOYMENT
CREDIT.
THEIR CREDIT HOUSE HAS NOT BEEN
UTILIZE A VERY MUCH HOW THEY
HAVE TO BE HAS A WHICH WHICH
ADMINISTERS.
THE CREDIT REPORTS THERE WAS
LESS THAN FOUR MILLION CREDITS
CLAIMED IN TWO THOUSAND
FOURTEEN.
AND LESS THAN TWO MILLION EACH
IN TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN THE TWO
THOUSAND SIX.
THIS TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE
INTENDS TO CREATE A NEW CREDIT
THAT HAS THE SAME GOALS AS THE
ORIGINAL CREDIT. AND THAT IS TO
CREATE JOBS FOR CALIFORNIANS WHO
MAY STRUGGLE TO FIND.
HARD TO FIND WORK DUE TO THE
PERSONAL HISTORY.
A BUT THE THEN NEW CREDIT IS
DESIGNED TO BE MORE USEFUL A TO
BE UTILIZED FOR.
HOME IN ORDER TO PROVIDE A A
STRONGER INCENTIVE THE TRAILER
BILL. CREATES A CREDIT THAT
EXPANDS ON THE CURRENT CREDIT IN
SEVERAL WAYS.
OF FIRST THE WAY DRAIN FOR
QUALIFIED WAGES WOULD BE ONE
HUNDRED PERCENT TO THREE HUNDRED
FIFTY PERCENT OF MINIMUM WAGE
THE CURRENT OF THE CURRENT
CREDIT HAS A RANGE OF HUNDRED
FIFTY PERCENT THREE AND FIFTY
PERCENT.
THE NEW CREDIT WOULD APPLY TO
QUALIFIED HIRES AND ALL OF
CALIFORNIA AS OPPOSED TO JUST
DESIGNATED.
RETURNS IN CALIFORNIA.
FINALLY THE TYPE OF QUALIFIED
EMPLOYEES EMPLOYERS WOULD BE
EXPANDED UNDER THE NEW CREDIT.
TO INCLUDE RETAIL AND FOOD
SERVICES.
ANOTHER ANOTHER CHANGES AT THE
NEW CREDIT WOULD USE THE MAXIMUM
OF. THE LOCAL MINIMUM WAGE FOR
THE STATEWIDE MINIMUM WAGE AS
OPPOSED TO THE CURRENT CREDIT.
WHICH JUST RELIES ON THE
STATEWIDE MINIMUM WAGE.
THE TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE
RETAIN SEVERAL FEATURES OF THE
EXISTING OUR CREDIT.
THE CATEGORIES FOR QUALIFIED
EMPLOYEES SAY THE SAME LONG TERM
A A INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE LONG
TERM UNEMPLOYED. VETERANS EX
OFFENDERS RECIPIENTS OF CAL
WORKS OR HOME.
OUR GENERAL ASSISTANCE AND OF
RECIPIENTS OF THE FEDERAL EARNED
INCOME TAX CREDIT.
ADDITIONALLY OUT TO CLAIM THE
CREDITS EMPLOYERS ARE STILL
REQUIRED.
TO MAKE A CREDIT RESERVATION
WHEN THEY HIRE THE EMPLOYEE THE
QUALIFIED EMPLOYEE. THEIR
RECORDS A NET INCREASE IN JOBS
FOR THE YEAR AND ME. AND THEY'RE
REQUIRED TO CLAIM THE CREDIT ON
AN ORIGINAL FILED RETURN.
THE EXISTING CREDIT WOULD
CONTINUE TO EXIST FOR ANY
EMPLOYERS WHO WISH TO AVAIL
THEMSELVES OF THAT CREDIT AND
UNTIL IT'S NORMAL SUNSET DATE.
I AND WE WOULD INCLUDE LANGUAGE
IN THE TRAILER BILL TO PRECLUDE
A EMPLOYER FROM TAKING THE SAME
CREDIT FOR ONE SET HER UP.
DID THE TWO CREDITS FOR ONE
EMPLOYEE.
ARMED THE NEW CREDIT IS EXPECTED
TO COST ABOUT FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS A YEAR ONCE IT IS FULLY
PHASED.
I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS.
THE OIL.
OF BROWN WITH THE FORD AT THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE THE
ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSAL WOULD
PROVIDE A STRONGER INCENTIVE A
TO BUSINESSES TO HIRE. THE
TARGETED INDIVIDUALS BUT WE DO
THINK THAT A MORE FUNDAMENTAL
RESTRUCTURING WOULD BE NEEDED.
TO PROVIDE A SUFFICIENT
INCENTIVE FOR BUSINESSES TO HIRE
INDIVIDUALS THOSE INDIVIDUALS A
TRULY FACE SIGNIFICANT BARRIERS
TO EMPLOYMENT SO.
WE'D RECOMMENDED.
THAT IF THE GOAL OF THIS CREDIT
IS TO BRING INDIVIDUALS THAT
FACE SIGNIFICANT BARRIERS TO
EMPLOYMENT INTO THE WORKFORCE.
PROVIDING A LARGER DOLLAR
AMOUNT TO THE LOWER WAGE.
WOULD BE I'M HELPFUL SO FOR
EXAMPLE IF YOU HIRE SOMEONE JUST
ABOVE MINIMUM WAGE ON THEIR THE
EMPLOYERS ONLY GOING TO BE
GETTING.
OF A FAIRLY SMALL AMOUNT.
TIRE THAT INDIVIDUAL AND.
YOU KNOW IF IF FIFTIES OR
INDIVIDUALS THAT ARE HAVING
TROUBLE ENTERING THE WORKFORCE
THEY MIGHT NEED SOMETHING MORE
IN THE LINE IF YOU HAVE SEVERAL
THOUSAND DOLLARS TO PROVIDE THAT
INCENTIVE TO. BRING THEM INTO
THE WORKFORCE.
AND.
AND IN THOSE LINES WE WE ALSO
RECOMMENDED.
YOU KNOW.
ALLOWING IT FOR YOU KNOW ALL
EMPLOYERS.
AND.
INTO MAYBE EVEN CONSIDERING PUT
PART TIME EMPLOYMENT BECAUSE FOR
SOME PEOPLE ENTERING THE
WORKFORCE.
THOSE THOSE INDIVIDUALS MIGHT
PREFER PART TIME POINT
SO ANYWAY I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS THANK YOU PICK
MILLION EXPLANATION WHY THE
ADMINISTRATION CHOSE AT. THE
RETAIL FOOD INDUSTRY FOR THE
EXPANSION OF THE CREDIT.
YEAH ARM SO SO IT WAS CONSIDERED
THOSE TWO INDUSTRIES WOULD
WOULD.
.
WOULD BRING IN THE MOST WOULD BE
THE MOST LIKELY TO BE HIRED
HIRING THESE INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE
WHO HAVE WHO ARE HARD HIGHER.
CARILLO.
YEAH I HAVE A HARD TIME.
AYE AYE. TOOK A LOOK AT THIS
AND.
.
THERE'S NO QUESTION WE NEED TO
FIGURE OUT HOW TO HIRE THE
HARDEST.
THE HARDEST TO HIRE
THE CHALLENGE WITH THE RETAIL IN
THE FOOD INDUSTRY IS YOU'LL END
UP WITH.
UNLESS THERE ARE LIMITATIONS THE
NATIONAL CHAINS THAT DON'T NEED
THESE KIND OF INCENTIVES IT'S
THE SAME THING AND LOCAL LAND
USE I JUST IT DRIVES ME CRAZY
WHEN THERE'S A TAX INCENTIVE FOR
A LOS TO COME INTO THE COMMUNITY
IT'S LIKE YOU KNOW WHAT THEY'LL
BUILD THERE IF THEY. WANT TO
ANYWAY SO I GUESS I'M I
UNDERSTAND THAT.
THE CONCEPT I GUESS I'D I JUST
I'M NOT I'M JUST NOT SURE.
I'M NOT SURE WE FIGURED OUT HOW
TO DO THIS TO INCENTIVIZE
BUSINESS FOR GROWTH ON UNLESS WE
DO SOMETHING THAT SAYS LOOK WHAT
WE REALLY WANT IN THIS STEVE
MANUFACTURING NOT MORE NOT MORE
RETAIL AND MORE FOOD. NOW AND I
DON'T KNOW HOW TO GET THERE AND
I IN PARTICULAR HAVE BEEN
CHALLENGING SOME OF THE GREEN.
AT TECH INDUSTRIES TO LOOK AT
MANUFACTURING BACK IN THE STATES
SO THAT WE CAN PUT PEOPLE INTO
JOBS THAT ARE LONG TERM. WHERE
WE'RE MAKING MAJOR INVESTMENTS
FOR AT FROM A STATE PERSPECTIVE?
UP AND WE HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY
TO INCENTIVIZE HE'S BUSINESSES
STARTING IN PRODUCING. THAT THE
PANELS FOR SOLAR. ENERGY THAT
YOU THE KINDS OF THINGS THAT ARE
GOING TO MAKE A DIFFERENCE AS WE
TRY TO GET RID OF GREENHOUSE
GAS.
BOB.
GREENHOUSE GASES SO ME I'M IN
RETAIL AND FOOD MAKES ME NERVOUS
BECAUSE I JUST I DON'T.
I DON'T SEE I DON'T THINK WE'RE
GONNA SEE THE MOM AND POP
HIRING.
S. FELONS IN SOME OF THE
CHRONICALLY UNEMPLOYED I THINK
IT'S GOING TO BE.
.
I LIKE TO THINK THAT THERE'S
SOMETHING WE CAN DO IN RURAL
CALIFORNIA THAT'S GOOD BECAUSE
THAT'S WHERE YOU HAVE THE
HIGHEST UNEMPLOYMENT RATES ARE
IN RURAL CALIFORNIA THAT THERE'S
SOMETHING THAT WE CAN DO THERE.
THAT PRODUCTION.
WE'LL WISE BOB WOULD CREATE
THOSE JOBS.
BUT I NEED TO THINK ABOUT IT.
I THINK IT IN AND I THINK TO THE
EXTENT THAT THOSE OF. OUR PAIN.
OUR PAIN HIGHER URBAN BUFFET
MUCH ABOVE THAT THE MINIMUM WAGE
THOSE OF THE WINTER THE
MANUFACTURERS ARE THE ONES.
HOME WHO WOULD BE MOST LIKELY TO
BENEFIT FROM THIS CREDIT.
BECAUSE HE OF REPAYMENT WAGE
THIS CREDIT IS NOT AND PROBABLY
HAVE BEEN.
SO WHAT GOAL SHOULD THE STATE
HIDING CREDIT CHIEF.
AND THAT THE GOALS REALLY ARE TO
ENCOURAGE THE HIRING OF THESE
INDIVIDUALS WHO WHO ARE HARD
HIGHER I MEAN. YEAH I IS
BASICALLY TO GET PEOPLE WHO.
OF OUR LONG TERM UNEMPLOYED HAVE
OTHER.
.
HER PERSONAL HISTORY THAT THAT
MAKE THEM HARD TO HIRE. TO BRING
THEM INTO THE WORKFORCE.
GIVE THEM.
WORKING SO THAT THEY HAVE A
RESUME AND MEN THAT THINK THEY
CAN MOVE ON TO OTHER JOBS
POTENTIALLY.
THE CURRENT HIRING CREDIT WAS
UNDER SUBSCRIBED SO WHY CREATING
NEW CREDIT. WENT LIVE THE
EXISTING CREDIT HIRING CREDIT
EXPIRE OR REDIRECT THE FUNDING
TO THEIR PROGRAM SUCH AS
CALIFORNIA COMPETES.
HOW WE REALLY FIT WLL I THINK
THE GOALS OF THE TOUR DIFFERENT
CALIFORNIA COMPETES IS REALLY
FOCUS ON BRINGING? A NEW JOBS TO
CALIFORNIA O. WHERE IS THE
HIRING CREDIT IS MORE FOCUSED ON
THE EMPLOYEE BEING HIRED. A A
AND THE INDIVIDUAL WHO HAS A.
CHARACTERISTICS WHERE THEY MAKE
THEM HARD TO HIGHER. SO I THINK.
WE WE STILL BELIEVE THAT GOAL
WITH WE THINK THOSE TWO GOALS
ARE DIFFERENT.
AND SO WHILE WE DO CERTAINLY
SUPPORT CALIFORNIA COMPETES IN
OUR IN OUR.
PROPOSING TO EXPAND A TO EXTEND
THAT.
WE THINK THAT THE THE GOALS OF
THE HIRING CREDIT ARE SEPARATE
FROM THAT AND ARE WORTHY GOALS
THAT.
THAT. WE WANT TO REMOVE SOME OF
THE LIMITATIONS.
THAT CURRENTLY EXIST AROUND
THAT
TO ME TOO SO THAT WOULD BE MORE
UTILIZED.
THANK YOU.
UPON OPEN UP PUBLIC COMMENT MANY
WISHES BECAUSE THIS ITEM.
KAEL CLOSE PUBLIC COMMENT RENAL
THIS ITEM OPEN.
WE WANT TO OUR NEXT ITEM ISSUE
NUMBER EIGHT OUR STAFFING
INCREASE
.
GOOD AFTERNOON I'M JUNIOR.
FRANCHISE TALKSPORT.
I'M TIFFANY LEASE FROM THE
FRANCHISE TAX BOARD.
SO WE HAVE THREE BCP'S FOR YOU
TODAY THE FIRST ONE IS TO
RECORDS TO A QUESTION BUT JUST
NOT FUNNY OF SEVEN POINT EIGHT
MILLION. TO AUGMENT THE FUNDING
COST FOR OUR WORKLOADS
ASSOCIATED WITH OUR AUDIT THIS
FUNDING REQUEST DOES NOT REQUEST
ADDITIONAL POSITIONS THAT ONLY
REQUEST FUNDING.
AFTER THE IS RECENTLY ENGAGED IN
SEVERAL STUDIES TO UNDERSTAND
THE INCREASING COMPLEXITY. AND
AUDIT WORKLOADS AS WELL AS OUR
EXISTING FUNDING LEVELS UP TO BE
MAKES GREAT EFFORTS TO ENSURE
OUR RESOURCES ARE UTILIZED TO
JUST THE BEST TO ADDRESS
NONCOMPLIANCE PROVIDE THE BEST
VALUE FOR THE STATE AND ENSURE
WE HAVE. AVOID ENGAGING AND
UNNECESSARY AUDIT WORK WHICH IS
BURDENSOME TO TAXPAYERS.
THE STUDY SHOWED TO CRITICAL
FACTORS BOTH OF WHICH ARE
DRESSED IN THIS PEACEKEEPING.
FIRST AFTER THE CONTINUES TO SEE
INTERESTING WILL CREASING
COMPLEXITY AND SOPHISTICATION
AND THE WORKLOADS THAT WE
PERFORM.
AS A RESULT OF THIS INCREASED
COMPLEXITY ATTRIBUTES A QUESTION
TO PERMANENTLY INCREASE THE
CLASSIFICATION LEVELS OF VARIOUS
POSITIONS TO PROGRAM SPECIALIST
TO AND PROGRAMS BUSLOADS THREE
OUR HIGHEST AUDIT
CLASSIFICATIONS.
THIS WILL PROBABLY ALIGN
EXISTING COMPLEX WORKLOADS WITH
THE APPROPRIATE WORKING LEVEL
AND SKILL LEVEL OF STAFF.
OF TO BE HAS ALREADY DONE MANY
OF THESE THREE CLASSIFICATIONS
AND THE RESULT HAS GENERATED
ALMOST A HUNDRED MILLION IN
ADDITIONAL REVENUE ANNUALLY.
OF TV IS STICKING FUNDING TO
ALLOW THESE UPGRADES TO BE
PERMANENT THAT STOPPING THE
FUNDING REQUEST ASSOCIATED WITH
A SIX FOUR POINT EIGHT MILLION.
THE SECOND COMPONENT OF THE B.
THREE P. REQUEST FUNDING TO
ADDRESS THE COMPENSATION
STRUCTURAL FUNDING ISSUE.
RELATED TO BASELINE FUNDING IN
THAT APARTMENT HOUSE ACTUAL
WAGES PAID.
MANY STOP CHOOSE TO PURSUE
CAREERS WITH HAVE TO BE AND A
BOX OF TO BE MISS STATE AND THEY
TEND TO REACH THE TOP STEP OF
THEIR SALARY RANGE.
AUDIT POSITIONS RECEIVE PRIOR TO
FISCAL YEAR TWO THOUSAND ONE TWO
THOUSAND TWO. ARE FUNDED AT THE
FIRST STEP OF THE SALARY RANGE
THIS IS A CALL THAT A SEVENTY
THREE PERCENT OF OF TV'S
POSITIONS.
HOWEVER THE REMAINDER TWENTY
SEVEN PERCENT ARE FUNDED AT MIT
STOP BUT TYPICALLY ARE THE LOWER
CLASSIFICATIONS THE AUDITOR'S
THE TALKS AUDITOR'S THE
ASSOCIATE TAX AUDITORS AND THE
PROGRAM'S POSSIBLES ONE
POSITIONS.
AS A RESULT OF THE STUDY OF TO
BE FOUND THAT THE MAJORITY IF
NOT ALL OF OUR PROGRAMS
SPECIALIST THREES ARE ACTUALLY
AT THE PIT STOP IN SPITE OF
BEING FUNDED AT THE FIRST STOP.
OF THE SALARY RANGE.
AFTER BE IS SEEKING FUNDING FOR
THE CLASSIFICATION OF THE TOP
STEP.
FOR THIS PROVINCE BUSES THREE
CLASSIFICATION FOR THE PROVINCE
MUST WAS TO OF TO BE FOUND THAT
ON AVERAGE EIGHTY PERCENT OF OUR
STAFF WERE AT THE TOP PAY SCALE
COMPARED TO THE FUNDING LEVEL AT
THE FIRST STEP UP TO THE HOUSE.
AFTER HE IS ASKING WITHIN THIS
BCP TO SEEK FUNDING TO ALLOW FOR
FIFTY PERCENT OF OUR PROVINCE
BUSES TO BE FUNDED AT THE TOP
STEP.
THAT'S REQUESTED CLUB WHICH IS
EQUIVALENT TO THREE MILLION
DOLLARS.
THIS POINT I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS YOU HAVE HONEST
BCP THANK YOU OIL.
YES SIR WE'RE NOT RAISING
CONCERNS OF THE PROPOSAL BUT.
AS DENOTED.
.
MANY OF THE DECISIONS AT FTP
WILL STILL BE FUNDED AT THE
FIRST STEP. POEM FURTHER IT IT
IS. NOT UNHEARD OF IT ALL BUT IT
IS UNCOMMON U
A LOT OF POSITIONS AT THE TOP
STEP. I'M IN THIS CASE GIVEN THE
SALARY LEVELS IT'S
IT'S PROBABLY JUSTIFIED TO DO
SO.
SO WE'RE NOT RAISING.
CONCERT AT THE PROPOSAL BUT WE
WANT TO MAKE YOU WEAR THE
CERTAINLY HAVE A LOT OF.
SOME OPTIONS HERE SO.
YOU KNOW IF THE IDEA IS TO FREE
UP FUNDING TO HIRE FILSON
VACANCIES CREATES A MORE. DO
MORE AUDITS AND CREATES MORE
REVENUE.
.
YOU COULD FUND THOSE POSITIONS
AT THE MID STEP AND HIRE FEWER
PEOPLE YOU COULD BRING OTHER
POSITIONS FROM FIRST STEP UP TO
MID STEP.
OR YOU AND YOU KNOW IT A LARGER
NUMBER OF EMPLOYEES ARE SMALL IN
NUMBER PLEASE AND ON. A VERY
DOLLARS TO GET TO ABOUT THE SAME
DOLLAR AMOUNT OR MORE LIST AND.
WHAT WHAT THE GOALS ARE?
FINANCE.
I DEPARTMENT FINANCE WERE IN
SUPPORT OF THIS.
PROPOSAL.
IT COMES WITH COMMITTEE.
ANY PUBLIC COMMENT.
OKAY REALISM OPEN NEXT ITEM
NUMBER NINE. ENTERPRISE DATA TO
REVENUE PROJECT.
THANK YOU THIS PROPOSAL ALSO
DEALS WITH THAT REQUEST ASKING
FOR TWENTY PERMANENT RESOURCES
TO MAINTAIN OUR EDR SYSTEM THEN
APPRAISE DATA TO REVENUE
PROJECTS SYSTEM.
WE CURRENTLY IN TWENTY FIFTEEN
SIXTEEN FISCAL YEAR HAD ASKED
FOR TWENTY PERMANENT POSITIONS
WHEN WE WERE NEARING THE END OF
THIS PROJECT.
HOWEVER DURING THE.
DURING THE OVERSEERS PROCESS OF
REVIEW THEIR REQUEST WAS TO PUT
THESE TO A THREE YEAR LIMITED
TERM ASSIGNMENT WITH THE
EXPECTATION THE CUMMOCK DURING
THIS TIME PERIOD AND JUSTIFY
THEIR ONGOING NEED.
THE POSITIONS HAVE BEEN CRITICAL
AND REMAIN CRITICAL AND CRUCIAL
FOR FCB IN REGARDS TO
MAINTAINING THE EPR SYSTEMS AND
APPLICATIONS.
TO DATE THOSE EATING OUR SYSTEMS
AND APPLICATIONS ARE IN FACT AND
RAIN THE ADDITIONAL ONE BILLION
ANNUAL REVENUE THAT WAS
COMMITTED TO DURING PROJECT.
NOW THAT THE MEDIA PROJECT HAS
ENDED WITHOUT THE CONTINUATION
OF THESE RESOURCES ACTUALLY BE
WILL BE JEOPARDIZED AND
MAINTAINING THEM SYSTEMS.
AFTER BE CURRENTLY HAS
REDIRECTED FORTY STOP
PERMANENTLY TO NEW ASSIGNMENTS
AS A RESULT OF THE CYSTIC THESE
NEW SYSTEMS.
WE'VE ALSO REDIRECTED PARTIALLY
ONE HUNDRED ADDITIONAL STOCK TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE CAN MAINTAIN
THE SYSTEMS THIS REQUEST FOR
TWENTY ADDITIONAL STUFF ROUNDS
OUT THE STOCK THAT WE BELIEVE
ARE NECESSARY TO MAINTAIN THESE
NEW SYSTEMS. AS WELL AS ENSURE
THAT OUR.
LEGACY SYSTEMS ARE MAINTAINED
AND SUPPORTED THIS POINT HAPPY
TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS YOU HOT
THANK YOU ELLIOTT.
HOME.
SO EDR WAS COMPLETED MORE OR
LESS ON TIME AND ON BUDGET HAS
ONGOING MAINTENANCE NEEDS AND WE
HAVE NO CONCERNS OF THIS
PROPOSAL.
FINANCE I SAW THIS RAT REQUEST
PROVIDES IT A FUNDING FOR
MAINTENANCE AND OPERATIONS AND
ONE SUPPORT THE PROPOSAL.
INCOMES THE COMMITTEE YES MISS
CARRIER. I JUST WANT TO SAY
THAT.
YOU KNOW THAT.
DEPARTMENTS HAVE TAKEN A LOT OF
GRIEF FOR.
.
THAT DATA SYSTEMS THAT REALLY
DON'T WORK AND THIS IS ONE
THAT'S BEEN TREMENDOUSLY
SUCCESSFUL SO CONGRATULATIONS ON
ON TIME ON BUDGET IS ON. IS A
REAL I THINK TESTAMENT TO THE UC
TO THE STAFF I JUST WANNA
UNDERSTAND THAT.
IT IT SOUNDS TO ME LIKE IF YOU
DIDN'T GET THESE AS A PERMANENT
AB AS PERMANENT POSITIONS THAT
YOU'D THIS WOULD BE A CONTRACT
THAT YOU'D BE ON. FORCED TO ON
ENGAGE AND ENERGY BRING PEOPLE
AND IN ORDER TO KEEP THE SYSTEM
RUNNING I'M IN MY UNDERSTANDING
THAT RIGHT.
THAT WOULD BE AN OPTION FIRST
THANK YOU FOR YOUR ON COMPLEMENT
CHARGE D'AFFAIRES VERY PROUD OF
THE EDEA PROJECT IN THE SUCCESS
OF ITS PLOT TO OF THE STATE.
SO IF WE ARE NOT ABLE TO OBTAIN
THE STUFF'S AN OPTION WOULD BE
TO CONTINUE CONTRACTING OUT
THESE SERVICES.
SO WE ARE NOT CONTRACTING OUT
THESE SERVICES TODAY WHAT WE ARE
CONTRACTING UT WHICH WILL CEASE
ON JUNE THIRTIETH OF TWENTY
EIGHTEEN IT THE KNOWLEDGE
TRANSFER ELEMENT FROM OUR
VENDOR.
AND WE ARE HOPING TO SEE THE
BACK OF THEM COME JUNE THIRTIETH
WHEN THEY ACCESS AND WE ARE NOW
HAVING TO MANAGE OUR OWN.
LEGACY SYSTEMS NEED SUPPORT. SO
IF WE DO NOT GET THOSE STUFF.
AND A CONTRACT IS NOT FEASIBLE
OR DESIRED THEN NOT REALLY COMES
DOWN TO THE POINT WHERE OUR
ORGANIZATION WILL BE SEVERELY
STRESSED TO MAKE SURE THAT. THE
SECURITY PATCHES ARE DONE IF
THERE'S A SYSTEM OUTAGE WERE
ABLE TO RESPOND VERY VERY
QUICKLY. AS YOU CAN IMAGINE IF
THE SYSTEM IS OUT THAT COULD BE
THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE SITTING IDLE
WAITING TO. HAVE IT FIXED AND
TURNED BACK ON VERY GOOD THANK
YOU SO MUCH I APPRECIATE THAT
AND I. I AM I RIGHT SUPPORT THAT
THE PROPOSAL BECAUSE OBVIOUSLY
ONCE WE BUILD THE SYSTEM WE GOT
MAINTAIN IT AND THAT'S
CRITICALLY IMPORTANT AND THE
ABILITY TO ACTUALLY DO IT IN
HOUSE.
IS ONE OF THE FEATURES THAT
WE'VE HAD WE HAVE.
HAVE NOT LOOKED AT HER NOT
REALLY SUFFICIENTLY PLANNED FOR
IN THE STATE AND SO WE'RE WE'RE
ALWAYS DOING PATCHES WITH
CONTRACTS IN TRYING TO BRING
PEOPLE INTO FIX THINGS UP SO.
REALLY APPRECIATE THAT FOCUS ON
ON HAVING IT.
WORK
AND BOMB TO THE EXTENT THAT THAT
THIS IS REVENUE THAT COMES INTO
THE STATE WE DEPEND ON IT TO
MAINTAIN SERVICES IT'S IMPORTANT
TO KEEP IT GOING SO THANK YOU
FOR THAT. OF HELENA EXCELLENT
COLLEAGUES COMMENTS I TOURED
WITH YOUR FACILITY ON THE SOME
MONTHS AGO. ISRAEL'S ARTICULATE
ISSUE WITH THE FOLKS THERE ARE
TWO FOLKS LIVE THERE TWENTY FOUR
HOURS A DAY AND OTHERS THAT.
THAT PAY DIFFERENTIAL IN.
WHEN THEY WERE ADDRESSED AT ALL
EXOTIC CURIOSITY.
I'M WE CONTINUE TO WORK WITH
COLLEGE TALK ON THAT ISSUE ON TO
DETERMINE IF THE APPROPRIATE
RESOLUTION IS THE PAY
DIFFERENTIAL OR SOME OTHER.
FEASIBLE SOLUTION.
OKAY HOPEFULLY WON'T BE A YEAR
FROM NOW AND IT STILL. WORKS.
SO THANK YOU WERE HOLDING OUT IN
THE OPEN.
AND.
NOTABLY NOPE.
PUBLIC COMMENT ON THIS.
WE WANT OUR NEXT ITEM ISSUE
NUMBER TEN.
INFORMATION TECHNOLOGY SECURITY
ENHANCEMENTS.
I AM VERY GOOD THING KILL ON FTP
SPINAL BZP REQUEST TWENTY THREE
POSITIONS AT A COST OF FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS AND EIGHTEEN
NINETEEN TO ENHANCE OUR EXISTING
SECURITY OPERATIONS. ATTRIBUTES
AND JUSTIN WITH MAINTAINING THE
CONFIDENTIALITY AND SECURITY OF
TAXPAYER INFORMATION AND WE TAKE
THIS RESPONSIBILITY VERY
SERIOUSLY.
AS WELL DOCUMENTED IN THE MEDIA
THE WORLD OF SECURITY EFFORTS
CONTINUE TO FALL AS THE INDUSTRY
SEEKS TO ADDRESS NEW EMERGING
THREATS. EITHER ASSOCIATED WITH
PHYSICAL TALKS OR A TOXIC THE
CYBER NATURE.
TO REMAIN VIGILANT IN THAT THE
FOR PRINT HAVE TO BE HAS
IDENTIFIED THE NEED FOR
ADDITIONAL STAFF RESOURCES AS
WELL AS AUTOMATED TOOLS TO
SUPPORT OUR EFFORTS.
I HAVE TO BE IS ALSO ESTABLISH
KEY PARTNER RELATIONSHIPS WITH
STAKEHOLDERS AT THE STATE LEVEL
TO ADDRESS CYBER CRIMES WHICH
HAS BEEN VERY VERY HELPFUL BUT
IN AND OF ITSELF SIR
INSUFFICIENT TO OFFER AN
APPROPRIATE LEVEL PROTECTION.
BEHIND THE FIREWALLS OF OF TO
BE.
THESE POSITIONS WILL ALLOW ACT
TO BE TO DO THE FOLLOWING
ESTABLISHED CLICK CONTINUOUSLY
OPERATIONAL SECURITY OPERATIONS
CENTER AND ESTABLISHES SECURITY
INTELLIGENCE PROGRAM. WHERE AND
STUFF WILL BE CONTINUE TO BE
RESPONSIBLE FOR EARLY DETECTION
OF CYBER ATTACKS AS WELL AS
MEDICATION?
ADDITIONALLY WILL PROVIDE
ADDITIONAL RESOURCES TO CONDUCT
REQUIRED SAFEGUARD REVIEWS OF
OUR DATA SHOWING PARTNERS AS
WELL AS REVIEWS ENSURING AFTER
B. ISN'T COMPLAINTS WITH FEDERAL
AND STATE MANDATES.
ADDITIONALLY THERE ARE STAFF
UPGRADE COSTS IN THIS BCP
ALLOWING AS TO BE TO ENSURE THAT
OUR STUFF LETTER BOOTS ON THE
GROUND TO MANAGE THIS HOW THE IN
FACT THE RIGHT SKILL SETS. UP
THE RIGHT CLASSIFICATION LEVEL
TO DO THIS WORK.
AND THEN LAST BUT NOT LEAST
THERE ARE SOME TOOLS IN HERE
THAT WILL HELP US BE ABLE TO
AUTOMATE OUR WORKLOAD AND BE
ABLE TO FOCUS ON THE MOST
CRITICAL RISK THAT IDENTIFIES.
THIS POINT HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS YOU HAVE.
IT IS RECRUITED XIN RETENTION
MINISH ISSUE FOR YOU GUYS AT
ALL.
DOES THE PAY.
THESE POSITIONS.
I THOUGHT IT ONE MORE TIME AS
RECRUITMENT AND RETENTION BE THE
ISSUE AT ALL.
SPECIFIC BECAUSE THE PAY. I
WOULD SAY NOT UNLADEN NOT AT
THIS POINT.
WE.
AGAIN OFTEN REFERRED TO KIND OF
ITS FINANCIAL INSTITUTIONS OF
SECURITY IS VERY EXTREME AND
THERE'S ALSO.
A LOT OF DESIRE TO WORK IN A
VERY HIGH RISK AREA. AND THWART.
CRIMINALS THAT ARE TRYING TO GET
INTO YOR SYSTEM AND ONE WAY OR
ANOTHER SO I THINK THAT LENDS US
TO HAVE A GOOD APPLICANT POOLS
WHEN WE ADVERTISE FOR THE JOB.
AND THEN AGAIN THE UPGRADES IN
THE CLASSIFICATIONS THAT ARE IN
HERE WHICH WOULD BE THE BEST
SKILLS SUCH THAT WE HOP HAS ALSO
SEARCHES. LITA RETENTION OF
EXISTING STOCK.
I THINK YOU LL.
WE HAVE NO CONCERNS WITH.
FINANCE.
THIS IS IN SUPPORT OF THE
PROPOSAL. ANY COLOR FOR THE
PUBLIC.
GIVEN ALL THIS ITEM OPEN AND
MOVE ON TO OUR NEXT ITEM OPEN
SORRY.
RUN ROBINETTE DEPARTMENT
TECHNOLOGY WE JUST WANT TO
EXPRESS SUPPORT FOR THIS REQUEST
AND.
.
TESTIFIED THAT THIS REQUEST IS
IN ALIGNMENT.
WITH THE STATE'S SECURITY
POLICY.
THANK YOU.
CABLETVINTERNET SADDAM.
I THINK YOU ISSUE ELEVEN.
.
CTF A CENTRALIZED REVENUE
OPPORTUNITY SYSTEM.
THAT AFTERNOON.
I'M KATIE HAGEN CHIEF DEPUTY
DIRECTOR CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT
OF TAX AND FEE ADMINISTRATION.
I'M. SINCE THE PASSAGE OF AB ONE
OH TO.
IN JULY OF TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN THE DEPARTMENT'S BEEN
FOCUSED ON TRANSITIONING MOST OF
BE OBESE PREVIOUS FUNCTIONS TO
SEE THE TFA.
THESE INCLUDE ADMINISTRATION OF
OVER THIRTY DIFFERENT TAX AND
FEE PROGRAMS.
AND AS YOU ARE WELL AWARE BO WE
FUNCTIONS NOW ARE LIMITED TO
STATE ASSESSED PROPERTY TAX
ADMINISTRATION OVERSIGHT OF
FIFTY EIGHT COUNTY ASSESSORS.
WHO ASSESSED PROPERTY TAX IN
THEIR RESPECTIVE COUNTIES?
ALCOHOL TAX AND INSURANCE TAX.
I AM CDT FAA AS.
COVERED EARLIER IN TESTIMONY.
PROVIDES VARIOUS ADMINISTRATIVE
SUPPORT SERVICES TO BE ARE WE.
I AM IF I GET.
JUST INTERJECT A COMMENT TO
EARLIER TESTIMONY FOR THE
LEGISLATURE'S INFORMATION AND
FRANNIE IMPACTED EMPLOYEES AT BO
WE THAT MIGHT BE LISTENING
TODAY.
I JUST WANTED TO CLARIFY ONE
POINT IN THAT.
ANYBODY THAT.
IS SUBJECT TO ON THEIR POSITION
BEING ELIMINATED IN STATE
SERVICE.
WOULD DEPEND ENTIRELY ON THEIR
EMPLOYMENT HISTORY.
DID.
TO DETERMINE WHERE THEY AND THAT
RATE SO IF THEY WERE HIRED OFF
THE STREET INTO AN EXEMPT
POSITION THEY ARE LIKELY GOING
TO HAVE RETURN RATES TO A CIVIL
SERVICE POSITION JUST LIKE HERE
IN THE LEGISLATURE.
HOWEVER IF THEY HAD.
BE PASSED PROBATION AT ANOTHER
STATE AGENCY ON THEN THEY WOULD
HAVE RETURNED RIGHTS IN ALL
LIKELIHOOD.
SO I AND IF
BE A WE DOES NO LONGER UTILIZES
THAT CLASSIFICATION IN WHICH
THEY HAVE RETURN RATES.
THEN WE WOULD WORK TO PUT PUT
THEM BACK INTO A DEPARTMENT THAT
UTILIZES THAT CLASSIFICATION IN
THAT WOULD LIKELY BE CD TFA IN
THIS CASE IF THEY CAME FROM
AUDIT POSITIONS.
SO I.
V. I AM.
THE POINT TO MY COMMENTS I WANT
TO REASSURE FOLKS THAT WE WOULD
FIND HOMES FOR PEOPLE WHO HAVE.
EMPLOYMENT RIGHTS AND BACK TO
THE STATE CALIFORNIA AND I WOULD
HAVE ALSO OFFERED TO MEET WITH
ANY EXEMPT EMPLOYEES. TO SHARE
RESOURCES ON HOW TO GAIN OTHER.
EMPLOYMENT OPPORTUNITIES INTO
THE STATE HOW TO TAKE EXAMS AND
THAT KIND OF THING. SO THAT THEY
COULD FIND ADDITIONAL JOB
OPPORTUNITIES
SO WITH THAT I WILL STICK IN MY
LANE.
AND GET PACKED MY COMMENTS ON
OUR PCP.
SO I WANTED TO JUST TAKE A
MINUTE.
IF I KNOW YOU'RE PROBABLY.
RUNNING SHORT ON TIME BUT I AM
I'D LIKE TO JUST TOUCH A LITTLE
BIT ON WHAT CD T. FAA'S
ACTIVITIES HAVE BEEN IN RECENT
MONTHS.
.
OUR TOP PRIORITIES INCLUDE
ENSURING CONTINUITY AN
IMPROVEMENT.
OF TAXPAYER EDUCATION AND OTHER
SERVICES ATTRACTING AND
RETAINING SKILLED EMPLOYEES AND
CHANGING THE DEPARTMENT'S
CULTURE TO MORE EFFICIENTLY
COLLECT TAXES.
THESE PRIORITIES HAVE US LOOKING
AT HARNESSING CROSSED THE
AUTOMATED PROJECTS WERE HERE'S
TO SPEAK TO TODAY. AND DATA
ANALYTICS FOR DATA DRIVEN
DECISION MAKING.
I'M WE'RE ALSO FOCUSING ON MERIT
BASED HIRING AN EMPLOYEE
TRAINING AND EMPHASIZING
INTERNAL CONTROLS PERFORMANCE
MEASURES REPORTING AND
MONITORING. UNDERLYING ALL OF
THESE SCHOOLS IS OUR DRIVE
TOWARDS ENTERPRISE LEVEL
MANAGEMENT
TO BREAK DOWN SILOS AND
INEFFICIENCIES.
OUT WERE SOME OF THE THINGS THAT
WE'RE CURRENTLY WORKING ON.
INCLUDE DEVELOPING A NEW
BUSINESS PLAN AND AT THAT
IDENTIFIES THE DEPARTMENT
SCHOOLS AND OBJECTIVES IN LIGHT
OF OUR PRIORITIES TO PROMOTE
CHANGE.
AND EXECUTIVE ACCOUNTABILITY WE
CONDUCT REGULAR ENTERPRISE RISK
MANAGEMENT TEAM MEETINGS TO
IDENTIFY AND PRIORITIZE THE
HIGHEST RISKS AND THEIR OWNERS
AND DEVELOP A PLAN OF ACTION TO
MITIGATE THOSE RISKS.
WE'VE DEVELOPED AN ANTI NEPOTISM
POLICY AND PROVIDED TRAINING IN
BEST PRACTICES FOR MERIT BASED
HIRING.
WE HAVE IMPLEMENTED OR BEGAN
IMPLEMENTATION FOR
RECOMMENDATIONS OUT OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE'S MISSION
BASED REVIEW.
I WE HAVE BEGIN PROCESS TO
ESTABLISH TWO NEW EXECUTIVE
POSITIONS UNDER OUR FIELD
OPERATIONS DEPUTY ONE WILL BE
RESPONSIBLE FOR AUDITS AND THE
OTHER IN COMPLIANCE.
WE ARE REVISITING AUDIT AND
COLLECTION POLICIES AS THEY
ARISE WHICH WILL BE AYE AIDED BY
THE TWO ADDITIONAL EXECUTIVES
THAT CAN ENSURE POLICIES ARE
APPLIED UNIFORMLY. AND A
FEEDBACK MECHANISM IS DEVELOPED
ON EXISTING POLICIES
FROM FIELD STAFF
WE'RE HOPING THAT THIS ACHIEVES
AT UNIFORMITY IN TAX
ADMINISTRATION ACROSS THE STATE.
WE'RE ALSO LOOKING AT THE.
RECOMMENDATIONS IN THE REPORT
ON.
AYE LOOKING AN ORGANIZATIONAL
STRUCTURE IN R. RANCHO CUCAMONGA
OFFICE AND POSSIBLY REPAIR TIES
IN THE WORK OF OUR
INVESTIGATIONS AND SPECIAL
OPERATIONS DIVISION AS
RECOMMENDED.
FINALLY WE ARE CONDUCTING AN IN
DEPTH STUDY TO DETERMINE HOW OUR
FIELD OFFICES SHOULD ULTIMATELY
BE STRUCTURED.
CONSISTENT WITH THE STRATEGIC
DIRECTION OF THE CD TFA.
OP AS YOU ARE WELL AWARE THE
TAXPAYER EDUCATION IS PARAMOUNT
TO EFFECTIVE TAX COLLECTION AS
MOST OF OUR REVENUE COMES TO US
VOLUNTARILY.
WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
TAXPAYERS HAVE ALL THE KNOWLEDGE
THEY NEED TO COMPLY WITH OUR TAX
LAWS.
TO THIS END FOR CALENDAR YEAR
TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN CT TFA IS
PLANNING UPWARDS OF FIVE HUNDRED
TAXPAYER EDUCATION EVENTS.
THIS INCLUDES DAYS NIGHTS AND
WEEKENDS FOR THE CONVENIENCE OF
BUSINESS OWNERS.
THIS NUMBER INCLUDES A HUNDRED
AND THIRTY EIGHT TAX SEMINARS
FIFTY FORCE SMALL BUSINESS FAIRS
A HUNDRED AND SIXTY EIGHT BUT
BASIC SALES AND USE TAX CLASSES.
ELEVEN TAX RETURN PREP CLASSES
IN EIGHTY SEVEN ONLINE E.
CLINICS.
BY CONTRAST THERE WERE A HUNDRED
AND EIGHTY THREE OUT REACH
EVENTS THAT WERE CONDUCTED IN
SIXTEEN SEVENTEEN.
I'M FINALLY I'VE BEFORE I HANDED
OVER TO SCOTT TO TALK ABOUT OUR
BE CP. I AM MOST FOLKS ARE
INTERESTED IN WHAT WE'RE DOING
WITH CANNABIS OUTREACH THAT
SEEMS TO BE THE TOPIC OF THE
YEAR. I'M WE'VE CONDUCTED THAT
DOZEN OR SO CANNABIS OUTREACH
EVENTS.
AND HAVE A MORE PLANNED
THROUGHOUT THE STATES AND WE
CONTINUE TO IDENTIFY THOSE
TRAINING NEEDS WEEKLY. IN
ADDITION TO THESE EVENTS WE HAVE
EXTENSIVE RESOURCES AVAILABLE
ONLINE AND CONDUCT REGULAR
OUTREACH.
UTILIZING SEVERAL SPECIAL
NOTICES THAT HAVE BEEN MAILED AN
EMAIL TO REGISTER TAXPAYERS AN
INDIVIDUALS WHO HAVE SIGNED UP
FOR OUR CANNABIS OUT REACH
LISTSERV.
ADDITIONALLY INFORMATION
ARTICLES HAVE BEEN PUBLISHED IN
OUR VARIOUS PUBLICATIONS AND
NEWSLETTERS.
WE.
ARE IN THE PROCESS OF FORMING A
CANNABIS ATTACKS ADVISORY GROUP
AS WELL. ITEMS CDFA HAS REACHED
OUT TO VARIOUS CANNABIS BUSINESS
OWNERS INDUSTRY SSOCIATIONS TAX
PRACTICE PRACTITIONERS AND CITY
AND COUNTY ASSOCIATIONS.
AND ASK THEM TO PROVIDE A
REPRESENTATIVE FROM THEIR AREA
OF EXPERTISE TO PARTICIPATE IN
THIS ADVISORY GROUP.
I IN WE'LL MEET PERIODICALLY TO
DISCUSS CANNABIS TAX ISSUES ARE
FIRST AT GROUP MEETING WITH
REPRESENTATIVES IS SCHEDULED FOR
APRIL NINETEENTH.
AND AT THAT I'D LIKE TO HAND IT
OFF TO SCHOOL.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN
SKYCAP ALONG PROJECT DIRECTOR
FOR THE CENTRALIZED FOR A NEW
OPPORTUNITY SYSTEM PROJECT.
I BEFORE I GO INTO THE PROJECT
STATUS IN OUR BCP REQUESTED JUST
WON'T GIVE SOME BACKGROUND ON
HER PROJECT OBJECTIVES AND THE
PROJECT SOLUTION IN YOUR FOREVER
YOU BE APPRECIATED TOO SIR.
SO THE OBJECTIVES FOR THIS
PROJECT.
WERE TO REPLACE ARE OUTDATED A
LEGACY SYSTEMS THAT WERE
DEVELOPED IN THE NINETEEN
NINETIES.
TO CREATE A CUSTOMER CENTRIC
SOLUTION. DECREASE OUR TAX GAP.
RE ENGINEERING IMPROVE PROGRAM
PROCESSES.
THE PROJECT SOLUTION.
WE AWARDED A FIXED PRICE
CONTRACT TO FAST ENTERPRISES IN
AUGUST TWENTY SIXTEEN AND THE
AMOUNT OF EIGHTY FIVE POINT ONE
MILLION DOLLARS.
THAT SOLUTION INCLUDED A
COMMERCIAL OFF THE SHELF
PRODUCT.
CALLED GEN TAX WHICH IS IN USE
IN TWENTY FIVE DEPARTMENT OF
REVENUE IN THE UNITED STATES.
THE SOLUTION PROVIDES DATA
WAREHOUSE AND DATA ANALYTICS
CAPABILITIES. GREATER ACCESS TO
DATA. OPPORTUNITIES FOR REVENUE
GENERATION.
OUR VENDOR PROJECTS THAT THE.
SOLUTION WILL INCREASE REVENUE
OF THREE HUNDRED THIRTY FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS OVER THE NEXT
SIX YEARS.
OUR CURRENT PROJECT STATUS WE
ARE ON SCHEDULE AND ON BUDGET TO
IMPLEMENT HER FIRST PRODUCTION
ROLLOUT IN MAY NEXT MONTH.
THAT WILL INCLUDE THE SALES AND
USE TAX AND RELATED FEE
PROGRAMS.
THIS PHASE OF THE PROJECT
REPRESENTS THE BIGGEST PHASE.
WHICH INCLUDES OUR LARGEST
TAXPAYER BASE AND THE NUMBER OF
USERS APPROXIMATELY ONE POINT
FIVE MILLION TAX AND FEE PAIRS
OR NINETY PERCENT OF OUR.
TAXPAYERS AND FORTY THOUSAND
AMPLE OF SORRY EXCUSE ME FOUR
THOUSAND EMPLOYEES WHICH IS
EIGHTY FIVE PERCENT OF OUR
DEPARTMENT.
WE'RE CURRENTLY FINISHING THE
LAST PHASE OF OUR TESTING IN
DATA CONVERSION ACTIVITY.
AS WELL AS CONDUCTING TRAINING
FOR STAFF.
WE'RE CONTINUING ORGANIZATIONAL
CHANGE MANAGEMENT ACTIVITIES TO
PROMOTE USER ADOPTION.
AND MAKING PREPARATIONS FOR OUR
NEXT ROLLOUT WHICH INCLUDES
TWELVE ADDITIONAL SPECIAL TAX
AND FEE PROGRAMS.
THAT'S SCHEDULED TO IMPLEMENT IN
APRIL OF TWENTY NINETEEN.
OUR FINAL RULE OUT WILL BE
IMPLEMENTED IN MAY OF TWENTY
TWENTY THE REQUESTED.
IS TO REQUEST SEVENTY POINT ONE
MILLIONDOLLARS WHICH INCLUDES
FENDER COMPENSATION PAYMENTS OF
APPROXIMATELY FIFTY TWO MILLION
DOLLARS.
AND ALLOWS OUR PROJECT TO
CONTINUE WITH THE IMPLEMENTATION
PHASE FOR THE REMAINING TAX AND
FEE PROGRAMS ADMINISTERED BY THE
DEPARTMENT.
I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE THANK YOU
HELLO.
WE WOULD JUST HIGHWAY AND THE
DEPARTMENTS.
COMING ABOUT THE NEXT ROLL OUT
IN THE TIMING OF THAT BEING IN
MAY THAT SO AT THAT COULD
INDICATE THE MAY REVISION
HEARINGS MIGHT. BE AN IDEAL
OPPORTUNITY TO CHECK AND FOR
MORE OVERSIGHT. FINANCE.
ONE SPORTS PROPOSAL. THEY'RE
GONNA OVERSIGHT OF OPEN.
NEXT ITEM.
TWELVE BUDGET OVERVIEW.
THE TAX BILLS
PLEASE BEGIN.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN COOPER.
MY NAME IS MARK I'VE WON THE
DIRECTOR OF THE OFFICE OF TAX
APPEALS AND WITH ME ON MY
COLLEAGUES TO MY RIGHT.
THEORY GRADY AND THE CHIEF
DEPUTY DIRECTOR.
JUSTIN CAME AND THE CHIEF.
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
COME BEFORE YOU TODAY AND.
WERE PREPARED TO GIVE A SHORT
PRESENTATION OVERVIEW OF OUR
STATUS AFTER A HUNDRED DAYS OF
BEING EXISTENCE.
.
WE ARE.
THE THEMES THAT YOU'LL FIND IN
THIS BRIEF PRESENTATION HAVE TO
DO THE OBJECTIVITY THE
TRANSPARENCY AND ACCESSIBILITY
OF THE OFFICE OF TAX APPEALS.
OR OTA. AND OUR GOAL IS AS SET
FORTH IN LEGISLATION.
TO PROVIDE A VENUE FOR IMPARTIAL
HEARINGS WITH OPINIONS BASED ON
LAW AND EVIDENCE.
AND. INSTILL A CONSISTENT A
TREATMENT OF LAW OVER TIME.
I'VE HANDED OUT A. A PACKET OF
INFORMATION THAT WE. ARE ON THE
LEFT SIDE IS SOME PROMOTE.
INFORMATION MATERIAL FOR
TAXPAYERS AND ON THE RIGHT SIDE
OR SOME OF THE ORGANIZATIONAL
CHARTS INSTANT.
DISTRICTS THAT WILL BE REFERRING
TO AND OUR PRESENTATION.
SO.
THE THE STRUCTURE THE OFFICE IS
SET FORTH IN AB ONE OUT TO.
AND AB ONE THIRTY ONE FROM LAST
YEAR.
IS REFLECTIVE OF THE ACHIEVING
THIS GOAL THAT I IDENTIFY JUST
PREVIOUSLY.
WERE INDEPENDENT FOR THE TAX
AGENCY'S WERE INDEPENDENT FROM
THE AGENCY TO WHICH THE TAX
AGENTS REPORT.
WE'VE REPORT TO THE DRY OUT
DIRECTLY TO THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE WE HAVE OBJECTED PANELS
OF ADMINISTRATIVE LAW JUDGES.
THAT MAKE JUDGMENTS ON APPEALS
BEFORE THE OTA.
DECISIONS BY THESE PANELS ARE
NOT SUBJECT TO APPROVAL BY
ANYBODY ELSE IN THE OFFICE.
THERE'S NO EX PARTE
COMMUNICATION.
AND IF YOU LOOK AT THE
ORGANIZATIONAL.
.
SHEET IN YOUR PACKET WHICH HAS
THE BLUE SQUARES.
WHAT WE'VE DONE IN TERMS THE
ORGANIZATION ALSO REFLECTS THIS
INTENT TO BE A INDEPENDENT WE
HAVE A SELF CONTAINED LEGAL TEAM
IN ADDITION TO OUR LJ IS? THAT
DOES ALL THE LEGAL ANALYSIS FOR
ALL THE CASES WE DON'T RELY ON
THE LEGAL ANALYSIS.
FROM THE TAX AGENCY'S.
THERE'S NO SIGNIFICANT.
AUTHORITY LODGE WITH ANYONE
PERSON THE ORGANIZATION HAS
CHECKS AND BALANCES
SO IN FOR EXAMPLE THE HEARING
DIVISION IS OVERSEEN BY BOTH THE
DIRECTOR AND THE CHIEF COUNSEL.
I DID WANT TO MENTION A FEW
THINGS IN TERMS OF WHAT WE'RE
DOING WITH RESPECT TO THE
ACCESSIBILITY. AND TRANSPARENCY
OF THE OFFICE WE TAKE.
BOTH OF THOSE VERY SERIOUSLY AND
WE WANT TO BE ACCESSIBLE TO
TAXPAYERS WE WANT TAXPAYERS TO
PEEL VERY COMFORTABLE REPRESENT
THEMSELVES. OR RELYING ON NON
EXPERT REPRESENTATION WE INTEND
TO USE VERY STRAIGHTFORWARD
ENGLISH LANGUAGE.
WITHOUT WRITTEN.
RELYING ON OVERLY AT A.
TECHNICAL LEGALLY IS AND SO
FORTH TO MAKE IT ACCESSIBLE.
OUR THE CHIEF COUNSEL'S GOING TO
TALK A LITTLE BIT MORE ABOUT
HEARINGS IN A BIT.
.
WE WANT TO PROVIDE. ADDITIONAL
EASE OF INFORMATION TO OUR TO
TAXPAYERS ARE APRIL HEARINGS
WILL BE WEBCAST.
.
WHICH WE HAD OF THAT LITTLE BIT
OF A DIFFICULT TIME GETTING THAT
UP AND RUNNING BUT THAT WILL BE
RUNNING IN APRIL. WERE WORKING
WITH.
KALINJAR ON A TRANSLATION PLAN
FOR VARIOUS PUBLICATIONS THAT
WERE IN THE PROCESS OF DOING.
AND WILL BE.
WORKING ON MORE FOR PUBLICATION
PROGRAM AS WE FLESH OUT OUR
COMMUNICATIONS TEAM.
I'M.
IN TERMS OF AN OUTREACH PLAN
WE ARE WORKING ON A
STRATEGIC PLAN FOR OUTREACH BUT
IN LIEU OF THAT WE'VE DONE
SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT OF OUTREACH
WITH.
DIFFERENT GROUPS ON SORT OF AN
AD HOC BASIS INCLUDING BARS
SENSATION.
THE CALIFORNIA TAX POLICY
CONFERENCE WE WERE AT THE CAL
TAX ANNUAL CONFERENCE.
AND WILL BE REACHING OUT TO
ADDITIONAL.
INDUSTRY GROUPS.
NOW I'M IN A TURNED OVER TO THE
CHIEF DEPUTY.
THEORY GRADY WHO'S GONNA GET.
MORGAN ADELINE HIM WHERE WE ARE
IN TERMS OF OUR BUDGET OUR
FACILITIES AND SO FORTH.
GOOD AFTERNOON
I'M GONNA GIVE YOU A LITTLE
OVERVIEW OF OUR OFFICES IN THE
STATUS.
AS YOU KNOW WE HAVE THREE
OFFICES THAT WE ARE ARE
CURRENTLY OVERSEEING SACRAMENTO
IS UP AND RUNNING.
WE HAVE A HEARING ROOM THAT WE
HAVE ACCESS TO BY WORKING
COLLECTIVELY WITH THE VICTIMS
COMPENSATION BOARD. A WERE
EXPECTING TO HAVE TO HAVE OUR
OWN HEARING ROOMS AT THIS
FACILITY ONCE THEY'RE BUILT OUT.
WE ARE WORKING WITH.
.
OUR OF FACILITIES PLANNING.
TO HAVE THAT BUILT OUT.
IN THE NEXT NINE TO TWELVE
MONTHS.
ALSO FOR THE PRESENT LOCATION
IT'S BEEN SECURED THE LEASES
BEEN SIGNED.
THIS IS GOING TO BE IN ON STAFF
SPACE.
WE EXPECT TO HAVE ABOUT THREE
HOTEL IN OFFICES.
STAFF FROM THE SACRAMENTO
LOCATION ARE EXPECTED TO TO
DRIVE DOWN TO THAT LOCATION TO
OFFER HEARING DAYS.
WE'RE EXPECTING THAT THAT
OFFICE WILL BE COMPLETELY BUILT
OUT IN OCTOBER.
AND THAN FOR OUR LOS ANGELES
LOCATION.
WE HAVE TEMPORARY SPACE THAT
WE'VE RETAINED RIGHT NOW WE'RE
CURRENTLY WORKING WITH DG ES TO
FINALIZE THE LEASE AND TO ALLOW
US ACCESS TO THAT FACILITY'S SO
WE CAN START HERE.
HEARING CASES THEY'RE A WERE
ALSO WORKING WITH THE GS TO LOOK
FOR MORE PERMANENT SPACE AND
SOME OF THE OUTLYING AREAS WERE.
TAKEN INTO CONSIDERATION.
PRICING FOR RENT PARKING AND
ALSO OF THE ABILITY TO
ACCOMMODATE OUR NEED FOR HEARING
ROOMS.
AS FAR AS OUR HIRING AND
STAFFING.
WE HAVE THE EIGHTY AUTHORIZED
POSITIONS.
EIGHT OF THOSE POSITIONS WERE
TRANSFERRED FROM THE BOARD OF
EQUALIZATION TWENTY TWENTY FOUR
WERE TRANSFERRED FROM THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT. OF TAX
AND FEE ADMINISTRATION TOTALING
FORTY EIGHT POSITIONS.
OUT WE HAVE A TOTAL OF FORTY
NEW POSITIONS ARE ADDED AS WELL.
OF THE FORTY EIGHT NEW POSITIONS
WE HAVE SIX THAT ARE EXEMPT THE
DIRECTOR CHIEF DEPUTY CHIEF
COUNSEL THE LEGISLATIVE DEPUTY.
COMMUNICATIONS DEPUTY AND
ADMINISTRATIVE ASSISTANT.
OUR SALARIES ARE DETERMINED BY
PRIOR BE OF THE NCD TFA
SALARIES.
AND THE REQUIREMENTS FOR
ADMINISTRATIVE LAW JUDGES AND
EXEMPT ADDITIONS ARE SET BY THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE.
AS OF MARCH.
WE HAVE ABOUT FIFTY FIVE
POSITIONS THAT HAVE BEEN FILLED
OUR GOAL IS TOCOMPLETELY FILL
OUT THE REST OF ARE POSITIONS
THAT ARE AUTHORIZED BY JUNE OF
TWENTY EIGHTEEN.
WE STILL HAVE SOME KEY POSITIONS
THAT WERE TRYING TO FILL.
INCLUDING THE COMMUNICATIONS
DEPUTY AND SEVERAL I'M
ADMINISTRATIVE LAW JUDGES.
AS FAR AS POLICIES AND
PROCEDURES ARE CONCERNED. FOR
OVERALL GOVERNANCE OF THE AGENCY
AND ITS PRACTICES WERE WORKING.
TO ENSURE THAT ALL OF OUR OFFICE
ATTACKS APPEAL ADMINISTRATIVE
PROCEDURAL FISCAL POLICIES AND
MANUALS ARE BEING DEVELOPD AND
COMMUNICATED AND SET IN PLACE.
AND THE LAST IN TERMS OF OUR.
OFFICE BUDGET FOR CURRENT YEAR.
OFFICE OF TAX APPEALS IS
OPERATING WITHIN THE ESTABLISH
RESOURCES. OF OUR FIVE MILLION
DOLLAR APPROPRIATION AS SET
FORTH IN AB ONE OF TWO. AND A
TWO POINT TWO MILLION THAT WAS
TRANSFERRED TO S. B. AT THE
BOARD OF EQUALIZATION AND CD
TFA.
FOR THE CURRENT YEAR THE
RESOURCES ARE AND DISTRIBUTED
FOR THE BUDGET YEAR
APPROXIMATELY NINETEEN POINT
NINE MILLION WILL BE SPLIT.
ELEVEN POINT FIVE MILLION OF
THAT WILL BE USED FOR PERSONNEL
COSTS AND EIGHT POINT FOUR
MILLION FOR. ONLY ANY EXPENSES.
ALMOST ABOUT THREE POINT ONE
MILLION.
IS ONE TIME PLUS ONGOING OF OWE
YOU NEED.
I WERE EXPECTED TO SPEND THAT ON
FACILITIES OPERATIONS LEASES TEN
IMPROVEMENTS IN SOME MIGHTY
BECAUSE.
THANK YOU OIL.
NO CONCERNS
FINANCE.
SUPPORT THE BUDGET.
AB MEMBERS THE PUBLIC WISHING TO
SPEAK.
THIS INFORMATION IS I WAS
HEARINGS FOR INFORMATION ONLY.
ITS HEARINGS ADJOURNED THANK
YOU